hello everyone
welcome to this data scientist full
course video by simplyloan
data scientists are professionals who
utilize their skills to analyze
visualize and find trends in the data
they uncover solutions
to business challenges by creating
models and generating insights
in this video we will cover all the
important data science concepts
skills and careers that will help you
become a successful data scientist
but before we get started please make
sure to subscribe to the simply loan
channel
to learn new technologies and up skill
yourself
we will start by understanding the
basics of data science with a short
animated video
and look at data science life cycle and
its applications
we will then see the different python
libraries for data science such as numpy
and pandas
next we focus on learning the crucial
algorithms used in data science for
solving specific
problems next we'll look at linear
regression
logistic regression decision trees
support vector machines
as well as some reinforcement learning
algorithms
after that we'll see the data science
job roles and responsibilities
the skills that you need to possess and
understand how to build a data science
engineer resume
finally you'll get an idea about the top
data science
interview questions that are often asked
in any job interview this includes
programming sql statistics machine
learning
as well as some scenario based questions
so let's get started with understanding
data science with a short animated
introduction
are you one of the many who dreams of
becoming a data scientist
keep watching this video if you're
passionate about data science because we
will tell you
how does it really work under the hood
emma is a data scientist
let's see how a day in her life goes
while she's working on a data science
project
well it is very important to understand
the business problem first
in our meeting with the clients emma
asks relevant questions
understands and defines objectives for
the problem that needs to be tackled
she is a curious soul who asks a lot of
eyes one of the many traits of a good
data scientist
now she gears up for data acquisition to
gather and scrape data from multiple
sources like web servers
logs databases apis and online
repositories
oh it seems like finding the right data
takes both
time and effort after the data is
gathered comes data preparation
this step involves data cleaning and
data transformation
data cleaning is the most time consuming
process as it involves handling
many complex scenarios here emma deals
with inconsistent data types
misspelled attributes missing values
duplicate values
and whatnot then in data transformation
she modifies the data
based on defined mapping rules in a
project etl tools like talent and
informatica
are used to perform complex
transformations that helps the team to
understand the data structure better
then understanding what you actually can
do with your data is very crucial
for that emma does exploratory data
analysis
with the help of eda she defines and
refines the selection of feature
variables that will be used in the model
development but
what if emma skips this step she might
end up choosing the wrong variables
which will produce an inaccurate model
thus exploratory data analysis becomes
the most
important step now she proceeds to the
core activity of a data science project
which is data modeling she
repetitively applies diverse machine
learning techniques like
canon decision tree knife base to the
data
to identify the model that best fits the
business requirement
she trains the models on the training
data set and test them
to select the best performing model emma
prefers python for modeling the data
however it can also be done using r and
sas
well the trickiest part is not yet over
visualization
and communication emma meets the clients
again to communicate the business
findings in a simple and effective
manner to convince the stakeholders
she uses tools like tableau power bi and
clickview that can help her in creating
powerful reports and dashboards and then
finally
she deploys and maintains the model she
tests the selected model in a
pre-production environment
before deploying it in the production
environment which is the best practice
right after successfully deploying it
she uses reports
and dashboards to get real-time
analytics
further she also monitors and maintains
the project's performance
well that's how emma completes the data
science project
we have seen the daily routine of a data
scientist is a whole lot of fun
has a lot of interesting aspects and
comes with its own share of challenges
now let's see how data science is
changing the world
data science techniques along with
genomic data provides a deeper
understanding of genetic issues in
reaction to particular drugs
and diseases logistic companies like dhl
fedex have discovered the best rules to
ship the best suited time to deliver
the best mode of transport to choose
thus leading to cost efficiency
with data science it is possible to not
only predict
employee attrition but to also
understand the key variables that
influence employee turnover also the
airline companies can now easily predict
flight delay and notify the passengers
beforehand to enhance their travel
experience
well if you're wondering there are
various roles offered to a data
scientist
like data analyst machine learning
engineer
deep learning engineer data engineer and
of course data scientist
the median base salaries of a data
scientist can range from
95 000 to 165 000
so that was about the data science are
you ready to be a data scientist
if yes then start today the world of
data
needs you so what is data science data
science is the field of study that deals
with modern
scientific techniques statistical
methods
and algorithms to derive insights from
vast volumes
of data companies using data science
are very numerous with companies
generating data
every minute there is a need to make
sense of this data
mu sigma fractal fidelity
intel jim pact cubela
amazon trendins connect the dots
just about every business out there
nowadays uses some form of data science
even if it's indirectly to help govern
their business
and help them growth and compete in the
business world and we use the data
science to find
unseen patterns within the data analyze
and draw
insights from our data and solve
business problems and make decisions
and the data science has a life cycle
we start with our data discovery then we
go through data preparation
exploratory data analysis data modeling
interpret the results and back to data
discovery
we talk about data discovery data
discovery involves asking the right
questions identifying the business
problems
finding the best solution and gathering
correct data from relevant
sources for analysis
this is in the data science life cycle
the most important step
now in general it only involves like a
small percentage of the time you spend
on this
but if you're not asking the right
questions you can't go in the right
direction
data preparation data preparation deals
with cleaning the data
finding the inconsistencies tackling
missing values converting it into the
right format and making it ready for
analysis
when i'm running the data science life
cycle this is probably where the most
time is spent
data can be so messy
you have to break it down into different
parts you have to import the different
pieces from different databases
are you dealing with straight numbers
off of spreadsheets and cells
or are you dealing with text documents
and natural tokenite language
tokenization
exploratory data analysis analyze and
visualize the data using different
charts and graphs to find significant
patterns
and hidden trends that helps to
understand the data better
the building of the charts is very
creative
probably one of the more enjoyable parts
is be able to come in there and describe
the data
and show that to the shareholders then
we dive into data modeling
use classification regression and
clustering algorithms to build machine
learning models
that can help predict and forecast
future trends
this is where we start getting into
predictions
what's next where's it going to go and
then interpret the results
validate the model results draw the
final conclusion and check if the
performance of the model is in line
with the requirements the final step is
the one that you set up in front of the
board members and give them suggestions
as to what's next where we're going to
spend our marketing money
where are we going to start preparing
our firefighters for the next fire
breaks next year
what is the weather patterns coming in
this is where you interpret the results
and say how accurate they are
are they valid is it something we're
going to keep are we going to throw it
out and have to start over
we look at data science components is
the mathematics
statistics domain expertise
data engineering data visualization
and machine learning when we sum this up
in data science
really this point
in all of this you want to focus on
first is domain
expertise now when you're taking your
classes obviously you want to go through
the mathematics the statistics the data
engineering the data visualization the
machine learning and learning all those
tools
but it really in the job field the
domain expertise comes in
because if you're really good with
business and you go into business with
these tools
then you're able to ask the right
questions and deal with it
when we talk about the tools in data
science and where they sit
there is a data analysis data analysis
focuses
more on statistics and mathematics where
the data science size
where the data science side focuses more
on the machine learning data
visualization
and then there's database management
which really focuses on the data
engineering part of it and how to manage
that data in the data flow
and you see all these components come
together and then they form the data
science
and we talk about tools in data science
we have sas we have matlab we have sql
you have your apache spark your r tab
blue
python right now in the programming
languages
python is probably the most widely used
with r coming in a close second
the reason for that is these are both
open source and anybody can use them
we look at sas and tabloo those are two
packages that are paid for
which have a lot of automation behind
them so a lot of the larger companies
will pay for those packages
because they help work out a lot of the
the back end stuff before you even need
to use them
and of course we have apache spark you
almost have to know apache spark in the
growing data
lakes today that's your big data how do
you distribute this if you're going to
process it over a large amount of data
we look at data science applications
there's internet search
very common you enter your google thing
and it uses the data science
algorithms to figure out what to return
voice assistance
analyzing the voice coming in and
connecting it with whatever patterns
they need
to activate so you can ask it to turn
your lights on in the living room
healthcare biggest field growing right
now how do we analyze health data from a
smart watch
and figure out how to know when a
disease is being
spread across the world health care how
do we identify
cancer versus non-cancer so we know who
to prioritize and get him in for surgery
where other people might not need that
immediate care and even identifying
problems somebody might have with their
health long before they even happen
what a neat thing to do instead of
waiting until you have a heart attack
to know months ahead of time that you're
having heart conditions
logistics how do we get from point a to
point b
if you ever look at some of the major
distributors they pre-ship things based
on what they guess
people are going to need this way you
get your stuff right in the mailbox the
day after you order it
e-commerce huge in there because you
have to know
what kind of marketing we're going to
put out who are we selling to what's our
target audience
robotics one of the funner ones when
you're coming up into the future is how
do we automate
the different tasks we have from
self-driving cars
to manufacturing lines to
maybe even a self-robotic chef in the
kitchen
so we talk about solving problems with
data science
we have to ask possible questions and
the desired algorithms
and these really are uh kind of an
overview of some of the terminology
you'll want to know
in data science so we talk about that
how much or how many
we're talking about regression
regression basically means a number
if you've ever seen stock charts you see
the guess at what the next sales price
is or buy
price is that's all on your regression
side
is it a or b classification
is that a dog or a cat that my photo
took a picture of
how is this organized clustering this is
where we take things that look alike and
put them together so that we can then
make predictions on it
how difference is this just like you
have clustering you have the opposite
anomaly detection how do we find things
that don't fit in where are the outliers
what are things we might need to look at
that aren't in our model
and what to do next reinforced learning
this is probably the newest market is
how do we set something up whereas the
data comes in
it learns from the new data as to what
the next action is going to take
most of these are combined so when we
talk about regression classification
clustering
anomaly detection reinforced learning a
lot of times when you put your model
together you might have
multiple parts of this we might look at
the clustering of data
and then feed it into a classification
is this a
bad loan to make it the bank or is this
a good loan to give
and from there we might start looking at
when we start clustering these things as
good and bad and what kind of
setup is we then might run it through a
regression model to say hey what is the
amount dollar amount this person
should be allowed to take a loan out and
you can see that all of these start
coming in
and then a lot of the models reinforce
learning
we talk about like bank loans and things
like that once a year
they have to rerun those algorithms and
so that's like a human run
reinforced learning now we're starting
to automate that so that as the data
comes in real time
the models start updating themselves
they start figuring out a way to solve
new problems
as they occur and of course in robotics
reinforced learning is one of the
biggest growing fields
logarithms used in data science linear
regression
logistic regression when you're looking
at both of these
uh think numbers we're talking
regression models
and so linear regression figures out the
best line through the data
maybe it's looking for a curved line
logistic regression starts looking at
data
on a continuum so that
it goes to an exponential you have a
spot where it might be one or the other
and then you know what it is as it goes
to one side or the other
decision tree wonderful tool
if you used to call it a hack now it's
becoming mainstream
to look at the back end what made the
decision so it's really easy to trace
back
to how you arrived at the decision
decision trees are kind of nice that way
nearest neighbors k nearest neighbors is
your clustering k means clustering
hierarchical clustering so hierarchical
starts dividing them
and builds a hierarchy where the k-means
and the k-nearest neighbor
look for things that kind of connect
each other how close are they
in data format db scan
another form of clustering your data
principle component analysis
so we start breaking up and looking at
the different components in our data
coming in
these are all algorithms used in data
science and there are more
these are kind of the mainline ones and
each one of these has many settings
which you can play with
to build a better model to predict your
data and where you want it to go
so let's now talk about the difference
between business intelligence and data
science
now business intelligence was one of the
initial phases where people started
making or
wanted to make some sense out of data so
for some of you who may not be aware
there were multiple phases of this it
revolution so initially there was all
automations you had automation of your
selling process manufacturing process
you had your erp systems
your crm systems and and so on uh which
are basically
enterprise resource planning and
customer relationship management erp and
crm
and all these enterprise applications
were generating a lot of data so then
people started
saying that okay we need to understand
or get some
information out of this data so that's
how business
intelligence started so if we take from
a
data source perspective let's compare
these from
with each of these criteria the criteria
are what is the data source what is the
method what are the skills and what is
the focus
now if we compare business intelligence
with data science this is how it looks
as far as the data source is concerned
business intelligence was primarily
using structured data
so you had all your enterprise
applications like erp
crm and so on and they were working out
of
pretty much rdbms relational database
management systems
like oracle or mssql mysql and so on
so all this data was structured in neat
form
form of tables rows and columns and then
they were all brought into
a centralized place because remember
these were still
different applications so they were
working off
different databases in silos so if you
wanted to get a
combined view you needed to create what
is known as a data warehouse
and bring all this data together and
then
look at it in a uniform way so this is
what business intelligence was doing
pretty much it was structured data
and it had reports and dashboards that
was
pretty much of what was there in
business intelligence now with the data
science
in addition to structured data we also
use a lot of unstructured data example
web blogs or
comments if we are talking about
customer feedback there is a structured
part there is an unstructured part where
people write free text
data science includes that as well and
brings everything
and then performs analysis so data
source wise that is the different
methods in business intelligence pretty
much it is
analytical in the sense that okay you
have some data
we are just trying to present the truth
and mostly
what has happened historical data that's
it in case of data science
we go beyond that we go deeper in terms
of
finding why a certain behavior has
occurred
and also go beyond just providing a
report there is a
deeper statistical analysis that is done
that is what is the scientific part
and deeper insights are gathered not
just reporting
so that's from a method perspective from
a skills perspective
business intelligence needs a little bit
of statistics
but more of visualization because they
primarily consisted of dashboards or
they primarily consist of dashboards
and reports whereas in data science the
visualization of course is there
but there is a lot more of statistics
involved because we are looking
at things like correlation we are
looking
for example if we perform machine
learning we try to do
regression try to predict what will be
the sales may be in the future
and so on and so forth so it is much
more
involved in case of data science
compared to
business intelligence the skills are
many more compared to
business intelligence and last but not
least what is the focus
focus of business intelligence is pretty
much historical data
so the sales have happened based on the
sales till
today you try to come up with a report
what was my sales
maybe for this whole year or maybe for
the last five years and so on and so
forth
in data science you take historical data
but you also combine that with maybe
some other
required information and you also try to
predict the future
so we try to extrapolate maybe the sales
and
say okay sales as of now as of today
this is sales is 5 million and
if we based on the the historical
information we see that
sales increase on a maybe i don't know
monthly basis 10 percent
that is what history says so our sales
for next month will be
this much right so that is the focus of
data science it goes beyond just
reporting so what are the prerequisites
for
data science there are three essential
traits
required for to be a data scientist one
is
curiosity you need to be able to ask
questions
the first step in data science is asking
questions what is the problem we are
trying to solve if you ask the right
question
only then you'll get the right answer
very often this is a very crucial step
where a lot of data science projects
fail because you're you may be asking
the wrong question
and then obviously when you get the
answer that's not the answer you're
looking for so it is very important that
you ask the right question needless to
say then the second part
or the second trait is common sense so
you need to be
creative you need to come up with ways
to use the data that you have
and try to solve the business problem on
hand
in many cases you may not have all the
data that you need
in many cases the data may be incomplete
so that is where you need to come up
with ways what are the best ways to
fill these gaps wherever this is missing
and that's where
common sense comes into play last but
not least after doing all this analysis
if you are unable to communicate the
results in the right way
the whole exercise will fail so
communication
is a key trait for a data scientist
maybe
technically you may be a genius but then
if you are unable to communicate those
results
in a proper way once again that will not
help
so these are the three main traits
curiosity common sense
and communication skills in a way you
can say these are the three c's
okay so what are the other prerequisites
first one so machine learning machine
learning is the backbone of data science
data science involves quite a bit of
machine learning in addition to the
basic statistics
that we do so a data scientist needs to
have a good hang or need to be very good
at
data science the second part is modeling
so modeling is also a part of machine
learning in a way
but you need to be good at identifying
what are the algorithms that are more
suitable to solve a given problem
what models can we use and how do we
train these models and so on and so
forth so that is the second
component then statistics statistics is
like
the core foundation of data science so
you need to understand
statistics and you need to have a good
hang of statistics in order to be a good
data scientist
and this will also help in getting good
results
programming is to some extent required
at least some program or the other would
be required
as a part of executing the data science
project
the most common programming languages
are python
and r python specially is becoming a
very
popular programming language in data
science because of its ease of learning
because of the multiple libraries that
it supports
for performing data science and machine
learning and so on so
python is by far one of the most popular
languages in data science if any one of
you is wanting to learn a new language
that should be python and then of course
you need to
understand databases how databases work
and how to handle databases how to get
data out of databases
and so on so these are some of the key
components of data science now coming to
the tools and skills that are used in
data science these are some of the
skills
from a language perspective it is python
or r and from a skills perspective
in addition to some of the programming
languages it would help if you have
a good knowledge or good understanding
of statistics
and what are the tools that are used in
data analysis
sas is one of the most popular tools
it's been there for very long time
and that's the reason it is very popular
and
however this is compared to most of the
other tools it is a proprietary
software whereas python and r are mostly
open source the other tools are like
jupiter
jupiter notebooks you have r studio
these are more development environments
and development tools so jupyter
notebooks is a interactive development
environment
similarly rstudio is for performing or
writing our code
and performing analytics and
performing data analysis and machine
learning activities you can perform
in rstudio it has a very nice ui
and initially r was not so popular
primarily because it did not have
user interface and rstudio is a
relatively new edition
and after the advent of rstudio r became
extremely popular and there are other
tools like matlab and of course some
people do with
excel as well as far as data warehousing
is concerned
some of the skills that are required are
etl
so in order to extract data
and transform load etl stands for
extract transform load
so you have data in the databases like
your erp system or a crm system
you need to extract that and then do
some transformations and then load it
into your warehouse
so that all the data from various
sources
looks uniform then you need some sql
skills which is basically
querying the data writing sql queries
hadoop is another
important skill especially if you are
handling large amounts of data
and also one of the specialities of
hadoop is it can
be used for handling unstructured data
as well so it can be used for large
amounts of structured and unstructured
data
then spark is a excellent computing
engine for performing
data analysis or machine learning in a
distributed mode
so if you have large amount of data the
combination of spark and hadoop can be
extremely powerful so you store your
data
in hadoop hdfs and use spark as your
computation engine
it works in a distributed mode similar
to hadoop
like a cluster so that those are
excellent skills for data warehousing
and
there are some standard tools that are
available like informatica
data stage talent and also aws redshift
if you
want to do some on the cloud i think aws
redshift is again a good tool
data visualization tools for data
visualization some of the skills that
would be required
are let's say r your r provides some
very good visualization capabilities
especially for for developing during
development
and then you have python libraries
matplotlib and so on which
provides very powerful visualization
capabilities
and that is from skills perspective
whereas
tools that can be used are tableau is a
very very
popular visualization tool again that's
a proprietary tool so it's a little
expensive maybe but
excellent capabilities from a
visualization perspective
then there are tools like cognos which
is an ibm product which provides very
good visualization capabilities as well
and then coming to the machine learning
part of it the skills required there are
python which is
more for programming part and then you
will
need some mathematical skills like
algebra
linear algebra especially and then
statistics and maybe a little bit of
calculus and so on
and the tools that are used for machine
learning
are spark mlib and apache
mahou and on cloud if you want to do
something
you can use microsoft azure ml studio as
well
so these are by no means an exhaustive
list there are actually many many tools
and probably
a few more skills also maybe there but
this is this gives a quick
overview like a summarizing of
summarization of
the tools and skills now moving on to
the life of a data scientist what does a
data scientist
do during the course of his work so
let's see
so typically a data scientist is given a
problem
a business problem that he needs to
solve and in order to do that
if you remember from the previous slide
he basically asks the question as to
what is the problem that he needs to
solve so that is the first thing
he has got the problem then the next
thing is to gather the data that is
required to
solve this problem so he goes about
looking for data from
anywhere it could be the enterprise very
often the data is not provided in the
nice
format that he would like to have it or
we would like to have it
so first step is to get whatever data
that is possible
what is known as raw data in whatever
format so it could be enterprise data it
could be
it is a probably a requirement to go and
get some public data in some cases so
all that raw data is collected and then
that is processed
and analyzed and in prepared
into a format in which it can be used
and then it is fed into the analytic
system be it a machine learning
algorithm
or a statistical model and we get the
output
and then he puts these output in
a proper format for presenting it to the
stakeholders and communicating
those insights or the results to the
stakeholders so this is a
very high level view of like a
day in the life of a data scientist so
gathering data
raw data performing some quick analysis
on that
and maybe processing or manipulating
this data to
bring it into a certain good format so
that it can be used for the analysis
feeding this into that analysis system
that has been designed
be it mathematical models machine
learning models
and then get the results the insights
and then present it in a nice way so
that the stakeholders can
understand how about machine learning
algorithms so let's see what are the
various machine learning algorithms that
would be required for a data scientist
so these are a few of the algorithms
again there's not an exhaustive list we
have
regression is one of the supervised
learning models or techniques so in case
of regression
you try to let's say come up with a
continuous number
so the difference between regression
and let's say a classification is that
in case of classification
those are discrete values whereas here
we are talking about regression where
you let's say you are trying to predict
the temperature which is a continuous
value or the
share price which is a continuous value
so that is regression so you need to
know what is regression how to perform
regression
and we need to understand clustering so
clustering is one of the
unsupervised learning techniques in this
case there is
no label data that is available and you
get some data and then you want to put
this into some
shape so that you can analyze it and you
try to make sense
out of it let's say you have one example
is you
have a list of cricketers and
they have not been marked as bowlers and
batsmen
or all renders or whatever right so you
just have
their names and maybe how many runs this
code how many wickets they have taken
and so on but there is no readily
available
information saying that okay this person
is a batsman this person is a bowler and
so on so i'm talking about cricket
hopefully most of you are familiar with
the game of cricket so
how do we find out so then we put this
into a clustering mechanism
and then the system will say that okay
these are the people
who are all who have all scored good
amount of runs
so they belong to one cluster these are
all the people who have taken
good amount of wickets so they belong to
one cluster and maybe here are some
people who have taken
good amount of wickets and they have
made good amount of runs so they may be
belonging to one group and then we take
a look at it and then we label them as
okay people who have all together
and those who have you know scored many
runs they are
we label them as batsmen people have
taken a lot of wickets we label them as
bowlers and people who have taken
good amount of wickets and also made
some good runs we
label them as all rounders but the
system will just say okay this is
cluster one cluster two cluster 3.
the names we give we human beings have
to give the names
now decision tree is used for what is
known as classification
primarily it can also be used for
regression but by and large it is used
for
classification and here again it's a
very
logical way in which the algorithm goes
about classifying
the various inputs one of the biggest
advantages of decision tree is that
it's very easy to understand and it's
very easy to explain why
a certain object has been classified in
a certain way
compared to maybe some of the other
mechanisms like say
support vector machines or logistic
regression and so on so that's the
advantage of dictionary but that is also
very popular algorithm
then we have support vector machines
primarily for classification purpose
and then we have naive bayes this is a
statistical probability based
classification
method so these are a few algorithms
there are a few more
that are not listed here but there are
some more algorithms as well
and by the way there are more detailed
or there are detailed videos about each
of
these algorithms available you can check
in the playlist
so now let's talk about the life cycle
of a data science project okay the first
step
is the concept study in this step it
involves
understanding the business problem
asking questions
get a good understanding of the business
model meet up with all the stakeholders
understand what kind of data is
available and all that
is a part of the first step so here are
a few examples
we want to see what are the various
specifications
and then what is the end goal what is
the budget
is there an example of this kind of a
problem that has been maybe solved
earlier
so all this is a part of the concept
study and another example could be a
very specific one
to predict the price of a 1.35 carat
diamond and there may be
relevant information inputs that are
available and
we want to predict the price the next
step
in this process is data preparation
data gathering and data preparation also
known as
data munching or sometimes it is also
known as
data manipulation so what happens here
is the raw data that is available
may not be usable in its current format
for various reasons so that is why in
this step
a data scientist would explore the data
he will take a look at some sample data
maybe pick
there are millions of records pick a few
thousand records and see how the data is
looking are there any gaps
is the structure appropriate to be fed
into the system
are there some columns which are
probably
not adding value may not be required for
the analysis
very often these are like names of the
customers they will probably not add any
value or much value
from an analysis perspective the
structure of the data maybe the data is
coming from multiple data sources
and the structures may not be matching
what are the other problems
there may be gaps in the data so the
data all the
columns all the cells are not filled if
you're talking about structured data
there are several blank records or blank
columns
so if you use that data directly
you'll get errors or you will get
inaccurate results so how do you
either get rid of the data or how do you
fill this
gaps with something meaningful so all
that
is a part of data munching or
data manipulation so these are some
additional
sub topics within that so data
integration is one of them
if there are any conflicts in the data
there may be data may be redundant yeah
data resident redundancy is another
issue
there may be you have let's say data
coming from two different systems
and both of them have customer table for
example customer information
so when you merge them there is a
duplication issue so how do we resolve
that so
that is one data transformation as i
said there will be situations where
data is coming from multiple sources and
then when we
merge them together they may not be
matching so we need to do some
transformations to make sure
everything is similar we may have to do
some
data reduction if the data size is too
big
you may have to come up with ways to
reduce it
meaningfully without losing information
then data cleaning so there will be
either wrong values or you know values
or there are missing values so how do
you handle all of that
a few examples of very specific stuff so
there are missing values how do you
handle missing values
or null values here in this particular
slide we are seeing three types of
issues one is missing value
then you have null value you see the
difference between the two right so in
the missing value there is nothing
blank null value it says null now the
system cannot
handle if there are null values
similarly there is improper data so it's
supposed to be numeric value but there
is a
string or a non-numeric value so how do
we clean
and prepare the data so that our system
can work flawlessly
so there are multiple ways and there is
no
one common way of doing this it can vary
from
project to project it can vary from what
exactly is the problem we are trying to
solve
it can vary from data scientist to data
scientist organization to organization
so these are like some
standard practices people come up with
and and of course
there will be a lot of trial and error
somebody would have tried out something
and it worked and will continue to use
that mechanism
so that's how we need to take care of
data cleaning now
what are the various ways of doing you
know if values are missing
how do you take care of that now if the
data is too large
and only a few records have some missing
values
then it is okay to just get rid of those
entire
rows for example so if you have a
million records and out of which
100 records don't have full data so
there are some missing values in about
100 cards so it's absolutely fine
because
it's a small percentage of the data so
you can get rid of the entire records
which are missing values
but that's not a very common situation
very often you will have
multiple or at least a large number of
data set
for example out of million records you
may have 50 000 records which are
like having missing values now that's a
significant amount
you cannot get rid of all those records
your analysis will
be inaccurate so how do you handle such
situations so there are again multiple
ways of doing it one is
you can probably if a particular values
are missing in a particular
column you can probably take the mean
value for that particular column
and fill all the missing values with the
mean value so that
first of all you don't get errors
because of missing values and second
you don't get results that are way off
because these values are completely
different from what is
there so that is one way then a few
other could be
either taking the median value or
depending on
what kind of data we are talking about
so something meaningful we will have put
in there
if we are doing some machine learning
activity
then obviously as a part of data
preparation you need to
split the data into training and test
data set the reason being
if you try to test with a data set which
the system has already seen as a part of
training
then it will tend to give reasonably
accurate results because it has already
seen that data
and that is not a good measure of the
accuracy of the
system so typically you take the entire
data set the input data set and split it
into
two parts and again the ratio can vary
from person to person individual
preferences some people like to split it
into
50 50 some people like it as 63.33
and 33.3 is basically two third and one
third and some people
do it as 80 20 80 for training and 24
testing so you split the data
perform the training with the 80 percent
and then use the remaining 20 for
testing all right
so that is one more data preparation
activity
that needs to be done before you start
analyzing or applying the
data or putting the data through the
model then the next step is
model planning now this models can be
statistical models
this could be machine learning model so
you need to decide
what kind of models you're going to use
again it depends on what is the problem
you're trying to solve if it is a
regression problem you need to think of
a regression algorithm and come up with
a regression
model so it could be linear regression
or if you are talking about
classification
then you need to pick up an appropriate
classification algorithm like
logistic regression or decision tree or
svm
and then you need to train that
particular
model so that is the model building or
model planning process
and the cleaned up data has to be fed
into the model
and apart from cleaning you may also
have to in order to determine what kind
of model you will
use you have to perform some exploratory
data analysis
to understand the relationship between
the various variables and
see if the data is appropriate and so on
right so that is the
additional preparatory step that needs
to be done
so a little bit of details about
exploratory data analysis so what
exactly is exploratory data analysis is
basically to
as the name suggests you're just
exploring you just receive the data and
you're trying to explore
and find out what are the data types and
what is the is the data clean in in each
of the columns what is the maximum
minimum value so for example
there are out of the box functionality
available in
tools like r so if you just ask for a
summary of the table it will tell you
for each column it will give some
details as to what is the mean value
what is the maximum value and so on and
so forth
so this exercise or this exploratory
analysis
is to get an understanding of your data
and
then you can take steps to during this
process you find that a lot of missing
values you need to take steps to
fix those you will also get an idea
about what kind of model
to be used and so on and so forth what
are the various techniques used for
exploratory data analysis
typically these would be visualization
techniques like you use histograms uh
you can use
box plots you can use scatter plots so
these are very quick ways of identifying
the patterns or a few of the trends of
the data and so on
and then once your data is ready you've
decided on the model
what kind of model what kind of
algorithm you're going to use
if you're trying to do machine learning
you need to
pass your 80 percent the training data
or rather you use that training data to
train your model
and the training process itself is
iterative so
the training process you may have to
perform multiple times and once the
training
is done and you feel it is giving good
accuracy
then you move on to test so you
take the remaining 20 of the data
remember we split the data into training
and test
so the test data is now used to
check the accuracy or how well our model
is performing and
if there are further issues let's say
and model is still
during testing if the accuracy is not
good then you may want to retrain your
model
or use a different model so this whole
thing again can be iterative but if the
test process
is passed or if the model passes the
test then it can go into
production and it will be deployed all
right so
what are the various tools that we use
for model planning r is an excellent
tool in a lot of ways
whether you're doing regular statistical
analysis
or machine learning or any of these
activities are in
along with our studio provides a very
powerful
environment to do data analysis
including visualization
it has a very good integrated
visualization of plot mechanism
which can be used for doing exploratory
data analysis and then
later on to do analysis detailed
analysis and machine learning and so on
and so forth then of course you can
write python
programs python offers a rich library
for performing data analysis
and machine learning and so on matlab is
a very popular
tool as well especially during education
so this is a very easy to
learn tool so matlab is another uh tool
that can be used and then last but not
least
sas sas is again very powerful
it is a proprietary tool and it has
all the components that are required to
perform
very good statistical analysis or
perform data science so
those are the various tools that would
be required for
or that that can be used for model
building and
so the next step is model building so we
have done the planning part
we said okay what is algorithm we are
going to use what kind of model we are
going to use
now we need to actually train this model
or build the model rather
so that it can then be deployed so what
are the various
uh ways or what are the various types of
model building activities
so it could be let's say in this
particular example that we have taken
you want to find out the price
of 1.35 carat diamond so
this is let's say a linear regression
problem you have data for various carets
of diamond
and you use that information you pass it
through
a linear regression model or you create
a linear regression model
which can then predict your price for
1.35 carat so this is one example
of model building and then a little bit
details of how linear regression
works so linear regression is basically
coming up with a relation between
an independent variable and a dependent
variable so it is pretty much like
coming up with equation of a straight
line
which is the best fit for the given data
so like for example here
y is equal to mx plus c so y is the
dependent variable and x is the
independent variable
we need to determine the values of m and
c for our given data so
that is what the training process
of this model does at the end of the
training process
you have a certain value of m and c and
that is used for predicting the values
of
any new data that comes all right so the
way it works is we use the training
and the test data set to train the model
and then validate whether the model is
working fine or not using
test data and if it is working fine
then it is taken to the next level which
is put in production
if not the model has to be retrained if
the accuracy is not good enough
then the model is retrained maybe with
more data or you come up with a newer
model
or algorithm and then repeat that
process so it is an iterative process
once the training is completed training
and test
then this model is deployed and we can
use this particular model
to determine what is the price of 1.35
carat diamond remember that was our
problem statement so now that we have
the best fit
for this given data we have the price of
1.35
carat diamond which is 10 000. so this
is
one example of how this whole process
works
now how do we build the model there are
multiple ways
you can use python for example and use
libraries like pandas or numpy
to build the model and implement it this
will be
available as a separate tutorial a
separate video in this
playlist so stay tuned for that moving
on
once we have the results the next step
is to communicate
these results to the appropriate
stakeholders
so which is basically taking this
results and preparing
like a presentation or a dashboard
and communicating these results to the
concerned people so finishing or getting
the results of the analysis
is not the last step but you need to as
a data scientist take this results and
present it to the team that has given
you this problem in the first place
and explain your findings explain the
findings
of this exercise and recommend maybe
what steps they need to take in order to
overcome
this problem or solve this problem so
that is the
pretty much once that is accepted and
the last step
is to operationalize so if everything is
fine your data scientists presentations
are
accepted then they put it into practice
and thereby they will be able to improve
or
solve the problem that they stated in
step one
okay so quick summary of the life cycle
you have
a concept study which is basically
understanding the problem
asking the right questions and trying to
see if there is
enough data to solve this problem and
then even maybe gather the data then
data preparation
the raw data needs to be manipulated you
need to do data munching
so that you have a data in a certain
proper format
to be used by the model or our analytics
system and then you need to do the model
planning what kind of a model what
algorithm you will use for a given
problem
and then the model building so the exact
execution of that model
it happens in step four and you
implement and execute
that model and put the data through the
analysis in this step
and then you get the results this
results are then
communicated packaged and presented and
communicated to the stakeholders
and once that is accepted that is
operationalized so that is the final
step
now in the end let's take a quick look
at the demand for data scientists
data science is an area of great demand
the demand for data scientists is
currently
huge and the supply is very low so there
is a huge
gap so what are some of the industries
with high demand for data scientists
i think gaming is definitely one area
where it's a industry which is consumer
facing industry and a lot of people
play games and growing industry and it
requires a lot of data science
so that is an area where data scientists
are in demand then we have healthcare
for example data science is used for
diagnosis and several other activities
within
healthcare predicting for example a
disease
so healthcare is definitely finance
definitely
banks insurance companies all of these
there is a huge demand for data
scientists
marketing is like a horizontal
functionality across all industries
there's a demand for data scientists
there then of course in technology area
so
pretty much all of these areas there is
a lot of demand
globally there is a huge demand so this
is a very very
critical skill that would be required
currently
as well as in the future so who is a
data science
engineer are you a data science engineer
or are you going to be looking for a
different field
what exactly is a data science engineer
well a data science engineer is someone
who has
programming experience in python and r
expert level knowledge
ability to write proficient codes and
they
we have python and our i'm going to say
python or
r once you become really proficient at
one language
transferring those skills into another
one is usually fairly easy
now r is a little different because it
is an analytics platform
so going from python to r if you already
know the data analytics and python
moving to r is pretty easy uh now r
doesn't have all the other code that
you can access with python there's so
many things you can do with python that
are not data analytics
so it's important to keep in mind that
you should probably be pretty
well-rounded in python
and really have a solid foundation in r
or have a solid foundation in
r and be well-rounded in another
programming language where you really
get the programming side of it
strong sql and big data experience so
you have to have a strong coding skill
with hands-on big data experience and of
course we're showing sql here
most commonly used whether you're using
a microsoft sql server or mysql server
you can also start thinking hadoop and
spark in big data access
hadoop file system is not a huge jump if
you've already learned your sql and
you've already learned your basics and
coding
hadoop sits on top of all that and does
a wonderful job creating huge clusters
of data
but you really need to know your sql
because that is so common in most
of the large companies now accessing
their data
and an ability to visualize models and
troubleshoot code
of the models this is a kind of an
interesting one because
these models are can get very
complicated so you gotta be able to
break them down
into something that you can put the
pieces together and digest each of the
pieces
so being able to visualize these models
is very important and then being able to
drill down and
troubleshoot the different models or the
pieces in those models
you need to be a versatile problem
solver equipped with strong analytical
and quantitative skills
a self-starter with a strong sense of
personal responsibility and technical
orientation
this is an interesting one because when
you talk about data science engineer
it's such a new field that most
companies don't have it well defined
they don't know what they're looking for
you might not even know what you're
looking for you might have an idea and
you're looking for patterns but where do
those patterns lead you
so you really need that self-starter
side to jump in there and figure out
where to go
and be able to communicate that back to
the team and there we go we have a
strong
product intuition data analysis skills
and business presentation skills and
this was talking about is
you got to bring that back to the team
so if you don't have a strong product in
tuition if you don't know what's going
on with the company
what they need and where you're going
with your analysis
it's going to be a dead end and you've
got to be able to present that to the
shareholders
to your co-workers which leads us to
great teammate with excellent
interpersonal skills and this is kind of
a strange one because you spend so much
time behind your desk so you have to be
able to kind of float between
you're studying all the data and being
able to explain this to people
in simple terms that they can understand
no one wants somebody to come up and say
yeah the p
score and the f score is this that and
the other thing and you might have
two people in the room understand you
you have to be able to sit down and
explain
what that means and why so let's take a
look at the data science
skill set we talk about data science
engineer skill set we're talking about
database knowledge
statistics programming tools data
wrangling
probably the least favorite and most
used machine learning
data visualization and then the touch on
big data
and so we'll start with database
knowledge the most
common databases of course your sql
structured query language
think rows and columns it's an essential
language for extracting a large amount
of data from data sets
so knowledge of the sql is mandatory for
data science engineers
and you can see there's tools required
there's the oracle database
i mentioned mysql server microsoft sql
server
teradata there are so many different
forms of sql
and it'll just keep coming back and
coming back so if you don't have a solid
basic understanding of sql go get it
very important because it will come up
you know it's if you don't know it it's
going to bite you and statistics of
course we are you know that's what this
is all about is figuring out and
predicting things so you need to know
your statistics statistics is a subset
of mathematics that deals with
collecting
analyzing and interpreting data
therefore data scientist needs to know
statistics so you need to understand
your probabilities and what that means
and what the p score means and the f
score
and means and mode and median all that
information
standard deviation all of those you need
to be aware of
and then we get into the programming
tools and i mentioned this earlier a
little bit
but you need to master any one of these
specific programming languages
programming tools such as r python sas
are essential to perform
analytics in data and again
you know you can move in there and you
can be an expert in just r
you can be an expert in just sas and a
little bit you can be an expert in
python
because most of these when we're talking
about data science and data wrangling
you really kind of get down to the point
where you really need to have a full
programming language at least the basics
and if you're
going to be working in data science
python right now is the main one but you
know there's also java c plus plus
so you need to know a solid language at
least the basics of it so you can
understand how to do basic iterations
and things like that
i always find that interesting that my
sister who runs a university data
analytics center that's the first
question she asks for
people candidates to come and work for
is how do you iterate through data you'd
be amazed at how many people don't
understand that very basic concept
in programming so when we look at r r is
a free software environment for
statistical computing and graphs
supports most machine learning
algorithms for data analytics like
regression
association clustering and etc python
python is an open source general purpose
programming language and there's our
general purpose i was just talking about
you need to know a little bit about
python libraries like numpy and scipy
are used in data science
scipy yeah numpy and scipy are very
central to python and i'd throw pandas
in there also
that module those are very central to
working with python and data analytics
and then sas sas can mine alter manage
and retrieve data from a variety of
sources
it can perform statistical analysis on
the data
so where r is the open source platform
sas is more like the paid for
platform and so it has some things more
automated because people
are paying for it developing it but it's
also if you really start using it as a
company you're going to have to pay for
it where rs free store
is a free software python is also open
source and free to use
so we're going to talk a little bit
about data wrangling and i mentioned
earlier that is
both the probably people's least
favorite
aspects of data science and also
probably one of the places
you spend the most time so we talk about
data wrangling
it is a process of transforming raw data
into an appropriate format to make it
useful for analytics
and it involves cleaning raw data
structuring raw data
and enriching raw data and this gets
interesting because you'll get stuck on
something like
in python you might get stuck on
something that is a
date time based on an integer 64
numpy set you might not know what all
those terms mean because you work in
r or something like that but you get the
point that it's all one particular
format and then you have to figure out
how to switch it so that the computer
can see it correctly in whatever format
you're using or whatever analytics
platform you're using
knowledge of machine learning techniques
such as supervised machine learning
decision trees linear regression k n etc
is useful for
few job roles so this is kind of
interesting because sometimes that's the
center of the job role of a data
scientist
and sometimes you just have to be able
to apply
the programming skills to it so you can
get the answer and let somebody else
fine-tune your machine learning
techniques so it really
depends on what it is you're working
with and you can see here we have our
nearest neighbor set up where it groups
things together that look alike
linear regression you're drawing a line
through the data or curve
so you can predict what the next value
is going to be
and then our nice decision tree would
start splitting things up and says you
know it's sunny out yes let's go
swimming
no it's raining we're not going to go
swimming yes it's sunny out we might go
swim
it's raining we'll stay indoors yes
we'll walk the dog no so you have a
decision tree that helps
figure out how you get to the end result
so decision trees can be pretty powerful
and data visualization data
visualization is the study
and creation of visual representation of
data data visualization uses
algorithms statistical graphs plots
information graphics and other tools to
communicate information clearly
and effectively this one you really have
to master as a data science
this one you really have to master as a
data scientist
and there certainly are so many
different tools to use to visualize it
but when you're communicating a picture
is worth a thousand words
when you can put a picture up and and
people can look at and go oh i see
what's going on
that's worth a lot more than saying yeah
yeah this is good people hear that and
they just kind of go okay it's good but
why
and you might say you know okay these
numbers make it look good no people want
something they can see
and there certainly is uh tabloo is
probably
one of the most popular ones out there
caleb view
power bi google data studio
in python there's um the pi kit
and seaborn there's all kinds of
different options for visualization you
need to master
probably at least one or two of them so
you understand how they work and how
they're different
and then big data big data is a massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
and processed
using traditional methods big data has
various benefits like access to social
data can enable organizations to
tune their business strategies big data
can improve customer experience
uh and so we're usually when you say big
data we're almost
always talking about hadoop and apache
spark it used to be hadoop as your
file system so that's how you store all
your data going across the nodes and
there certainly are other ways to
store it when we talk about hadoop we're
usually talking about at least 10
terabytes of data when you're dealing
with a hadoop
file structure and then you can use
spark where
hadoop processes on and off the hard
drive so it's continually
reading and writing to the hard drive
spark is running in your ram
and so when you're doing a very
intensive data process
you'll run a spark setup which will
spread those processes over multiple
computers
and of course now the two uh combine and
spark sits on top of hadoop and you get
your big data there's also
talent tableau has its own server set up
there's splunk uh cassandra you'll hear
the cassandra database pentaho i'm not
even sure how to pronounce that one it's
not one i've worked with
certainly there's a lot of options for
big data the two big players are of
course hadoop and spark
and even your sql servers and mysql
servers will spread across
five different servers and you can be
talking about big data across five
servers with those pulling them into say
apache spark to do your high-end
processing and then there's
non-technical skills
probably the most important one in data
science and any
of our data analytics is intellectual
curiosity
updating knowledge by reading contents
and relevant books on trends in data
science
this is such there's so much going on in
this field and it's exploding now
that it's hard to keep track of it all
uh so you really need to have that
curiosity
in the data science probably even more
so than a lot of other fields
but i would say in just today's world
you need intellectual curiosity because
things are changing so rapidly in
today's world
the way it's going with our technology
understanding how
the problem solved can impact the
business
business acumen this is the one where a
lot of people kind of skip over
you have to have a little business sense
if you don't know how it's going to
impact the business
you're going to be in trouble why do
they want to even pay you to be there
unless they know what's going on and
they're getting something in return
so this is your bottom line for your
paycheck is
what's going on with the business how is
this going to impact the business what
are you doing for them and communication
skills
companies look for someone who can
clearly and fluently
translate technical findings to a
non-technical team
and i've talked about this a bunch and i
i can't even iterate this enough
if you are struggling with your
communication skills
work on building them they don't have to
be you know this isn't
rocket science where you have to know
all these complicated terms
what you need to do is take the
complicated terms you know from data
science
and reduce that down to something that
anybody can understand
so when you come up and you have you
know knn
no one knows what k n is you know unless
they're in data science
nearest neighbor looking for things that
match together you got to explain that
to people who do not have
the technical skill in the data science
arena and a data science engineer needs
to work with
everyone in the organization including
customers
so it's teamwork and that's always one
that throws people for a loop
but ultimately you are analyzing your
customers information and so sometimes
getting in there
and rolling up your sleeves if you're
let's say you're doing data analysis for
the sales team and you're backing a
sales team you might have to get in
there and go
start making some sales and making some
phone calls and see what it's like what
is that team doing
when they call 15 people in cold calls
and then they do a follow-up two weeks
later or three weeks later which one
works better
two or three does it work better to call
and send a fax
call and send an email you know when you
should you show up in person if it's
that kind of business
so working with everybody including the
customer is very important with the data
and
with this kind of setup and
non-technical skills for a data
scientist
so let's take a look at some of the
roles data science plays in the job
market
let's drill in there just a little bit
here so when you have a data scientist
they're going to perform predictive
analysis and identify trend and patterns
that can help in better decision making
companies hiring data scientists include
apple adobe
google microsoft i would say that's even
expanding down to smaller companies you
know where you're talking about only 100
employees or something like that
they're starting to look at data
scientists because they need them to
come in
and be a part of that team and the role
is understanding challenges of a system
and offer best solutions this should
always be the goal of a data scientist
is to be looking at the whole system and
then trying to find those patterns that
are going to best enhance the company or
the business
or the whatever group maybe you're
working with the sales team or the
marketing team
and you can see languages pretty
important to have a these are a number
of different languages and again it
depends on your own specialty
there's all kinds of different
variations but we have r
sas python matlab sql hive pig spark
you should have at least a knowledge of
all of these maybe a python programmer
never used r
download it go through the basics so at
least you know what's going on in r
versus python because r is pretty
powerful for doing a very quick
display and then of course a lot of
things you can do in python you have to
be able to do
queries on database from time to time
create and modify algorithms which can
be used to reduce
information from large databases and
usually this is one of those things you
do at the beginning you set it up
and then you kind of let it go until it
breaks and you have to go back and fix
it because
your query isn't working that certainly
is a very common thing to
to have happen especially if you're
pulling data off the web and the
internet
and then we have some more companies
that are hiring data analysis like ibm
dhl hp and so we're talking about data
analysis the role is responsible for a
variety of tasks such as visualization
optimization and processing large amount
of data and so when you talk about a
data
analyst we're also we're still talking a
lot of the same stuff but you'll see we
now thrown in javascript and html in
here
because that's pretty common with a data
analyst versus a data scientist
and you can see that sql is still pretty
solid and also
cc plus is pretty big so some companies
also use java so i'd put java in the
languages
also on that for a data analyst and then
you have a data architect
ensuring that data engineers have best
tools and systems to work with
and so companies hiring a data architect
are like visa logitech
coca-cola they create blueprints for
data management with the best
security measures i cannot highlight
that a data architect really spends a
lot of time with security measures
that's big how many hacks have we seen
in the last year on large companies have
lost
data for millions of their customers and
how badly that affects them and we're
looking at languages
as you see that sql is pretty solid
across all of these
under a data architect xml that's one
that a lot of the data science jobs
don't really
you don't see as much but you're going
to see more xml with a data architect
because there's a lot of xml files that
are
that have your security measures
embedded in them and of course your hive
pig those are hadoop systems we're doing
some basic queries
so instead of doing the high end queries
you know how these simplified query
systems built into hadoop
and spark so if you're using big data
you're going to want to know your spark
also
and then we have our data engineer the
data engineer updates the existing
systems with better version of the
current technologies to improve the
efficiency of the databases
think admin here a lot of work tracking
down what version you're in
of the different programs what version
of python are you using what version of
r
are using what version of c plus so
companies hiring data engineers are like
amazon
spotify facebook and they develop
construct
test and maintain architectures such as
databases and long scale processing
systems
and here we have our languages our sql
our matlab
sas spss python java ruby c plus plus
pearl hive
pig you pretty much as a data engineer
at this level when you talk about
admin and updating all these databases
need to know all the different stuff
that's being used
in the company and you're testing out
these structures to make sure they work
and so you really are talking admin
level
uh kind of setup so if you like spinning
up an admin
onto a google cloud service or amazon
cloud service
now you start to get an idea what we're
talking about because then you can test
it out up there and then you can bring
it back and update it to the company
statition creates new methodologies for
engineers to apply
and so when we look at this this is
where we're digging into the math of
which models to use
what setup is going to work what kind of
activation do we have on our neural
network
these little tweaks are going to make a
big difference
and we look for methodologies at a large
level what kind of data are we going to
be looking at how are we going to pull
it together
companies hiring a data engineer or
we're talking about stations we're
talking about linkedin
pepsico johnson and johnson and of
course these companies
probably hire a little bit of everything
but they have a lot of statisticians
working for them
and so we look at the role extract and
offer valuable reports from the data
clusters
through statistical theories and data
organization and the languages
across the board we're still seeing sql
r matlab sas spss
data that's a new one that i've seen in
some of the other roles
python pearl an older version and that
shouldn't be a surprise because a lot of
these companies probably built a lot of
the original packages on pearl if you go
look at johnson and johnson
and of course your big data high pig and
spark and then our database
administrator
i mentioned the other one is an admin
they're more an admin level for the
software itself
so administrator is another level some
of the tasks involved are monitoring
operating and maintaining databases
installation configuration defining
schemas training users etc
and this is interesting training users
because when you build a database and
you define all the different
tables that are embedded in that
database and how they're all connected
the end users got to have that
information otherwise you're in trouble
when we have companies hiring data
engineers of course tabloo
twitter reddit the role ensures that all
the databases are available to all
relevant users again a little security
in there what role do they have
is allowed in and not and is performing
correctly and is being kept safe
and you better be ready to spend some
time in security
because again that's a very big thing
nowadays with the number of people who
hack into these databases
and the languages are going to be
covered you have your c
sharp your java sql ruby on rails
xml again there's that xml because a lot
of your security is embedded in xml
files um
python all the main players depending on
what the company's using
data and analytics manager so when you
see manager that means that somebody's
going to sit on top
and organize the people underneath so
they're going to improve the business
process
as an intermediary between business and
i.t
oh you better have some really good
communication skills for this one
uh some of the companies hiring a data
engineers are coursera
motorola slack and of course these
companies are hiring data scientists in
almost all of these fields
so the role oversees the data science
operations
and assigns the duties to the team
according to skills and expertise
so that's a big one you better be able
to communicate what's going on help your
team members
come out and be able to communicate with
other people so sometimes your job is
just being able to get people to talk to
each other the big thing on that
is is the whole communication line going
from one end to the other
because you can't communicate all the
information that everybody's working on
you have to pretty much come in there
and and help people communicate
what there's going on and also know what
they're up to without being
micromanagement
because that will crash a company if you
micromanage everybody but if you just
let them do whatever they want and they
never talk to each other that will also
destroy the company you gotta find that
nice middle ground
and you really have to have an overview
of everything as a data and
analytics manager one of the things i
mean you know it's good to have at least
one or two solid bases of programming
under your belt for a data analytics
manager
but you do need to have a very general
understanding of all the different tools
being used so that you know what's going
on with your different team members
of course sql r sas java python matlab
all of those are big business analytics
so this is
when you're talking about your bi or
your business intelligence
and your business analytics very
important to
know this is kind of a subdivision of a
lot of the other stuff we've talked
about a lot of the other roles we've
looked at
so you possess specialized knowledge of
their business domain and
apply that knowledge and analysis
specifically to the operation
of the business uh so you might be a
specialist in banking
you might be a genetics engineer
so you know about genetics you might
just be general business
helping the marketing so a lot of
companies hiring data engineer oracle
uber dell and the role act as a link
between the data engineers and the
management executives so it's very
similar to when we go back up here we
look at data analytics
manager a business and analytics is
going to also kind of fill that role in
between
but they're more specialized in business
and you better know sql because we're
talking about
business specifically most of the large
companies are storing their data
that's up and running right now that
people are accessing to
purchase something on the home depot
website or the uber they're logging in
you better know your sql it's very
central to business analytics
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
data science engineer salary trends
and you'll see that our source is glass
door that's we're pulling a lot of our
data from
average base pay is around 117 000
in the u.s the average salary and when
we look at india we're talking about
000 a year and those are based on some
of them you need to go ahead and dig
deeper to find out what education level
versus entry level
but those are pretty solid base once
you're in the industry and once you
created your career in there and we look
at the job titles the most common
job title is data scientist business
intelligence manager
is the second greatest one that's kind
of good to note that's why they put that
up there as being its own little
subcategory of data science managers a
business intelligence
manager because it's such a high level
of jobs and then we looked at some of
the other ones data architect
business intelligence architect again
your
bi your business intelligence gets its
own
ranking because it's such a high level
you know it's a business people want
their businesses to make money so that's
who's hiring of course data engineer
business intelligence
developer business intelligence
consultant business intelligence
analyst business analyst and data
analyst
so you can look at the data analysts as
being the general one that doesn't
go specific to business so if you're
looking just for your
career as far as getting a job probably
should have some kind of business
understanding in the background and
again you know your companies want to
make money so they're going to hire
someone who knows business
if banking business if you specialize in
banking or retail if you specialize in
retail and marketing
and you can see here on the data science
salary trends and the growth and data
science
job listings it's continually going up
it's um
since 2014 to 2012 we've gone from 400
to 600
that's a pretty big increase so you know
huge growth in this markets one of the
biggest growing markets right now
for jobs and careers python libraries
let's bring it together we have data
analytics and we have python
so when we're talking data analytics
we're talking python libraries for
data analytics and the big five players
are numpy
pandas matplot library scipy which is
going to be in the background so we're
not going to talk too much about the
scientific formulas inside pi and psi
kit
so numpy supports n-dimensional arrays
provides numerical computing tools
useful for linear algebra
and fourier transform and you can think
of this as just a grid of numbers
and you can even have a grid inside a
grid
or data it's not even numbers because
you can also put
words and characters and just about
anything into
that array but you can think of a grid
and then you can have a grid inside a
grid and you end up with a nice
three-dimensional
array if you want to talk
three-dimensional array you can think of
images you have your three channels of
color four if you have an alpha
and then you have your x y coordinates
for the image we're looking at so you
can go x y and then
what are the three channels to generate
that color
and numpy isn't restricted to three
dimensions you could imagine
watching a movie well now you have your
movie clips and they each have
their x number of frames and each of
those frames have
x number of x y coordinates for the
pictures in each frame and then you have
your
three dimensions for the colors so numpy
is just a great way to work with
in-dimensional arrays
now closely with numpy is pandas
useful for handling missing data perform
mathematical operations
provides functions to manipulate data
pandas is becoming huge because it is
basically a data frame
and if you're working with big data and
you're working in spark or any of the
other major packages out there
you realize that the data frame is very
central to a lot of that
and you can look at it as a excel
spreadsheet
you have your columns you have your rows
or indexes and
you can do all kinds of different
manipulations of the data within
including filling in missing data which
is a big thing when you're dealing with
large pools or lakes of data where they
might be collected differently from
different
locations and matplot library
we did kick over the sci pi which is a
lot of mathematical computations
which usually runs in the background of
the for of numpy and pandas
although you do use them they're useful
for a lot of other things in there
but the matplot library that's the final
part that's what you want to show people
and this is your plotting library in
python several toolkits extend matplot
library functionality
there's like a hundred different
toolkits to extend matplot library
which range from how to properly display
star constellations from astronomy
there's a very specific one built just
for that
all the way to some very generic ones
we'll actually add seaborne in when we
do the labs in a minute
several toolkits extend matplot library
functionality and it creates interactive
visualization so there's all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as just
displaying graphs and there's even some
that you can create
interactive graphs we won't do the
interactive graphs but you'll see you'll
get a
pretty good grasp of some of the
different things you can do in matplot
library
let's jump over to the demo which is my
favorite roll up our sleeves
get our hands in on what we're doing now
there's a lot of options when we're
dealing with python
you can use pycharm is a really popular
one
and you'll see this all over the place
so it's one of the main ones that's out
there and there's a lot of other ones i
used to use netbeans which is kind of
lost favor
don't even have it installed on my new
computer but the most popular one right
now for data
science now pycharm is really popular
for python
general development for data science we
usually go to
jupiter notebook or anaconda
and we're going to jump into anaconda
because that's my favorite one to go to
because it has a lot of external tools
for us
we're not going to dig into those but we
will pop in there so you can see what it
looks like
so with anaconda we have our jupiter lab
we have our notebook these are identical
jupiter lab is an upgrade to the
notebooks with multiple tabs that's all
it is
and we'll be using the notebook and you
can see that pycharm is so popular with
python that we even have highlighted
here in anaconda as part of the setup
jupyter notebook can also be a
standalone so we're actually going to be
running
jupyter notebook and then you have your
different environments
i have we're going to be under main pi
36 there's a root one
and i usually label it pi three six the
reason is is currently as of writing
this
tensorflow only works in three six and
not in 3 7 or 3 8 for doing neural
networks
but you can actually have multiple
environments which is nice there
they separate the kernel so it helps
protect your computer when you're doing
development
and this is just a great way to do a
display or a demo
especially if you're looking for that
job pull up your laptop open it up
or if you're doing a meeting get it
broadcast up to the big screen so that
the
ceo can see what you're looking at
and when we launch the notebook it
actually opens up a file browser in
whatever web browser you have this
happens to be chrome
and then you can just go under new
there's a lot of different options
depending what you have installed
python 3 and this just creates an
untitled
version of this and you can see here i'm
actually in a simply learn folder for
other work i've done for simply learn
and that's where i save all my stuff and
i can browse through other folders
making it real easy to jump from one
project to another
and under here we'll go ahead and change
the name of this and we'll go ahead and
rename it
data analytics data analytics
just so i can remember what i was doing
which is probably about 50 of the
folders in here or files in here right
now
uh so let's go ahead and jump in there
and take a look at some of these
different
tools that we were looking at and as we
go through the demo
let's start with the numpy the least
visually exciting and i'm going to
zoom in here so you can see what we're
doing
and the first thing we want to do is
import numpy
and we'll import it as np that is the
most common
numpy terminology and let's go and
change the view so we also have the line
numbers
i don't know why we probably won't need
them but make it for easy reference
and then we'll create a one dimensional
array we'll just call this array one
and it equals np dot array and you put
your array
information in here in this case we'll
spell it out
uh you can actually do like a range in
other ways there's lots of ways to
generate these arrays
but we'll just do one two three so three
integers
and if we print our array one
we can go ahead and run this and you can
see right here prints one two three
you can see why this is a really nice
interface to show other people what
you're doing
with the jupiter notebook so this is the
basic we've created an array this is a
one dimensional array and then the array
is one
two three one of the nice things about
the jupiter notebook is whatever ran
in this first setup is still running
it's still in the kernel
so it still has the numpy imported as np
and it still has our variable
arr1 for array one equal to np array of
one two three
so we go to the next cell we can check
the type of the array we're just going
to print we say hey what's
what what is this set up in here and we
want
type and then we want what is the type
of array
one let's go ahead and run that and it
says class numpy nd array so it's its
own class that's all we're doing is
checking to see what that class is
and if you look at the array class
probably the biggest thing you
do i don't know how many times i find
myself
doing this because i forget what i'm
working on and i forget i'm working with
a three-dimensional or four-dimensional
array
and i have to reformat somehow so it
works with whatever
other things they have and so we do the
array shape
the array shape is just three because it
has three members and it's a one
dimensional array that's all that is
and with the numpy array we can easily
access
stick with the print statement if you
actually put a variable
in jupyter notebook and it's the last
one in the cell
it will be the same as a print statement
so if i do this
where array one of two is the same as
doing print
array of two that's those are identical
statements in our jupiter notebook
uh we'll go and stick with the print on
this one and it's three so there's our
print
space two and we have zero 1 2
2 equals 3 we can easily change that so
we have array
1 of place 2
equals 5 and then if we
print our array 1 you can see right down
here when it comes out
it's 1 2 and 5. and there i left the
print statement off because it's the
last
variable in the list it'll always print
the variable if you just put it in like
that
that's a jupiter notebook thing don't do
that in pycharm i've forgotten before
doing a demo
and we talked about multiple dimensions
so we'll do an array
two dimensional array and this is again
a numpy array
and in the numpy array we need
our first dimension we'll do one two
three
and our second dimension
three four five and you can see right
here that
when we hit the uh we'll do this we'll
just do array two
and we can run that and there's our
array two one two three three four five
we can also do array two
of 1
and then we can do let's do 0 it doesn't
really matter which one actually do
2 there we go and if i run this it'll
print out 5
because here we are this is 0
0 1 2 3 is under 0 row
3 4 5 is on our one row and we start
with 0
and then the 2 0 1 2 goes to the 5.
and then maybe we forgot what we were
working with so we'll go do array two
dot
shape
and if we do array two of shape
we'll go and run that we'll see we have
two rows
and each row has three elements a two
dimensional array
two three if you looked up here when we
did it before it just had three comma
nothing when you have a single entity it
always saves it as a tuple with a blank
space
but you can see right here we have two
comma three
and if you remember from up here we just
did this array two of
oh let's go what is it one comma two
we run that we get the five you can also
count
backwards this is kind of fun and you'll
see i just kind of
switched something on you because you
can also do one comma two to get to the
same spot
now 2 is the last one 0 1 2. it's the
last one in there
we can count backwards and do minus 1.
and if we run this
we get the same answer whether we count
it as
let's go back up here whether we count
this as 0 1 2
or we count backwards as minus 1 minus 2
minus 3. and you can see that if i
change this minus 1 to a minus 2 and run
that
i get 4 which is going backwards minus 1
minus 2.
so there's a lot of different ways to
reference what we're working on
inside the numpy array it's really a
cool tool it's got a lot of things you
can do with it
and we talked about the fact that it can
also hold things that are not
values and we'll call this array s for
strings
equals np.array
put our setup in there brackets
and let's go china
um india
usa uh mexico
it doesn't matter we can make whatever
we want on here and if we print that out
and we run this you can see that we get
another numpy of ray china india usa
mexico
it even gives us our d type of a u6
and a lot of times when you're messing
with data we'll call this array r
for range just to kind of keep it
uniform
np dot a range
so this is a command inside numpy to
create a range of numbers
and if you're testing data maybe you
want maybe you have equal time
increments that are spaced a certain
point apart but in this case we're just
going to do integers
and we're going to do a set up from 0
20 skipping every other one and we'll
print it out and see what that looks
like
and you can see here we have 0 2 4 6 8
10 12 14 16 18 like you expected it
skips every one
and just a quick note
there's no 20 on here uh why well this
starts at
0 and counts up to 20.
so if you're used to another language
where explicitly says
less than or less than equal to 20 like
for x equals
0 x plus plus
x is less than 20. that's what this is
it just assumes x is less than 20 on
here
and if we want to create a very uniform
set you know 0 2
4 6 what happens if i want to create
numbers
from 0 to 10 but i need 20 increments in
there
we can do that with line space so we can
create um
an r uh we'll call this l
equals i don't think we'll actually use
any of this again so i don't know why
i'm
creating unique identifiers for it uh
but we'll do np
lin space
and we're going to do 0 to 10 or 0 to 9
remember it doesn't it goes up to 10 and
then we want to let's say we have 20
different um increments in there so
we're creating a
we have a data set and we know it's over
a certain time period and we need to
divide that time period by 20
and it happens to just have 10 pieces in
it
and here we go you can see right here we
have 20 or has 20 pieces in it but it's
over 10 years
we got divided in the middle and you can
see it does it goes 0.52
remember the others are 10 on the end so
it goes up to 10.
uh and then we can also do random
there's np.random
if you're doing neural networks uh
usually you start it by seeding it with
random numbers
and we'll just do np.random and we'll
just call this array
we'll stop giving it unique numbers
we'll print that one out and run it
and you can see we have random numbers
they are
zero to one so you'll see that all these
numbers are under one
and you can easily alter that by
multiplying them out or something like
that if you want to do like 0 to 100
you can also round them up if it's
integer 0 to 100 there's all kinds of
things you can do but generates
a random float between 0 and 1. and you
have a couple options you could reshape
that
or you can just generate them in
whatever shape you want
and so we can see here we did three and
four
and so you can see three rows by four
variables
same thing as doing a reshape of 12
variables to 3 and 4.
and if you're going to do that you might
need an empty data set
i have had this come up many times
or i need to start off with 0 and i
don't know you know because i'm gonna be
adding stuff
in there or it might be zero and one
where one is uh
if you're removing the background of an
image you might want the background is
zero
and then you figure out where the image
is and you set all those boxes to one
and you create a mask
so creating masks over images is really
big and doing that with
a numpy array of zero and we can also uh
give it a space and we'll just do this
all in one shot this
time and we'll do the same thing like we
did before
zeros and in this case we'll do uh two
comma three
and so when we run this
i forgot the asterisks around it i knew
it was forgetting something there we go
so when we run this uh you can see here
we have
our ten zeros in a row and maybe this is
a mask for an image
and so it has a two rows of three
digits in it so it's a very small image
a little tiny pixel
and maybe you're looking to do something
the opposite way
instead of creating a mask of zeros and
filling in with
ones maybe you want to create a mask of
ones
and fill them in with zeros and we'll
just do
just like we did before with the three
comma four and when we run this you'll
see it's all ones
and we could even do this even maybe
we'll do it this way
let's do 10
10 by 10 icon and then you have your
three colors
so creates quite a large array there for
doing pictures and stuff like that when
you add that third dimension in
if we take that off it's a little bit
easier to see
we'll do 10 again
and you can easily see how we have 10
rows of 10 ones
and you can also do something like
create an array
and we'll do 0 1 2
and then in this array um we actually
print it right out we want a repeat
so you can actually do a repeat of the
array and maybe you need this array
let's repeat it three times so there's
our repeat of an array repeat three
times
and if we run this you'll see we have
zero zero zero one one one two two two
and whenever i think of a repeat i don't
really think of repeating being the
first digit three times the second digit
i really always think of it as
zero one two zero one two zero one two
it catches me
every time but the actual code for that
one
is going to be tile and again if we do a
range
three and we run this
you can see how you can generate one
zero one two zero one two zero one two
and if you're dealing with um an
identity
matrix um we can do that also if you're
big on you're doing your matrixes
and we'll just uh identity i guess we'll
go ahead and spell it out today any
tricks
and the command we're looking for is um
i e y e and we'll do three and then
we'll just go ahead and print this out
there we go there's our identity matrix
and it comes out by
a three by three array because there's
our matrix
and then it puts the ones down the
middle and for doing your different
matrix math
and we can manipulate that a little bit
too
we talk about matrixes
we might not want ones across the middle
in which case we now have
the diagonal so we can do an np dot
diagonal
and we do a diagonal let's put in the
diagonal
one two three four five and when we run
this
again this generates a value and by just
putting that value in there's the same
as putting print around it or putting
array equals and then print array
and you can see it generates a diagonal
one two three four five and there's your
your beginning of your matrix array for
working with matrixes
and we can actually go in reverse let's
create an array
equals remember our random
random.random and we'll do a five by
five array
oops there we go five by
five and just so you can see what that
looks like
helps if i don't miss type the numbers
which in this case i just need to take
out the brackets and there you go you
have your your five by five array
set up in there and we can now because
we're working with uh matrixes
we might want to do this in reverse and
extract the diagonals which would be the
point
seven nine the point six seven eight and
so on
and we simply type in np.diagonal
and we put our array in there and this
will of course print it out because it
returns it as a variable
and you can see here here's our diagonal
going across from our matrix
and we did talk about shape earlier if
you remember you can do
print the shape out you can also do the
dimensions
so in dimensions very similar to shape
it comes out and just has two dimensions
we can also look at the size so if we do
size on here
we can run that and you can see has a
size of 25 two dimensions and of course
5x5
and that was from the shape from earlier
that we looked at
there's our five by five shape and if
you remember earlier we did
random well you can also do random
i talked a little bit about manipulating
zero to one and how you can get
different answers
you can also do straight for the integer
part and we'll do minus
10 to 10
4 and so we're going to generate random
integers between minus 10 to 10.
we're going to generate four of those
once when we run that we have seven
minus three minus six minus three
they're all between minus ten and ten
and there's four of them
and now we jump into some of the
functionality of
arrays which is really great because
this is where they come in
here's your array and you can add 10 to
it and if i run this
there takes my original array from up
here
with the integers and adds 10 to all of
those values so now we have
oh this is the decimal that's right this
is a random decimal i had stored an
array
but this takes a random decimal the
random numbers i had from 0 to 1
and adds 10 to them and we can just as
easily do
minus 10.
we could even do
times two
and we could do divide by two and it
would it'll take that
random number we generated and cut in
half so now all these numbers are under
0.5
another way you can change the numbers
to what you need on there
and as you dig deeper into numpy we can
also do exponential
so as an exponential function which
would generate some interesting numbers
off of the random
so we're taking them to the power i
don't even remember what the original
numbers in the
array work because we did the random
numbers up there here's our original
numbers
and if you build an exponential on there
this is where you get e to the x on this
and just like you can do e to the x
you can also do the log so if you're
doing logarithmic functions
that reinforce learning you might be
doing some kind of log setup on there
and you can see the logarithmic
of these different ray numbers
and if you're working with log base 2
you can do you can just change it in
there in p log 2. you have to look it up
because this is not log 1 2 3 4 5.
it is log and log 2 so just a quick note
that's not a variable going in that is
an actual command
there's a number of them in there and
you'll have to go look and see
what the documentation is but you can
also do log
10. so here's log value 10.
some other really cool functions you can
do with this is your
sine so we can take a sine value of all
of our different
values in there and if you have sine you
of course have
cosine we can run that
so here's the cosine of those and if
you're doing activations
in your numpy array and you're doing a
tangent activation
there's your tangent for that and the
tangent activation is actually from
neural networks that's one of the ways
you can activate it because it forms a
nice
curve between uh from whether you're
generating
one to negative one with some
discrepancy in the middle
just jumping a little bit in there into
neural networks
and then we get into let me just put the
array back out there so we can see it
while we're doing this as we're getting
into this you can also sum the values so
we have np
sum and you can do a summation of all
the values in this array
and you'll see that if you added all
these together they'd equal 12.519
and so on i don't know what the whole
setup is in there
but you can see right here the the
summation of this one of the things you
can also do is by axes so we could do
axes
equals zero and if we run
the summation of the axis equals zero
and you can think of that in numpy
as the rows so that would be or
you can think of that in numpy as being
the columns we're summing these columns
going across
and you can also change this to one and
now we're summing the rows
and so that is the summation of this row
and so forth and so forth going down
and maybe you don't need to um
know the summation maybe what you're
looking for is the minimum
so here's our minimal you're looking for
and this comes up a lot because you have
like your errors we want to find the
minimal error
inside of this array and just like um
the other one we can do axes equals zero
and you can see here .0645 is the
smallest number in this first column is
.0645 and so on
and if you have a minimum well you might
also want to know the max maybe we're
looking for the maximum profit
and here we go you can see maximum 0.79
is the maximum on this first column
and just like we did before you can
change this to a one
on axes you can take the axes out of
here
and just find the max value for the
whole array and the max value in here
was 0.8344 so on so on
and since we're talking data analytics
uh we want to go ahead and look at the
mean
uh pretty much the same as the average
this is the mean across the whole thing
and just like we did before we could
also do axes equals zero
and then you'll see this is the mean of
this axes and so on
and we have mean we might want to know
the median
and there's our median our most common
numbers if we have median we might want
to know the standard deviation
or if we have the average a lot of times
you do the means and the standard
deviation
we can run that and there's our standard
deviations along the axes
we can also do it across the whole array
if we're going to do standard deviations
there's also
variance which is your var
and there's our variance across the
different levels
and so if we looked at that we looked at
variance we looked at standard deviation
the median and the means
there's more but those are the most
common ones used with data analytics
and then going through your data and
figuring out what you're going to
present to the shareholders
and some other things we can do is we
can actually take slices
uh you'll hear that terminology and a
slice
might be um like we have a five by five
array but maybe we don't want the whole
array maybe we want
from one on we don't want the zero in
there so we got
up to four and maybe on the second part
we just
want two to row three
and see this notation right here says
one to the end
and if we run this you can see how that
generates a single row
to the end and then row two and three
now remember it doesn't include
three that's why we only get the one
column
so if you wanted two and three you would
need to go ahead and go two to four
so it goes up to four we could also do
this in reverse
just like we learned earlier we can go
minus one whoops
and when we go to minus one it's the
same thing because we have zero one two
three four this is the same thing as two
to four it goes two to the last one
also very common with arrays is you're
going to want to sort them so we still
have our array up here
that we randomly generated and we might
want to
sort it and we'll go and throw an axis
back in there
axes equals one if we run this you can
see from the axes that it sorts it
uh the point two being the lowest value
to the highest value
by the row we can also change this of
course to axis zero
if you're sorting it by column so maybe
your values are based on columns
and then of course you can do the whole
array and we can sort that
don't usually do that but you know i
guess sometimes you might that might
come up
and so you can see right here we have a
nice sorted array
uh something else let's just go ahead
and reprint our array so we can look at
it again
starting at too many boxes up there
something else you can do with an array
is we can take and transpose it
this comes up more than you would think
when you transpose it you'll see that
the rows in the column are transposed so
where
0.79.57.064
is the column now we've switched it and
we have 0.79.42
as the index
you can see this really more dramatic if
we take a slice
and we'll just do a slice of the first
couple
and then we'll just do all the other the
full rows and if we run this
you can see how it comes up a little bit
different and we'll just do the same
slice up here so you can see how those
two look
next to each other there we go there's
our slice
run and so you can see the slice comes
up and it has a
one two three four five columns now we
have one two three four
five rows and three columns versus three
rows
and the original version when they first
started putting this
together was a function so the original
version was transpose
and this still works you can still see
it generates the same value as just a
capital t
so many times we flip this data because
we'll have an x y value
or we'll have an image or something like
that and it's being read
one way into the next process and the
next one needs it the opposite
so this actually happens a lot you need
to know how to transpose the data really
quick
and we can go ahead oh let's just take
here's our transpose we'll just stick
with the transpose on here
and instead of doing it this way we
might need to do something called
flattening
why would you flatten your data if this
is an array going into
a neural network you might want to send
it in as one set of values instead of
two rows
and you can see here is all the values
as a single array
it just flattens it down into one array
so we covered our scientific means
transpose
median some different variations on here
some of the other things we want to do
is what happens if we want to append
to our array so let's create a new array
i'm getting tired of looking at the same
set of random numbers we generated
earlier
so we'll go ahead and create a new array
here something a little simpler so it's
easier to see what we're doing
and four five six seven eight uh that's
good enough i'll just do four five six
seven eight
and if we print this array there it is
four five six seven eight
and we might wanna append something to
the array
so we have our array we need to extend
it you gotta be very careful
about appending things to your array and
there's a number of reasons for
that one is run time
because of the way the numpy ray is set
up
a lot of times you build your data and
then push it into the numpy array
instead of continually adding on to
the array and then it also usually it
automatically generates a copy
for protecting your data so there's a
lot of reasons to be careful about
appending this way
but you can certainly do it and we can
just take our array we're going to
create a new array array
1 and if we print array 1 and we append
8 to it
you'll see 4 5 6 7 and then there's our
8 appended onto the end
and if you want to append something to
an array um you'd probably
also want to whoops
array one let's try that again there we
go now we have the eight appended on to
the end
so you can see four five six seven eight
and then we pinned it another eight on
there
and if you're going to append something
you might want to
go ahead and insert instead of appending
it might be you need to keep a certain
order
and we can do the same thing we do our
array
and we're going to pin or insert
at the beginning and let's go ahead and
insert uh one two three
one two three and we go ahead and print
our array two
we run it and you can see one two three
a pin is inserted at the beginning
inserts a lot more powerful and that you
can put it anywhere in the array we can
move it to the one spot
and there we go one two three we can do
a minus one just for fun
and you'll see it comes up one two three
and we're counting backwards by one
imagining do a minus zero and run
this and it turns out that minus zero
puts it back at the beginning because
that's why it registers a zero just
takes a minus sign off
and just like we add numbers on we might
want to delete numbers
and so let's do an np dot delete
well let's keep it a little bit make it
a little easy here to watch we'll go
ahead and create an array three
and we'll do np delete and we're just
working with array
uh two and we want to do is delete
zero space uh so if you look at this
here's our array two our array two
starts with 1
and when we delete the space on here
and print that out we deleted the 1
right out of there
and we can also do something like this
where we can do it as a slice
and we can do let's do one comma three
and if we run one comma three you'll see
we've deleted the one space
and the three space out which deleted
our two and four
now keep in mind when you're messing
with
adding lines and deleting lines
you have to be really careful because
there's a time element involved
as far as where the date is coming from
and it's really easy to delete the wrong
data and corrupt what you're working on
or to insert stuff where you don't want
it
so there's always a warning when we talk
about manipulating numpy arrays
and just like anything else we're doing
we'll create an
array c which equals we'll just do
our um our numpy array then we just
created our number array 3
and we can do copy so you can make a
copy of it
maybe you want to protect your original
data or maybe you're making a mask and
so you copy the array
and then the new array make all these
alterations and change it from values to
zero to one
to mask over the first one and of course
we if we do
array c since it equals a copy of
array three it's the same thing one
three five six seven eight
and now we're getting into uh combine
and split arrays
i end up doing a lot of this and i don't
know how many times i end up fiddling
with this and having
a mess so but
but you do it a lot you know you combine
your arrays you split them you might
need one set of data for one thing
another set of data for the other
so let's go and create two arrays array
1 or a2
and i want you to note in the
terminology we're going to look for is
concatenate what that means is we're
going to take
um we'll call this a ray cat i like a
raycat
there we go our array cat
our concatenated array
we're taking array one and two and it's
very important to really pay attention
to your axes and your counts
i can't merge two arrays that have like
the if their axes are messed up and i'm
merging on
axis zero it's going to give me an error
and i'll have to reshape them so you got
to make sure that whatever you're
concatenating together works
and what that means as you can see here
we have one two three four
one two three four and then five six
seven eight five six seven eight along
the zero axes
these each are four values so it's a two
by four value
and if we go ahead and switch this to
one you can see how this that flips it a
little bit so now we have one two three
four five six seven eight
it's interesting that we chose that one
if i did something like this
where this is now there we go
and we concatenate it um run this
and it gives me an answer okay because i
have two by two and i'm using axes one
but if i switch this to axis zero where
now it's got
3 and 5 it gives me an error
so you've got to be really careful on
that to make sure that your whatever
axes you are
putting together that they match
so like i said this one oops x is 1.
axis 1 has two entities and since we're
going on axes 1 or by row
you can see that it lets it merge it
right onto the n there
and you could imagine this if this was a
xy plot of value
or the x value going in and the
predicted y value coming out
and then you have another prediction and
you want to combine them this works
really easy for that
and we'll go back and let's just put
this back to where we had it
oops i forgot how many changes i made
there we go
um just put it oops i messed up in my
concatenation order here
[Music]
there we go
okay so you can see that we went through
the different concatenation
axes is really important when you're
doing your concatenation values on here
and we'll switch this back to one just
because i like the looks of that better
there we go
two rows now there are
other commands in here so we can do
cat v equals npv
v stack this is nothing more than your
concatenation
but instead we don't have to put the
axes in there
because it's v stands for vertical and
so if we print out
cat v and we run this
you can see we get the one two three
four one two three four and that would
be the same as making this axis zero for
vertical stack
and if you're going to have a vertical
stack you can also have an
h stack so if we change this
to from v stack to oops here we go
h stack and we'll just change this from
cat to cat
and i run this
it's the same as doing axes zero the
process is identical in the background
um this is like a legacy setup uh your v
stack and your h stack
most people just use concatenate and
then put the axes in there because it's
much
uh has a lot more clarity and is more
more commonly used nowadays
the last section in numpy we're going to
cover uh
is underst is kind of data exploration
um and they'll make a little bit more
sense in just a moment
sometimes they call them set operations
but let's say we have an array
one two three four five six three
whatever it is uh things we generate a
nice little array here
and what i want to go ahead and do is
find the unique
values in that array so maybe
i'm generating what they call a one hot
encoder
and so these values then all become i
need to know how long my bit
array is going to be so each word how
many how many
each word is represented by a number and
then i want to know just how many of
those words are in there if we're doing
word count very popular thing to do
and you can see here when we do unique
we have 1 two three four five six those
are our unique values
uh some of the things we can do with the
unique values is we can also instead of
doing just
unique we can do uniques
our new unique values and counts of each
unique value
and this is very similar to what we just
did up here where we
we're doing np unique but we're going to
add a little bit more into there
and it's just part of the arguments in
this and we want to do return
counts equals true
so instead of just returning the unique
values
we want to know how many of those unique
values are in each one
and we'll go ahead and print our uniques
and print our counts
when we run that you can see here we
have our unique value one two three four
five six
just like we had before and then there's
two of the first of two ones two twos
two threes two fours one five two sixes
and so on
and you can go through and actually look
at that if you want to count them
but a quick way to find out your
distribution of different values
so you might want to know how often the
word the is used versus the word and
if each word is represented as a unique
number
and along the set variables we might
want to know
let me just put a note up here we're
going to start looking at
intersection and we might want to also
know
differentiation
and uh neither
so when we're whoops neighbor neither
um so what we're looking at now is we
want to know hey where do these two
arrays intersect and we have 1 2 3 4
five
three four five six seven we might want
to know what is common between the two
arrays
and so when we do that we have np
intersect and it's a 1d array
one dimensional array
and then we need to go ahead and put
array 1
array 2. and if we run this
we can see they intersect at three four
five that's what they have
common uh and because we're going to go
ahead and go through these
and look at a couple different options
let's change this from intersect 1d
and we'll do the same thing we'll go
ahead and print this
so we might want to know the
intersection where they have
commonalities
another unique word is union of 1d
so instead of intersect we want to know
all the values that are in both of them
so here's our union of 1d when we run
that you can see we have one two three
four five six seven so it's all the
different values in there
and the last one of the last words we
have two more to go
as we want to know what the set
difference is
uh and so that's where the you'll see
that if you remember set we talked about
that being the
what they call these things um so the
set difference
of a 1d array when we run that you can
see that one
is only in one array and two is only in
one array
and if we want to know what's in array 1
but not in array 2 we might want to know
what is in array 1 but not 2 and what's
in 2 but not
1 and this would be the set x
or 1d on here so we have the
four different options here where we can
do an intersection what do they both
have in common we can do a union
what are all the unique values in both
arrays
we can see the difference what's in
array one but not
array two so set diff one d and then
set x or what is not in one but is in
two and what is in not in two but in one
so we dug a lot in numpy because we're
talking
there's a lot of different little
mathematical things going on in numpy
a lot of this can also be done in pandas
although usually the heavy lifting is
left for numpy because that's what it's
designed for
let's go ahead and open up another
python3
setup in here and so we want to explore
what happens when you want to display
this this is where it starts getting
in my opinion a little fun because
you're actually playing with it and you
have something to show people
and we'll go ahead and rename this we're
going to call this pandas
and pie plot so pandas pie plot
just so we can remember for next time
and we want to go ahead and import the
necessary libraries
we're going to import pandas as pd now
remember this is a data frame
so we're talking rows and columns and
you'll see how
pandas work so nicely when you're
actually showing data to people
and then we're going to have numpy in
the background numpy works with pandas
so a lot of times you just import them
by default
seaborn sits on top of the matplot
library
so sometimes we use the seaborn because
it kind of extends it's one of the
100 packages that extends the matplot
library probably the most commonly used
because it has a lot of built-in
functionality
almost by default i usually just put
cborn in there in case i need it
and of course we have matplot library as
pi plot
as plt and note we have as
pd as np as sns as plt
those are pretty standard so when you're
doing your imports i would probably keep
those just so other people can read your
code and it makes sense to them that's
pretty much a standard nowadays
and then we have the strange line here
it says
ambersign matplot library inline
that is for jupiter notebook only so if
you're running this
in a different package you'll have a
pop-up when it goes to display the map
plot library
you can with the most current version of
jupiter usually leave that out
and it will still display it right on
the page as we go and we'll see what
that looks like
and then we're going to go ahead and
just do the seaborn the sns.set
and we're going to set the color codes
equals true let them
just keep the default one so we don't
have to think about it too much
and we of course have to run this the
reason we run this is because these
values are all
set if we don't run this and i access
one of these
afterward it will crash the cool thing
about
jupiter notebooks is if you forgot to
import one of these you forgot to
install it because you do have to
install this under your anaconda setup
or whatever setup you're in
you can flip over to anaconda and run
your install for these
and then just come back and run it you
don't have to close anything out
and we'll go ahead and paste this one in
here real quick we have car
equals pd dot read underscore csv
and then we have the actual path
this path of course will vary depending
on what you
are working with so it's wherever you
save the file at
and you can see here i have like my
onedrive documents simply learn
python data analytic using python
slash car csv it's quite a long file
when we open that up what we get is we
get
a csv file and we have the make the
model the year
the engine fuel type engine horsepower
cylinders and so on and this is just a
comma separated file so each row is like
a row of data
think of it as a spreadsheet
and then each one is a column of data on
here and
as you can see right here it has the
make model so it has columns for a
header on here
now your pandas just does an excellent
job of
automatically pulling a lot of this in
so when you start seeing the pandas on
here
you realize that you are already like
halfway done with getting your data in
i just love pandas for that reason numpy
also has it you can load a csv
directly into numpy but we're working
with pandas
and this is where it really gets cool is
i can come down here
and i can print remember our print
statement we can actually get rid of it
and we're just going to do car head
because it's going to print that out
the head is going to print the top
values of
that data file we just ran in and so you
can see right here
it does a nice printout it's all nice
and inline because we're in jupyter
notebook
i can scroll back and forth and look at
the different data
and just like we expected we have our
column and it brought the header right
in
one thing to note is the index it
automatically created an index 0 1 2
3 4 and so on and we're just looking at
the head so we've got 0 1 2 3
4. you can change this you might want to
just look at the top two we can run that
there's our top two bmws
another thing we can do is instead of
head we can do tail
and look at the last three values that
are in that
data file and uh you can see right here
it numbered them all the way up to 11
913 oh my goodness they put a lot of
data in this file
i didn't even look to see how big the
file was so you can really easily get
through and view the different data in
here
when you're talking about big data
you almost never just print out car
in fact let's see what happens when we
do if we run this and we just run the
car
it's huge in fact it's so big that the
pandas automatically truncates it and
just does head plus tail
so you can see the two so we really
don't want to look at the whole thing
i'm going to go back to let's stick with
the head
displaying our data there we go so
there's a head of our data gives us a
quick look
to see what's actually in there i can
zoom out if we want so you can actually
get a better view although we'll keep it
zoomed in so you can see the code i'm
working on
and then from the data standpoint we
course want to look at
data types what's going on with our data
what does it look like
now this you know you show your when
you're talking to your shareholders
they like to see these nice easy to read
charts they look like a spreadsheet
so it's a nice way of displaying pieces
of the chart we talk about the
data types now we're getting into the
data science side of it what are we
working with well we have
make model we have an integer 64 for the
year
engine fuel type is an object if we go
up here you can see that there
most of them are um like you know it's a
set
manual rear wheel drive uh so they might
be very
limited number of types in there uh and
so forth and you'll it's either gonna be
a float64 an integer or an object is the
way it's going to read it on here
and the next thing you're going to know
is like your columns
and since it loaded the columns
automatically we have here
the make the model the year the engine
the size all the way up to the
msrp
and just out of something you'll see
come up a lot
is whenever you're in pandas and you
type in dot values
it converts it from a pandas uh list to
a numpy array
and that's true of any of these uh so
then you end up in a numpy array
so you'll see a little switch in there
in the way that the data is actually
stored and that's true of any of these
in this case
we want car dot columns you have a total
list of your car columns
and like any good data scientist
we want to start looking at analytical
summary of the data set what's going on
with our data
so we can start trying to piecemeal it
together so we can do car
describe and then we'll do is we'll do
include
equals all so a nice panda command is to
describe your data
if you're working with r this should
start looking familiar
and we come down here and you can see
count there's a
make the model the year how many of each
one
how many unique values of each one the
top value of each one what's most common
the frequency
the mean clearly on some of these it's
an object so really can't
tell you what the average is you know
it'd just be the top ones the average i
guess
the year what's the average year on
there all this stuff comes down here
your standard deviation
your minimum value your maximum value
what's in the lower quarter 50 percent
mark where's that line at
and what's in the upper 75 percent the
top 25
going into the max now this next part is
just
cool uh this is what we always wanted
computers to be back like in the 90s
instead of 5 000 lines of code to do
this maybe not 5
000. all right i built my own plot
library back in 95 and the amount of
code for doing a simple plot
was um i don't know probably about 100
lines of code
this is being done in one line of code
we have our car
which is our pandas we generated that
it's our data frame
and we have dot hist for histogram
that is the power of seaborn now it's
still going to generate a numpy
graph but seaborn sits on top and then
we can do the figure size
this is just um so it fits nicely on the
paper on here and we do something simple
like this and you can see here where it
comes up and does say matplot library
and does subplots and everything
but we're looking at a histogram of all
the different
pieces in our database and we have our
engine cylinders
that's always a good one because you can
see like they have some that are they
had
a null on there so they came out as zero
maybe a couple maybe one of them had a
two cylinder engine away back when
four is a common six a little less
common and then you see the eight
cylinder
uh 12 cylinder engines well it's got to
be a speedster or something
but you can see right here just breaks
it down so now you have
how many cars with how many whatever it
is cylinders
horsepower uh and so on and it does a
nice job displaying it
you can see if you're working with your
uh um
you're going into your demo it's really
nice just to be able to type that in and
boom
there it is it can see it all the way
across
and we might want to zero in and use
like a box plot and this time we'll go
ahead and call the
seaborn sns box plot and we're going to
go ahead and do
vehicle size in versus engine horsepower
xy plot
and the data comes from the car so if we
run this
we end up with a nice box plot you see
our mid-size
compact and large you can see the
variation there's our outlier showing up
there on the compact
that must be a high-end sports car a
large car might have a couple engines
and again we have all these outliers and
then your deviation on them
powerful and quick way to zero in on one
small piece
of data and display it for people who
need to have it reduced to something
they can see and look at
and understand and that's our seabourn
box plot or
dot sns.box plot and then if we're going
to back
out and we want a quick look at what
they call pair plotting
we can run that and you can see with the
seaborn it just does all the work for
you
it takes just a moment for it to pull
the data in and compile it
and once it does it creates a nice grid
um in this grid
if you look at this one space here which
is you might not be able to see the
small number it says engine horsepower
this is engine horsepower uh to the year
was built
and it's just flipped so everything to
the right of the middle diagonal is just
the rotation of what's on the left and
as you expect
the engine horsepower gets bigger and
bigger and bigger
as time goes on so the the year it was
built the further up in the year the
more likely you are to have a heavy
horsepower engine
and you can quickly look at trends
with our pair plot coming up and look
how fast that was that was it took a
couple
a moment to process but right away i get
a nice view of all these different
information which i can look at visually
and kind of
see how things group and look now if i
was doing a meeting
i probably wouldn't show all the data
one of the things i've learned over the
years is people myself
included love to show all our work you
know we are taught in school show all
your work prove what you know
the ceo doesn't want to see a huge uh
grid of
of graphs i guarantee it so we want to
do is we want to go ahead and drop
the stuff that might not be interested
in and we're gonna i'm not really a car
person
a guy in the back is obviously so you
have your engine fuel type we're gonna
drop that we're gonna drop market
category vehicle style popularity number
of doors vehicle size
and we have the axes in here if you
remember from numpy
we have to include that axis to make it
clear what we're working on that's also
true with pandas
and then we'll look at just that what it
looks like from the head
and you can see that we dropped out
those categories and now we have the
make
model year and so forth and we took out
the engine fuel type market category etc
and this should look familiar to you now
when you start working with pandas
i just love pandas for this reason look
how easy it is it just displays it as a
nice
spreadsheet for you you can just look at
it and view it very easily
it's also the same kind of view you're
going to get if you're working in spark
or
pi spark which is python for spark
across big data
this is the kind of thing that they they
come up with this is why pandas is so
powerful
and we may look at this and decide we
don't like these columns and so you can
go in here and we can actually rename
the columns
simple command car equals car rename
columns equals
engine horsepower equals horsepower this
is just your standard
python dictionary so it just maps them
out
and you know instead of having like a
lengthy effect here we had
engine horsepower we just want
horsepower we don't need to know what's
the engine horsepower
engine cylinders we don't need to know
that it's for the engine because there's
only one thing we're describing if we're
talking about cars and that cylinders
and we'll go ahead and just run this and
again here's our car head and you can
see how that changed
we have model year in horsepower versus
model year
engine horsepower engine cylinders and
just cylinders
again we want to keep reducing this so
it's more
and more readable the more readable you
get it the better
and of course we can also adjust the
size a little bit so that
when it prints out instead of splitting
it on two lines we get like a single
line we can do that also
that's just your control mouse up or
plus sign
you use in chrome that's a chrome
command
and if you remember from numpy we had
shape well pandas works the same way
we can look at the shape of the data so
we now have
11 914 rows and 10 columns
so you see some similarities because
pandas is built on numpy
and questions that come up just like you
did in numpy we might want to know
duplicate rows
and so we can do car and look at this
switch here
we're doing a selection this is a pandas
selection with the brackets
but we want to select it based on car
dot duplicated
so how many duplicates on there so we're
starting to look a little bit different
as far as how we access
some of the data in here this can be a
logical statement and we get the number
of duplicate rows we have 989 rows by 10
columns again
and this is one of those troubleshooting
things that we end up doing
a lot more than we really feel like we
should
we might go ahead and do like a car
count just to see how many rows we're
dealing with
and then right after that we might want
to go ahead and say hey
let's drop duplicates so remember we did
all the duplicates on there so car
equals car
dot drop duplicates and then we can
print the head again
we'll just do car head here and you can
see the data on there
looks the same as before
and just note that we did car equals car
draw
duplicates there are commands in here
where you can do
where it changes the actual value and it
works on some of them and not on others
depending on what you're doing
but by default it always returns a copy
so when we
do this we're reassigning it to car and
you can see it's the same header but we
want to go ahead and do count
and see how the count changes let's go
ahead and run this and you can see here
instead of 11 914 we have 10
925 uh so we've removed
about a hundred cars that were
duplicated just slightly under a hundred
there
and then as we're prepping our data we
might wanna know
um car is null so it's going to count
the values of null and then we want to
sum that up
and when we do that we do the car is no
function dot sum
uh we end up with uh hp the horsepower
at 69 have null values and 30
have cylinders have no values now if you
don't put the sum
at the end it's just going to return a
mask with the true false of is it null
or is it not
by zero and one so you're summing up the
ones underneath
each column
and this of course then you have to
decide what you're going to do with the
null values there's a lot of different
options it might be that you need to put
in the
average or means maybe you want to put
in the median value
there's a lot of different ways to fill
it usually when you first start out with
the data a lot of them you just drop
your null values and you can see here
car.drop in a
which is equal to all and then we're
going to go ahead and count it and you
can see that we've dropped
almost another hundred values so from 10
1925
to 10 827 maybe 75 or so values
so we clean that this is really a big
part of cleaning data you need to know
how to get rid of your null values or at
least count them and what to do with
them
and of course if we go back to
counting our null values we should now
have
no null values there we go and you'll
see there's zero null values
i don't know how many times i've been
running a model that doesn't take no
values
and it crashes and i just sit there and
look at it trying to get why did that
crash it should have worked
it's because i forgot to remove the null
values
so we've been jumping around a lot we're
going to go back to
finding outliers and let's go ahead and
bring that back into our seaborn
and if you remember we did a box plot
earlier uh this time we're going to do a
box plot
just on the price and you can see here
our price value and we have the
deviation with the two thinner bars on
each side of the main value
and then as we get up here we have all
these outliers in fact we have one way
out here that's
probably a really expensive high-end car
is what we're looking at
if you were doing fraud analysis
you would be jumping on all over these
outliers why are these deviation from
the standard what are these people doing
again this is probably like i said a
really high-end expensive car out here
that's what we're looking at
and we can also look at the box plot
for the horsepower and we'll put that in
down here
and run that and you can see again
here's our horsepower and it just jumps
and there's these really odd
huge muscle cars out here that are
outliers
and we're going to jump into making this
a little bit more
as you start displaying your data or
your information to your shareholders
we're going to look at plotting a
histogram for the number of cars per
brand
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is we have with our car and go back over
here here we go
uh we have our make value counts largest
plot
and we want to do a kind equals bar uh
fig
size 10 5.
and right off the bat we jump up here we
see chevrolet
it's going against what was it it's uh
figure resolution
the value counts and we want the largest
value so here's our value counts
and compared to what the different cars
are chevrolet puts out a lot of
different kinds of cars
i didn't realize that they made that
many cars or different types
and then for readability let's go ahead
and add a title
number of cars by make number of cars
and make
if you had looked at this the first time
you would have been like well what the
heck am i looking at
well we're looking at the number of cars
by make and then you can see here now
we're talking about the type of cars
and the different ones are put out lotus
i guess only had a few different kinds
of cars over there
very high-end cars and then
as doing data analytics and as a data
scientist
one of the things i am most interested
in is the relationship between
the variables so this is always a place
to start
we want to know what's going on with our
variables and how they connect with each
other
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and set a figure
size because we want to make sure
it fits our graph we'll just go ahead
and set this one
plot figure set to figure size 2010.
if you never use the matplot library
which is sitting behind seaborne
whatever is in the plt this is what's
loaded it's like a
canvas you're painting on so the second
you load that
pi plot as plt anything you do to that
is affecting everything on it
and then we want to go ahead uh since
we're using seaborn
we'll go ahead and create a variable c
for
relationships or correspondence and car
dot
c-o-r-r that's a correlation in
seaborne on top of pandas again
one line and you get the whole
correlation on there
and because we're working with seaborn
let's put it into a nice heat map
if you're not familiar with heat maps
that means we're just using color
as part of our setup so we have a nice
visual
and we can see here that the seaborne
connected to the pandas prints out a
nice
chart we'll talk a little bit about the
color here in a second
it prints out a nice chart this is a
chart i look at as a data scientist
these are the numbers i want to look at
and we'll just highlight one of them
here's cylinders
versus horsepower the closer to one the
higher the correlation so 0.788
pretty high correlation between the
number of cylinders and how heavy the
horsepower
is i'm betting if you looked at the year
versus uh
horsepower um we just look at that one
here's year and horsepower
0.314 not as so much but if you combine
them you don't actually add them but if
you combine them you'll start to see an
increase in horsepower per year
and cylinders you could probably get a
correlation there and just like 0.78
is a positive correlation you might
notice if we look at cylinders
and or let's look at horsepower and
mileage
uh so if we go here to horsepower to
mileage you get a nice
um negative we'll do cylinders that's a
bigger number
with cylinders to the miles per gallon
it's a minus
0.6 so it's a negative correlation the
closer to minus 1 the more the negative
correlation is
and then the chart you would actually
show people is a nice
heat map this is all our colors and it's
just those numbers put into a heat map
the darker the color the higher the
correlation you can see
straight down the middle obviously the
year correlates directly with the air
horsepower with horsepower and so on
that's why it's a one the closer to the
one the higher the correlation between
the two pieces of data
now this is a good introduction pandas
goes way beyond this
most the functionality in numpy since
panda sits on it
is also in pandas and then it even has
additional
features in it and we use seaborne
pretty extensively
sitting on top over our pie plot so keep
in mind that our
pie plot has a ton of other features in
it that we didn't even touch on
in here we couldn't even if you had a
soul course in it
there's just so many things hidden in
there depending on what your domain
you're working on
but you can see here here's our seabourn
and here's our matplot library
that's all our graphics that we did and
then the seaborn
works really nicely with the pandas we
really like that
understanding linear regression linear
regression
is the statistical model used to predict
the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable
and the second one that we need to look
at closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest
possible accuracy if it's inaccurate we
can't use it
so it's very important we find out the
most accurate line we can get
since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data
we're going to jump back and take a look
at some euclidean geometry the simplest
form
of a simple linear regression equation
with one dependent
and one independent variable is
represented by
y equals m times x plus c
and if you look at our model here we
plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2
y being the dependent variable remember
that from before
and x being the independent variable so
y
depends on whatever x is m in this case
is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the y2
minus y1
and x2 minus x1 and finally we have c
which is the coefficient of the line
or where it happens to cross the zero
axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression
we're going to go back to plotting the
amount of crop yield
based on the amount of rainfall and here
we have
our rainfall remember we cannot change
rainfall
and we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall
so we have our independent and our
dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data
and then we look at that we put the red
point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year
and what's going on then we can guess
how good our crops are going to be
and we've created a nice line right
through the middle to give us a nice
mathematical formula
let's take a look and see what the math
looks like behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line
now before we dive into the math and the
formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study
and we actually apply some python script
that this math you're going to see here
is already done automatically for you
you don't have to have it memorized it
is however
good to have an idea what's going on so
if people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows
and find out how to draw the regression
line we're only going to do five
rows because if we did like the rainfall
with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics
so we'll go ahead and create our own two
sets of data
and we have our independent variable x
and our dependent variable
y and when x was 1 we got y equals 2
when x was 2 y was 4
and so on and so on if we go ahead and
plot this data on a graph
we can see how it forms a nice line
through the middle
you can see where it's kind of grouped
going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the
data coming in the x and the y the means
doesn't mean anything other than the
average
so we add up all the numbers and divide
by the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4
plus 5
over 5 equals 3 and the same for y we
get 4.
if we go ahead and plot the means on the
graph we'll see we get three comma four
which draws a nice line down the middle
a good estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line
now remember before i said you don't
have to have all these formulas
memorized or fully understand them even
though we're going to go into a little
more detail of how it works
and if you're not a math wiz and you
don't know if you've never seen the
sigma character before
which looks a little bit like an e
that's opened up
that just means summation that's all
that is so when you see the sigma
character it just means we're adding
everything in that row
and for computers this is great because
as a programmer
you can easily iterate through each of
the xy points
and create all the information you need
so in the top half you can see
where we've broken that down into pieces
and as it goes through the first two
points it computes
the squared value of x the squared value
of y and
x times y and then it takes all of x and
adds them up all of y adds them up
all of x squared adds them up and so on
and so on and you can see we have the
sum of
equal to 15 the sum is equal to 20 all
the way up to x
times y where the sum equals 66. this
all comes from our formula for
calculating a straight line where y
equals the slope
times x plus the coefficient c so we go
down below
and we're going to compute more like the
averages of these
and we'll explain exactly what that is
in just a minute and where that
information comes from is called the
square means error
but we'll go into that in detail in a
few minutes all you need to do is look
at the formula
and see how we've gone about computing
it line by line
instead of trying to have a huge set of
numbers
pushed into it and down here you'll see
where the slope
m equals and then the top part if you
read through the brackets you have the
number
of data points times the sum
of x times y which we computed one line
at a time there and that's just the 66
and take all that and you subtract it
from the sum of x
times the sum of y and those have both
been computed so you have 15
times 20. and on the bottom we have the
number of lines
times the sum of x squared easily
computed as
86 for the sum minus i'll take all that
and subtract
the sum of x squared and we end up as we
come across
with our formula you can plug in all
those numbers which is very easy to do
on the computer
you don't have to do the math on a piece
of paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6
and you'll get your c coefficient if you
continue to follow through that formula
you'll see it comes out as equal to 2.2
continuing
deeper into what's going behind the
scenes let's find out the predicted
values of
y for corresponding values of x using
the linear equation where
m equals 0.6 and c equals 2.2
we're going to take these values and
we're going to go ahead and plot them
we're going to predict them so y equals
0.6 times where x equals 1
plus 2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and
here the blue points represent the
actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y
values based on the model we created the
distance between the actual and
predicted values
is known as residuals or errors
the best fit lines should have the least
sum of squares of these errors
also known as e-square if we put these
into a nice
chart where you can see x and you can
see why what we actual values were
and you can see why i predict it you can
easily see where we take y
minus y predicted and we get an answer
what is the difference between those two
and if we square that
y minus y prediction squared we can then
sum those squared values
that's where we get the 0.64 plus the
0.36
plus 1 all the way down until we have a
summation equals 2.4
so the sum of squared errors for this
regression line is 2.4
we check this error for each line and
conclude the best fit line having the
least e
square value in a nice graphical
representation
we can see here where we keep moving
this line through the data points to
make sure
the best fit line has the least square
distance between the data points
and the regression line now we only
looked at the most
commonly used formula for minimizing the
distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points
like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors
root mean square error etc what you want
to take away from this is whatever
formula
is being used you can easily using a
computer programming and iterating
through the data
calculate the different parts of it that
way these complicated formulas you see
with the different summations and
absolute values are easily computed one
piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values
x and y well in the real world it's very
rare that you only have two values when
you're figuring out a solution
so let's move on to the next topic
multiple linear regression
let's take a brief look at what happens
when you have multiple
inputs so in multiple linear regression
we have
well we'll start with the simple linear
regression where we had y
equals m plus x plus c and we're trying
to find the value of
y now with multiple linear regression we
have multiple variables coming in
so instead of having just x we have x1
x2 x3 and instead of having just
one slope each variable has its own
slope attached to it
as you can see here we have m1 m2 m3 and
we still just have the single
coefficient
so when you're dealing with multiple
linear regression you basically take
your single linear regression
and you spread it out so you have y
equals m1 times
x1 plus m2 times x2 so on all the way to
m to the nth x to the nth and then you
add your coefficient
on there implementation of linear
regression now we get into my favorite
part
let's understand how multiple linear
regression works by implementing
it in python if you remember before we
were looking at a company
and just based on its r d trying to
figure out its profit
we're going to start looking at the
expenditure of the company we're going
to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r
d we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs
marketing costs and so on and from there
we're going to see if we can figure out
what the profit of that company is going
to be
to start our coding we're going to begin
by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression
we're going to take a look at the data
to see what we're playing with then
we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it
and just see how valid our solution is
so let's start with importing the basic
libraries
now i'm going to be doing this in
anaconda jupiter notebook a very popular
ide
i enjoy it's such a visual to look at
and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this
so break out your favorite python ide so
here we are in our jupyter notebook
let me go ahead and paste our first
piece of code in there and let's walk
through what libraries we're importing
first we're going to import numpy as np
and then i want you to skip one line and
look at import pandas as
pd these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np
and you have to almost have that for
your sk learn toolbox you always import
that right off the beginning
pandas although you don't have to have
it for your sklearn libraries it does
such a wonderful job of importing data
setting it up into a data frame so we
can manipulate it rather easily and it
has a lot of tools also in addition to
that so we usually like to use the
pandas when we can and i'll show you
what that looks like
the other three lines are for us to get
a visual of this data and take a look at
it
so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as
plt and then seaborn as sns
seborn works with the matplot library so
you have to always import matplot
library and then seaborn sits on top of
it
and we'll take a look at what that looks
like you could use any of your own
plotting libraries you want there's all
kinds of ways to look at the data
these are just very common ones and the
seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody
and the final line is the amber scion
map plot library inline that is only
because i'm doing an
inline ide my interface in the anaconda
jupiter notebook
requires i put that in there or you're
not going to see the graph when it comes
up
let's go ahead and run this it's not
going to be that interesting so we're
just setting up variables
in fact it's not going to do anything
that we can see but it is importing
these different
libraries and setup the next step is
load the data set and extract
independent and dependent variables
now here in the slide you'll see
companies equals pd.read csv and it has
a long
line there with the file at the end 1000
companies.csv
you're going to have to change this to
fit whatever setup you have
and the file itself you can request just
go down to the commentary below this
video
and put a note in there and simply learn
we'll try to get in contact with you and
supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself
so we're going to add this code in here
and we're going to see that i have
companies equals pd.reader
underscore csv and i've changed this
path to match my computer
c colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies dot
and then below there we're going to set
the x equals to companies
under the i location and because this is
companies as a pd
data set i can use this nice notation
that says
take every row that's what the colon the
first colon is comma
except for the last column that's what
the second part is or we have a colon
minus one
and we want the values set into there so
x is no longer
a data set a pandas data set but we can
easily extract the data from our pandas
data set with this notation
and then y we're going to set equal to
the last row
well the question is going to be what
are we actually looking at
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and we're going to look at the
companies dot
head which lists the first five rows of
data and i'll open up the file in just a
second so you can see where that's
coming from but let's look at the data
in here
as far as the way the pandas sees it
when i hit run
you'll see it breaks it out into a nice
setup this is what panda is
one of the things pandas is really good
about is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet
you have your rows and remember when
we're programming we always start with
zero
we don't start with one so it shows the
first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns
r and d spend administration marketing
spend
state profit it even notes that the top
are column names it was never told that
but pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows
why don't we go ahead and open this file
up in a csv so you can actually see the
raw data so
here i've opened it up as a text editor
and you can see at the top we have rnd
spend comma administration comma
marketing spin comma state comma profit
carriage return i don't know about you
but i'd go crazy trying to read
files like this that's why we use the
pandas
you could also open this up in an excel
and it would separate it since it is a
comma separated variable file but we
don't want to look at this one we want
to look at something we can read rather
easily so let's flip back and take a
look at that
top part the first five row now as nice
as this format
is where i can see the data to me it
doesn't mean a whole lot
maybe you're an expert in business and
investments and you understand
what 165 349 dollars and
twenty cents compared to the
administration cost of a hundred and
thirty six thousand eight hundred ninety
seven dollars and eighty cents so on so
on
it helps to create the profit of 192
261 and 83 cents that makes no sense to
me whatsoever
no pun intended so let's flip back here
and take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means
so at this point we're going to use a
single line of code to get a lot of
information so we can see where we're
going with this
let's go ahead and paste that into our
notebook and see what we got going and
so we have the visualization
and again we're using sns which is
pandas
as you can see we imported the map plot
library dot pi plot as plt
which then the seaborn uses and we
imported the seaborn as sns
and then that final line of code helps
us show this
in our inline coding without this it
wouldn't display and you could display
it to a file in other means and that's
the matte plot library in line with the
amber sign at the beginning so here we
come down to the single line of code
seaborn is great because it actually
recognizes the panda data frame
so i can just take the companies dot
core for coordinates
and i can put that right into the
seaborn and when we run this
we get this beautiful plot and let's
just take a look at what this plot means
if you look at this plot on mine the
colors are probably a little bit more
purplish and blue than the original one
we have the columns and the rows we have
r and d spending we have administration
we have marketing spending and profit
and if you cross index any two of these
since we're interested in profit if you
cross index profit with profit
it's going to show up if you look at the
scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence
so rnd spending is going to be the same
as
rnd spending and the same thing with
administration costs so right down the
middle
you get this dark row or dark um
diagonal row that shows that this
is the highest corresponding data that's
exactly the same and as it becomes
lighter there's less connections between
the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit
and next it has a very high correlation
with r d spending
which we looked at earlier and it has a
slightly less
connection to marketing spending and
even less to how much money we put into
the administration
so now that we have a nice look at the
data let's go ahead and dig
in and create some actual useful linear
regression models so that we can predict
values and have a better profit now that
we've taken a look at the visualization
of this data
we're going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values
so let's see what that looks like we're
going to set up our linear regression
model
in two steps the first one is we need to
prepare
some of our data so it fits correctly
and let's go ahead and paste this code
into our jupiter notebook and what we're
bringing in is we're going to bring in
the sklearn
pre-processing where we're going to
import the label encoder
and the one hot encoder to use the label
encoder we're going to create a variable
called label encoder and set it equal to
capital l
label capital e encoder this creates a
class that we can reuse
for transferring the labels back and
forth now about now you should ask what
labels are we talking about
let's go take a look at the data we
processed before and see what i'm
talking about here
if you remember when we did the
companies dot head and we printed the
top
five rows of data we have our columns
going across
we have column zero which is r and d
spending
column one which is administration
column two which is marketing spending
and column three is state and you'll see
under state we have new york california
florida now to do a linear regression
model it doesn't know how to process
new york it knows how to process a
number so the first thing we're going to
do is we're going to change that new
york california and florida
and we're going to change those to
numbers that's what this line of code
does here
x equals and then it has the colon comma
3
in brackets the first part the colon
comma means that we're going to look at
all the different rows so we're going to
keep them all together but the only row
we're going to edit
is the third row and in there we're
going to take the label coder
and we're going to fit and transform the
x
also the third row so we're going to
take that third row we're going to set
it equal to a transformation
and that transformation basically tells
it that instead of having
a new york it has a 0 or 1 or a 2. and
then finally we need to do a one
hot encoder which equals one hot ink or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x
and we go ahead and do that equal to one
hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation
preps our data force so it's completely
set the way we need it as just a row of
numbers
even though it's not in here let's go
ahead and print x
and just take a look what this data is
doing you'll see you have an array of
arrays
and then each array is a row of numbers
and if i go ahead and just do row 0
you'll see i have a nice organized row
of numbers that the computer now
understands
we'll go ahead and take this out there
because it doesn't mean a whole lot to
us it's just a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding
dummy variable trap this is very
important
why because the computer has
automatically transformed
our header into the setup and it's
automatically transferring
all these different variables so when we
did the encoder
the encoder created two columns
and what we need to do is just have the
one because it has both the variable and
the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x
equals x colon comma one colon
all this is doing is removing that one
extra
column we put in there when we did our
one hot encoder and our label encoding
let's go ahead and run that and now we
get to create our linear regression
model
and let's see what that looks like here
and we're going to do that in two steps
the first step is going to be in
splitting the data
now whenever we create a predictive
model of data we always want to split it
up so we have a training set
and we have a testing set that's very
important otherwise we'd be very
unethical without testing it to see how
good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model
and train it and set it up let's go
ahead and paste this next piece of code
in here
and i'll go ahead and shrink it down a
size or two so it all fits on one line
so from the sklearn module selection
we're going to import train test split
and you'll see that we've created four
completely different variables
we have capital x train capital x test
smaller case y train smaller case y
test that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different models usually see that a
capital x
and you see the train and the test and
the lowercase y what this
is is x is our data going in that's our
rnd span our administration our
marketing
and then y which we're training is the
answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity that's what we're going
to shoot for in this
tutorial the next part train test split
we take
x and we take y we've already created
those
x has the columns with the data in it
and y has a column with profit in it and
then we're gonna set the test size
equals point two that basically means
twenty percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're gonna put them off to
the side
so since we're using a thousand lines of
data that means that
200 of those lines we're going to hold
off to the side to test for later
and then the random state equals zero
we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this
it's not overly exciting so it's setting
up our variables but the next step
is the next step we actually create our
linear regression model now that we got
to the linear regression model
we get that next piece of the puzzle
let's go ahead and put that code in
there and walk through it
so here we go we're going to paste it in
there and let's go ahead and
since this is a shorter line of code
let's zoom up there so we can get a good
look and we have from the sklearn
dot linear underscore model we're going
to import linear regression
now i don't know if you recall from
earlier when we were doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back there and
take a look at that do you remember this
or we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this
summarization
and then we also looked at setting it up
with the different
lines and then we also looked all the
way down to
multiple linear regression where we're
adding all those formulas together
all of that is wrapped up in this one
section so what's going on here is i'm
going to create a variable called
regressor and the regressor equals the
linear regression that's a linear
regression model that has all that math
built in
so we don't have to have it all
memorized or have to compute it
individually and then we do the
regressor dot fit
in this case we do x train and y train
because we're using the training data
x being the data in and y being profit
what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line
we've created the whole linear
regression model and we fit the data to
the linear regression model and you can
see that when i run the regressor
it gives an output linear regression it
says copy x equals true
fit intercept equals true in jobs equal
one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model
now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it and if you remember we kept a bunch
of data aside
so we're going to do a y predict
variable and we're going to put in the x
test and let's see what that looks like
scroll up a little bit
paste that in here predicting the test
set results
so here we have y predict equals
regressor dot predict
x test going in and this gives us y
predict
now because i'm in jupiter inline i can
just put the variable up there
and when i hit the run button it'll
print that array out
i could have just as easily done print
why predict
so if you're in a different ide that's
not an inline setup like the jupyter
notebook you can do it this way print y
predict and you'll see that for the 200
different test variables we kept off to
the side
is going to produce 200 answers this is
what it says the profit are for those
200 predictions
but let's don't stop there let's keep
going and take a couple look we're going
to take just a short
detail here and calculating the
coefficients and the intercepts
this gives us a quick flash at what's
going on behind the line
we're going to take a short detour here
and we're going to be calculating the
coefficient
and intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice
about our regressor we created is it
already has a coefficients for us
we can simply just print regressor dot
coefficient
underscore when i run this you'll see
our coefficients here
and if we can do the regressor
coefficient we can also do the regressor
intercept and let's run that and take a
look at that this all came from the
multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into where it's
coming from
you can see the formula down here where
y equals m1 times x1 plus
m2 times x2 and so on and so on plus c
the coefficient so these variables fit
right into this formula
y equals slope 1 times column 1 variable
plus slope 2 times column 2 variable all
the way to the
m into the n and x to the n plus c the
coefficient
or in this case you have minus 8.89
to the power of 2 etc etc times the
first column and the second column and
the third column and then our intercept
is the minus
one zero three zero zero nine point boy
it gets kind of complicated when you
look at it this is why we don't do this
by hand anymore this is why we have the
computer to make these calculations easy
to understand
and calculate now i told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script
as you remember from the beginning i
said if we're going to divide this
information we have to make sure it's a
valid model that this model works and
understand how good it works
so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use
to predict how good our prediction is
and let's take a look what that looks
like in code and so we're going to use
this
from sklearn.metrics we're going to
import
r2 score that's the r squared value
we're looking at the
error so in the r2 score we take our y
test versus our y predict y
test is the actual values we're testing
that was the one that was given to us
that we know are true
the y predict of those 200 values is
what we think it was true and when we go
ahead and run this
we see we get a 0.9352 that's the r2
score now it's not exactly a straight
percentage
so it's not saying it's 93 percent
correct but you do want that
in the upper 90s o and higher shows that
this is a very valid prediction based on
the r2 score
and if r squared value of 0.91 or 92 as
we got on our model
remember it does have a random
generation involved this proves the
model is a good
model which means success yay we
successfully trained our model with
certain predictors and estimated the
profit
of the companies using linear regression
all right what is logistic regression
logistic regression
is an algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how
this works let's say your car has not
been serviced for quite a few years
and now you want to find out if it is
going to break down
in the future so this is like a
classification problem
find out whether your car will break
down or not
so how are we going to perform this
classification so here's how it looks
if we plot the information along the x
and y axis
x is the number of years since the last
service was performed and
why is the probability of your car
breaking down
and let's say this information was this
data rather was
collected from several car users it's
not just your car
but several car users so that is our
labeled
data so the data has been collected and
for for the number of years and when the
car
broke down and what was the probability
and that has been plotted along
x and y axis so this provides
an idea or from this graph we can find
out whether
your car will break down or not we'll
see how so first of all
the probability can go from zero to one
as you're aware
probability can be between zero and one
and
as we can imagine it is intuitive as
well
as the number of years are on the lower
side
maybe one year two years or three years
till
after the service the chances of your
car breaking down
are very limited right so for example
chances of your car breaking down
the probability of your car breaking
down within two years of your last
service are
0.1 probability similarly 3 years is
maybe 0.3 and so on but as the number of
years increases
let's say if it was six or seven years
there is almost a certainty that your
car
is going to break down that is what this
graph shows so this is an example of a
application of the classification
algorithm
and we will see in little details how
exactly logistic regression
is applied here one more thing needs to
be added here is that the dependent
variable's outcome is discrete so
if we are talking about whether the car
is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about
what we are looking at is whether the
car is going to break down
or not yes or no that is what we are
talking about
so here the outcome is discrete and not
a continuous value so this
is how the logistic regression curve
looks
let me explain a little bit what exactly
how exactly we are going to
determine the class at the outcome
rather
so for a logistic regression curve a
threshold has to be said
saying that because this is a
probability calculation
remember this is a probability
calculation and
the probability itself will not be 0 or
1 but
based on the probability we need to
decide what the outcome
should be so there has to be a threshold
like for example
0.5 can be the threshold let's say in
this case
so any value of the probability below
0.5
is considered to be 0 and any value
above 0.5
is considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1
and let's say an output of 0.29
is considered as 0 which means that the
car will not break down
so that's the way logistic regression
works now let's do a quick comparison
between
logistic regression and linear
regression because they both have
the term regression in them so it can
cause confusion
so let's try to remove that confusion so
what is linear regression linear
regression
is a process is once again an algorithm
for supervised learning however here
you're going to
find a continuous value you're going to
determine a continuous value it could be
the price of a real estate property
it could be your hike how much height
you're going to get or it could be
a stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete
compared to a yes or no kind of a
response that we are looking for
in logistic regression so this is one
example of
a linear regression let's say the hr
team
of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they
collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available
and the system learns from this it is
trained and it learns from this labeled
information
so that when a new employee's
information is fed
based on the rating it will determine
what should be the high so this is
a linear regression problem and a linear
regression
example now salary is a continuous
value you can get five thousand five
thousand five hundred
five thousand six hundred it is not
discrete
like a cat or a dog or an apple or a
banana
these are discrete or a yes or no these
are discrete values
right so this way you're trying to find
continuous values
is where we use linear regression so
let's say
just to extend on the scenario we now
want to find out whether this employee
is going to get a promotion
or not so we want to find out that is a
discrete problem right
a yes or no kind of a problem in this
case
we actually cannot use linear regression
even though we may have
labeled data so this is the label data
so based on the employee rating
these are the ratings and then some
people got the
promotion and this is the ratings for
which people did not get promotion that
is a no
and this is the rating for which people
got promotion
we just plotted the data about whether a
person has got
an employer's got promotion or not yes
no right so there is nothing in between
and what is the employee's rating okay
and ratings can be continuous that is
not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion
yes no okay so if we try to plot that
and
we try to find a straight line this is
how it would look
and as you can see it doesn't look very
right because
looks like there will be lot of errors
thus root mean square error
if you remember for linear regression
would be
very very high and also the the values
cannot go beyond
zero or beyond one so the graph should
probably look somewhat like this
clipped at zero and one but still the
straight line
doesn't look right therefore instead of
using
a linear equation we need to come up
with something different
and therefore the logistic regression
model looks
somewhat like this so we calculate the
probability
and if we plot that probability not in
the form of a straight line but we need
to use some other equation we will see
very soon what that equation is
then it is a gradual process right so
you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions
and then slowly uh at certain rating
they get promotion
so that is a gradual process and this is
how
the math behind logistic regression
looks
so we are trying to find the odds for a
particular
event happening and this is the formula
for finding the odds so
the probability of an event happening
divided by the probability of the event
not happening so p if it is the
probability of the event happening
probability of the person getting a
promotion and divided by
the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is one minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values
of the odds range from 0 to infinity so
when this probability
is 0 then the odds will the value of the
odds is equal to 0 and when the
probability becomes
1 then the value of the odds is 1 by
0 that will be infinity but the
probability itself remains between
0 and 1. now this is how an equation of
a straight line looks so y
is equal to beta0 plus beta1 x where
beta0 is the y-intercept and beta1 is
the
slope of the line if we take the odds
equation
and take a log of both sides then this
would look somewhat like this and the
term
logistic is actually derived from the
fact that
we are doing this we take a log of px by
1 minus px
this is an extension of the calculation
of odds that we have seen right
and that is equal to beta0 plus beta1 x
which is the equation of the straight
line and now from here if you want to
find out the value of px you will
see we can take the exponential on both
sides
and then if we solve that equation we
will get the equation
of px like this px is equal to 1 by
1 plus e to the power of minus beta0
plus beta1 x
and recall this is nothing but the
equation of the line which is equal to y
y is equal to beta0 plus beta 1 x so
that
this is the equation also known as the
sigmoid function and this is the
equation of the logistic regression
all right and if this is plotted this is
how the sigmoid curve
is obtained so let's compare
linear and logistic regression how they
are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved
or used to solve regression problems and
logistic regression is used to solve
classification problems
so both are called regression but linear
regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have
had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression
are continuous in nature whereas here
they are categorical or discrete in
nature
and linear regression helps to estimate
the dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression
it helps to calculate the probability or
the possibility of a particular event
happening and linear regression as the
name suggests
is a straight line that's why it's
called linear regression
whereas logistic regression is a sigmoid
function
and the curve is the shape of the curve
is
s it's an s-shaped curve this is another
example of
application of logistic regression in
weather prediction
whether it's going to rain or not rain
now keep in mind
both are used in weather prediction if
we want to find
the discrete values like whether it's
going to rain
or not rain that is a classification
problem we use logistic regression but
if we want to determine what is going to
be the temperature tomorrow then we use
linear regression so just keep in mind
that in weather prediction we actually
use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be
rain or not it's going to be sunny or
not it's going to snow or not these are
all
logistic regression examples a few more
examples
classification of objects this is a
again
another example of logistic regression
now here of course one distinction is
that
these are multi-class classification so
logistic regression is not used in
its original form but it is used in a
slightly different form
so we say whether it is a dog or not a
dog i hope you understand so instead of
saying is it a dog or a cat or an
elephant
we convert this into saying so because
we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog
or not a dog is it a cat or not a cat
so that's the way logistic regression
can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find
the survival rate of a patient so they
take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth
and they try to predict the rate of
survival
all right now finally let's take an
example and
see how we can apply logistic regression
to
predict the number that is shown in the
image so this is
actually a live demo i will take you
into jupiter notebook
and show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain
what we are trying to do so let's say
you have an 8x8 image
and there the image has a number one two
three four
and you need to train your model to
predict what this number is
so how do we do this so the first thing
is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model
so in this case we are using logistic
regression
so and then we provide a training set
to train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is
with the test data which means that like
any machine learning
process we split our initial data into
two parts training set and test set with
the training set we train our model
and then with the test set we test the
model then we get
good accuracy and then we use it for for
inference right so that is typical
methodology
of training testing and then deploying
of
machine learning models so let's uh take
a look at the code
and see what we are doing so i will not
go line by line but just take you
through some of the blocks so first
thing we do
is import all the libraries and then we
basically take a look
at the images and see what is the total
number of images
we can display using matplotlib some of
the images are a sample of these
images and then we split the data into
training and test as i mentioned earlier
and we can do some exploratory analysis
and
then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how
accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix
the heat map and use heat map for
visualizing this and
i will show you in the code what exactly
is the confusion matrix and how it can
be used for
finding the accuracy in our example we
got we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94
which is pretty good all right so what
is the confusion matrix
this is an example of a confusion matrix
and
this is used for identifying the
accuracy of
a classification model or like a
logistic regression model
so the most important part in a
confusion matrix
is that first of all this as you can see
this is a matrix and the size of the
matrix depends on how many
outputs we are expecting right so
the most important part here is that the
model will be
most accurate when we have the maximum
numbers in its diagonal like in this
case that's why it has
almost 93 94 percent because the
diagonal should have the maximum
numbers and the others other than
diagnose the cells other than the
diagonals should have
very few numbers so here that's what is
happening so there is a two here there
are
there's a one here but most of them
are along the diagonal this what does
this mean this means that
the number that has been fed is zero
and the number that has been detected is
also zero
so the predicted value and the actual
value are the same so
along the diagonals that is true which
means that
let's let's take this diagonal right if
the maximum number is here that means
that
like here in this case it is 34 which
means that
34 of the images that have been fed or
rather actually there are two
misclassifications in there so
36 images have been fed which have
number four
and out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four
and one has been predicted as number
eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two misclassifications
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum number should be in the
diagonal so if you have
all of them so for an ideal model which
has let's say 100 accuracy everything
will be only in the diagonal there will
be no numbers
other than zero in all other cells so
that is like a hundred percent
accurate model okay so that's uh just of
how to use this
matrix how to use this confusion matrix
i know the name
is a little funny sounding confusion
matrix
but actually it is not very confusing
it's very straightforward so you are
just plotting
what has been predicted and what is the
labeled information or what is the
actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all it is
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more
information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that
all of them have been predicted
correctly there have been 38 zeros
and the predicted value and the actual
value is exactly the same whereas
in this case right it has uh there are
i think 37 plus five yeah 42
have been fed the images 42 images
are of digit 3 and the accuracy
is only 37 of them have been accurately
predicted
three of them have been predicted as
number seven
and two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook
and see how the code looks so this
is the code in in jupiter notebook
for logistic regression in this
particular demo what we are going to do
is
train our model to recognize
digits which are the images which have
digits from
let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these
numbers correctly or not so let's get
started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and then
the last line in this block is to load
the
digits so let's go ahead and run this
code then here we will visualize
the shape of these digits so we can see
here
if we take a look this is how the shape
is 1797
by 64. these are like 8 by 8 images
so that's that's what is reflected in
this shape now from
here onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the
libraries that are required like numpy
and matplot
and we will take a look at some of the
sample
images that we have unloaded so this one
for example creates a figure
and then we go ahead and take a few
sample images
to see how they look so let me run this
code and
so that it becomes easy to understand so
these are about
five images sample images that we are
looking at
zero one two three four so this is how
the image is this is how the data is
okay and uh based on this we will
actually
train our logistic regression model and
then we will test it and see
how well it is able to recognize so the
way it
works is the pixel information so as you
can see here this is an 8
by 8 pixel kind of a image and
the each pixel whether it is activated
or not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern
of this activation and non-activation of
the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example
right similarly as you can see so
overall
each of these numbers actually has a
different pattern of the pixel
activation and that's pretty much that
our
model needs to learn uh for which a
number
what is the pattern of the activation of
the pixels right so that is what we are
going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need
to do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform
any training we split the data into
training and test so that the training
data set is used to train the system so
we pass this
probably multiple times and then we
test it with the test data set and the
split is
usually in the form of the and there are
various ways in which you can split this
data
it is up to the individual preferences
in our case here we are splitting in the
form of
23 and 77 so when we say
test size as 20 0.23
that means 23 percent of that entire
data
is used for testing and the remaining 77
percent is used for training
so there is a readily available function
which is
uh called train test split so we don't
have to write any special code for the
splitting it will automatically
split the data based on the proportion
that we give here which is test size so
we just give the test size
automatically training size will be
determined and we pass the
data that we want to split and the the
results will be stored in x
underscore train and y underscore train
for the training data set and what is x
underscore train
these are these are the features right
which is like the independent variable
and why underscore train is the label
right so in this case what happens is we
have the input value which is or the
features value which is in x underscore
train
and since this is the labeled data for
each of them
each of the observations we already have
the label information saying whether
this digit is a zero or a one or a two
so that this this is what will be used
for comparison to find out whether
the the system is able to recognize it
correctly or there is an error for each
observation it will compare with this
right so this is the label so the same
way x underscore train y
underscore train is for the training
data set x underscore test
y underscore test is for the test data
set okay
so let me go ahead and execute this code
as well and then we can
go and check quickly what is the how
many entries are there
and in each of this so x underscore
train the shape is
13 83 by 64
and y underscore train has 1383 because
there is
nothing like the second part is not
required here
and then x underscore test shape
we see is 414 so actually there are 414
observations
in test and 1383 observations
in train so that's basically what these
four lines of code
are are same okay then we import the
logistic regression library and
which is a part of scikit learn so we we
don't have to implement the logistic
regression process itself we just call
this
the function and let me go ahead and
execute that
so that we have the logistic regression
library imported now we create an
instance of logistic regression right so
logistic regr is a is an instance of
logistic regression and then we use that
for
training our model so let me first
execute this code
so these two lines so the first line
basically creates an instance of
logistic regression model
and then the second line way is where we
are passing
our data the training data set right
this is our
the the predictors and uh this is our
target
we are passing this data set to train
our model
all right so once we do this in this
case the data is not large but
by and large the training is what takes
usually a lot of time so we spend in
machine learning
activities and machine learning projects
we spend a lot of time
for the training part of it okay so here
the data set is relatively small so it
was pretty quick so all right so now our
model has been trained using the
training data set
and we want to see how accurate this is
so what we'll do is we will test it out
in probably
faces so let me first try out how well
this is
working for one image okay i will just
try it out with one image my the first
entry in my test
data set and see whether it is correctly
predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the
fit method there is a method called fit
which is for training the model
and once the training is done if you
want to test for a particular value new
input
you use the predict method okay so let's
run the predict method
and we pass this particular image
and we see that the shape is
or the prediction is 4. so let's try a
few more
let me see for the next 10 seems to be
fine so let me just go ahead and test
the entire data set
okay that's basically what we will do so
now we want to find out how accurately
this has uh performed so we use the
score
method to find what is the percentage of
accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 percent to accurate
okay so that's on this part now what we
can also do
is we can um also see this accuracy
using what is known as a confusion
matrix so let us go ahead and
try that as well so that we can also
visualize
how well this model has uh done
so let me execute this piece of code
which will basically import some of the
libraries that are required
and we we basically create
a confusion matrix and instance of con
confusion matrix
by running confusion matrix and passing
these
values so we have so this confusion
underscore matrix method takes two
parameters
one is the y underscore test and the
other is
the prediction so what is the y
underscore test these are the labeled
values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are
what the system has predicted for the
test data set
okay so this is known to us and this is
what the system
has the model has generated so
we kind of create the confusion matrix
and we will print it
and this is how the confusion matrix
looks as the name suggests it is a
matrix
and the key point out here is that
the accuracy of the model is determined
by
how many numbers are there in the
diagonal the more the numbers
in the diagonal the better the accuracy
is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix
is equal to the number of observations
in the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the
number of observations in the test data
set and then
out of that the maximum number of them
should be
in the diagonal that means the accuracy
is pretty good
if the the numbers in the diagonal are
less and in all other places there are a
lot of numbers
uh which means the accuracy is very low
the diagonal indicates a correct
prediction that this means that the
actual value
is same as the predicted value here
again actual values same as the
predicted value and so on right
so the moment you see a number here that
means the actual value
is something and the predicted value is
something else
right similarly here the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else
so that is basically how we read the
confusion matrix now how do we find
the accuracy you can actually add up the
total
values in the diagonal so it's like 38
plus 44 plus 43 and so on
and divide that by the total number of
test observations
that will give you the percentage
accuracy using a confusion matrix
now let us visualize this confusion
matrix in a slightly
more sophisticated way uh using a heat
map
so we will create a heat map with some
we'll add some colors as well it's uh
it's like a
more visually visually more appealing so
that's the whole idea so
if we let me run this piece of code and
this is how
the heat map looks uh and as you can see
here
the diagonals again are all the values
are
here most of the values so which means
reasonably this seems to be reasonably
accurate and yeah basically the accuracy
score is 94 percent this is calculated
as i mentioned
by adding all these numbers divided by
the total
test value so the total number of
observations in test data set
okay so this is the confusion matrix for
logistic regression all right so
now that we have seen the confusion
matrix
let's take a quick sample and see how
well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples
of the data so if we see here we we
picked up randomly a few of them
so this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four
this is an image of zero so the
predicted value is also zero
actual value is of course zero then this
is the image of
nine so this has also been predicted
correctly
nine and actual value is nine and this
is the image of
one and again this has been predicted
correctly as
like the actual value okay so this was a
quick demo
of logistic regression how to use
logistic regression to
identify images need for confusion
matrixes
classification models have multiple
output categories
most error measures will tell us the
total error in our model
but we cannot use it to find out
individual instances of errors in our
models
so you have your input coming in you
have your classifier
it measures the error and it says oh 53
of these are correct
but we don't know which 53 percent are
correct is it 53
correct uh on guessing on the spam is it
23
guessing on spam and 27
guessing on what's not spam this is
where the
confusion matrix comes in so
during the classification we also have
to overcome the limitations of accuracy
accuracy can be misleading for
classification problems
if there is a significant class
imbalance
a model might predict the majority class
for all cases
and have a high accuracy score
and so you can see here we have our
email coming in and there's two spams
the classifier comes in and goes hey it
only catches one of those spams and it
misclassifies one that's not spam
so our model predicted eight out of ten
instance and will have an accuracy of 80
percent
but is it classifying correctly
a confusion matrix represents a table
layout of the different
outcomes of prediction and results of a
classification problem and helps
visualize its outcomes
and so you see here we have our simple
chart predicted
and actual the confusion matrix helps us
identify the correct predictions of a
model for different individual classes
as well as the errors so you'll see here
that the values predicted by our
classifier are along the rows
this is what we're going to guess it is
or our model is guessing what this is
based on its
training so we've already trained the
model to
guess whether it's spam or not spam or
whatever it is you're working on
and then the actual values of our data
set are along the columns
so this is the actual value that's
supposed to be
people who can speak english will be
classified as positives
so because they have a remember 001. do
you speak english yes
no and you could extend this that they
might have do you speak
french do you speak whatever languages
and so you might have a whole lot of
classifiers that you would look at each
one of these
people who cannot speak english will be
classified as negatives
so there'll be a zero so you know zero
ones
the number of times our actual positive
values are equal to predicted
positive values gives us true positive
tp
the number of times our actual negative
values are equal to predictive negative
values gives us true negative t in
the number of times our model wrongly
predicts negative values as positives
gives us a false positive
fp and you'll see when you're working
with these a lot
you know memorizing that is false
positive you can easily figure out what
that is and pretty soon you're just
looking at the fp
or the tp depending on what you're
working on and the number of
times our model wrongly predicts
positive values as negatives
gives us a false negative fp
now i'm going to do a quick step out
here
let's say you're working in the medical
and we're talking about
cancer do you really want
a bunch of false negatives you want zero
under false negative
so when we look at this confusion matrix
if you have five percent false positives
and five percent false negatives it'd be
much better to even have
twenty percent false positives because
they go in and test it and
zero false negatives the same might be
true
if you're working on uh say a car
driving
is this a safe place for the car to go
well you really don't want any false
positives
you know yes this is safe right over the
cliff
so again when you're working on the
project or whatever it is you're working
on
this chart suddenly has huge value
we were talking about spam email how
many
important emails say from your banking
overdraft charge coming in
that you want to be a a true a false
negative you don't want it to go in the
spam folder
likewise you want to get as much of the
spam out of there but you don't want to
miss anything really important
confusion matrix metrics are performance
measures which help us find the accuracy
of our classifier
there are four main metrics accuracy
precision recall and f1 score
the f1 score is the one i usually hear
the most and accuracy
is usually what you put on your chart
when you're sending in front of the
shareholders how accurate is it people
understand
accuracy f1 score is a little bit more
on
the math side and so you got to be a
little careful when you're quoting f1
scores in the
when you're sitting there with all the
shareholders because a lot of them will
just glaze over
so confusion matrix metrics are
performance measures
which help us find the accuracy of our
classifier there are four main metrics
accuracy the accuracy is used to find
the portion of the correctly classified
values
it tells us how often our classifier is
right
it is the sum of all true values divided
by the total values
and this makes sense again it's one of
those things
i don't want to fall you know what
depends on what you're looking for
are you looking for not to miss any spam
mails
are you looking to drive down the road
and not run anybody over
precision is used to calculate the
model's ability to classify
positive values correctly it answers the
question
when the model predicts a positive value
how often is it right
it is the true positive divided by the
total number of predicted positive
values again this one depends on what
project you're working on
whether this is what you're going to be
focusing on
so recall it is used to calculate the
model's ability to predict positive
values
how often does the model actually
predict the correct
positive values it is the true positives
divided by the total number of
actual positive values and then your f1
score
it is the harmonic mean of recall and
precision it is useful when you need to
take both precision
and recall into account
consider the following two confusion
matrix derived from two different
classifier
to figure out which one performs better
we can
find the confusion matrix for both of
them
and you can see we're back to does it
classify
whether they can speak english or or
non-speaker they speak some they don't
know the english language and so we put
these two
confusion matrixes out here we can go
ahead and do the math behind that we can
look up the accuracy
that's a t p n plus t n over the t f
plus t n
plus f p plus f n and so we get an
accuracy of 0.8125
and we have a precision if you do the
precision which is your
tp truth positive over tp plus
fp we get 0.891
and if we do the recall we'll end up
with the 0.825 that's your tp over tp
plus fn
and then of course your f1 score which
is 2 times precision times recall
over precision plus recall and we get
the 0.857
and if we do that um with another model
let's say we had two different models
and we're trying to see which one
we want to use for whatever reason
we might go ahead and compute the same
things we have our accuracy
our precision and our recall and our f1
score
and as we're looking at this we might
look at the accuracy
because that's really what we're
interested in is how many people
are we able to classify as being able to
speak
english i really don't want to know if
i'm you know i i really don't want to
know if
they're non-speakers i'd rather miss 10
people speaking english
instead of 15. and so you can see from
these charts we'd probably go with the
first model
because it does a better job guessing
who speaks english and has a higher
accuracy because in this case
that is what we're looking for so
uh with that we'll go ahead and pull up
a demo so you can see what this looks
like in the
python setup in in the actual coding
for this we'll go into anaconda
navigator
if you're not familiar with anaconda
it's a really
good tool to use as far as doing display
and demos and for quick development
as a data scientist i just love the
package
now if you're going to do something
heavier lifting there's some limitations
with anaconda and with the setup
and generally you can do just about
anything in here with your python
and for this we'll go with jupiter
notebook uh jupiter lab is the same as
jupiter notebook
you'll see they now have integration
with pi charm if you work in pi charm
uh certainly there's a lot of other
integrations that
anaconda has and we've opened up
i simply learned files i work on and
create a new file called confusion
matrix demo
and the first thing we want to note is
the data we're working with
here i've opened it up in a wordpad or
notepad or whatever
you can see it's got a row of headers
comma separated and then all the data
going down below
and then i save this in the same file so
i don't have to remember what path i'm
working on
of course if you have your data
separated and you're working with a lot
of data you probably want to put it into
a different folder or file depending on
what you're doing
and the first thing we're going to do is
go ahead and import our tools
we're going to use the pandas that's our
data frame
if you haven't had a chance to work with
the data frame please review
panda's data frame going to simply learn
you can pull up the pandas data frame
tutorial on there and then we're going
to use uh
the scikit framework which is all
denoted as
sklearn and i can just pull this in you
can see here's the
scikit learn.org with the stable version
that you can import into your python
and from here we're going to use the
train test split
for splitting our data we're going to do
some pre-processing
we're going to do use the logistic
regression model
that's our actual machine learning model
we're using
and then what this court this particular
setup is about is we're going to do the
accuracy score
the confusion matrix and the classifier
report
so let me go ahead and run that and
bring all that information in
and just like we open the file we need
to go ahead and load our data in here
so we're going to go ahead and do our
pandas read csv
and then just because we're in jupyter
notebook we can just put data to read
the data in here
a lot of times we'll actually let me
just do this i prefer to do the
just the head of the date or the top
part and you can see we have
age sex i'm not sure what cp stands for
test bps cholesterol so a lot of
different
measurements if you were in this domain
you want to know what all these
different
measurements mean i don't want to focus
on that
too much because when we're talking
about data science a lot of times you
have no idea what the data means
if you've ever looked up the breast
cancer measurement it's just a bunch of
measurements and numbers
unless you're a doctor you have no idea
what those measurements mean but if it's
your specialty in your domain
you better know them so we're going to
go ahead and create y and it's going to
we're going to set it equal to the
target
uh so here's our target value here
and there it's either one or zero
so we have a classifier if you're
dealing with one zero true false
what do you have you have a classifier
and then our x is going to be
everything except for the target
so we're going to go ahead and drop the
target axis equals
1. remember that's columns versus the
index or rows
axis equals 0 would would give you an
error but you would drop like
row 2. and then we'll go ahead and just
print that out so you can see what we're
looking at
and here we have y data x data
and you can see from the x data we have
the x head and we can go ahead and just
do print
the y head data and run that
so this is all loading the data that
we've done so far
if there's a confusion in there go back
and rewind the tape and review it
and then we need to go ahead and split
our data into our
x train x test y train
y test and then keep in mind you always
want to split the data
before we do the scalar and the reason
is is that
you want the scalar on the training data
to be set on the training data
data or fit to it but not on the test
data think of this as being out in the
field
you're not you could actually alter your
results
so it's always important to do make sure
whatever you do to the training data
or whatever fit you're doing is always
done on the training
not on the test and then we want to go
ahead and
scale the data now we are working with
a linear regression model and i'll
mention this here in a minute when we
get to the actual model
uh so some sometimes you don't need to
scale when you're working with linear
regression models it's not going to
change your result as much as say a
neural network where it has a huge
impact but we're going to go ahead and
take here's our x train
x test y train y test we create our
scalar
we go ahead and scale the scale is going
to fit the x
train and then we're going to go ahead
and take our x train and transform it
and then we also need to take our x test
and transform it based on the scale on
here so that our x is now
between that nice minus one to one and
so this is all
uh our pre data setup
and hopefully uh all of that looks
fairly familiar to you if you've done a
number of our other classes and you're
up to
the setup on here and then we want to go
ahead and do is create our model and
we're going to use the
logistic regression model and from the
logistic regression model
we're going to go ahead and fit our x
train and y train
and then we'll run our predicted value
on here
and let's go ahead and run that and so
now
we are we actually have like our x test
and our prediction so if you remember
from our matrix
we're looking for the actual versus the
prediction
and how those compare and
if i take us back up here you're going
to notice that we imported the accuracy
score
the confusion matrix and the
classification report
and there's of course our logistic
regression the model we're using for
this
and i did mention is going to talk a
little bit about scalar and the
regression model
the scalar on a lot of your regression
models your basic mass standard
regression models
and i'd have to look it up for the
logistic regression model when you're
using a standard regression model you
don't need to scale the data
it's already just built in by the way
the model works
in most cases uh but if you're in a
neural network and you're there's a lot
of other different setups then you
really want to take this
and fit that on there and so
we can go in and do the accuracy and
this is if you remember correctly we
were looking at the accuracy
with the english speaking uh so this is
saying
our accuracy as to whether this person
is
i believe this is the heart data set
it's going to be accurate about 85
percent of the time as far as whether
it's going to predict the person's going
to have
a heart condition or the one as it comes
up with the zero one on there
which would mean at this point that you
have an 85 percent uh being correct on
telling someone they're extremely high
risk for a heart attack kind of thing
and so we want to go ahead and create
our confusion matrix
and let me just do that
of course the software does everything
for us so we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see right here here's our 25
prediction correct predictions right
here
and if you remember from our slide i'll
just bring this over says a nice visual
we have our true positive
false positive so we had 25 which were
true
that it said hey this person is going to
be high risk at heart
and we had four that were still high
risk that it said were false
so out of these 25 people or out of
these 29 people and that makes sense
because you have 0.85
out of 29 people it was correct on 25 of
them
and so uh here's our accuracy score we
were just looking at that
our accuracy is your true positive and
your true negative
over all of them so how true is it there
is our accuracy
coming up here 0.85 and then we have our
nice matrix generated from that
and you can see right here is a similar
matrix we had going for the from the
slide
and this starts to this should start
asking questions at this point
so if you're in a board meeting or
you're working with this you really want
to start looking at
this data here and saying well is this
good enough
is this number of people and hopefully
you'd have a much larger data set
it might is my confusion matrix showing
for the true positive and
false positive is that acceptable for
what we're doing
uh and of course if you're going to put
together whatever data you're putting
out you might want to separate the
true negative false positive false
negative true positive
and you can simply do that by doing the
confusion matrix
and then of course the ravel part lets
you set that up so you can just split
that right up into a nice tuple
and the final thing we want to show you
here in
the coding on this part
is the confusion matrix metrics
and so we can come in here and just use
the matrix equals classification report
the y test and the predict and then
we're going to take that classification
report
and go ahead and print that out and you
can see here it does a nice job
giving you your accuracy your micro
average
your weighted average you have your
precision
your recall your f1 score and your
support
all in one window so you can start
looking at this data and saying oh
okay our precision's at .83
0.87 for getting a a positive and
0.83 for the negative side for a zero
and we start talking about whether this
is a valid information or not to use
and when we're looking at a heart attack
prediction we're only looking at
one aspect what's the chances of this
person having a heart attack or not
um you might have something where we
went back to the languages
maybe you also want to know whether they
speak english or
hindi or french and you can see right
here that we can now
take our confusion matrix and just
expand it as big as we need to depending
on how many different classifiers we're
working on
what is a decision tree let's go through
a very simple example before we dig in
deep
decision tree is a tree shaped diagram
used to determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision or current
or reaction let's start with a simple
question how to identify a random
vegetable
from a shopping bag so we have this
group of vegetables in here
and we can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not
then it's going to be the purple fruit
to the left probably an eggplant
if it's true it's going to be one of the
red fruits is the diameter greater than
two if false is going to be a what looks
to be a red chili
and if it's true it's going to be a bell
pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum problems that
decision tree can solve so let's look at
the two different categories the
decision tree can be used on
it can be used on the classification the
true false yes no
and it can be used on regression where
we figure out what the next value is in
a series of numbers or a group of data
in classification the classification
tree will determine
a set of logical if-then conditions to
classify
problems for example discriminating
between three types of flowers
based on certain features in regression
a regression tree is used when the
target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree
let's take a look at the advantages of
using a decision tree and we'll also
take a glimpse at the disadvantages
the first thing you'll notice is that
it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree
little effort is required for data
preparation so you don't have to do
special scaling there's a lot of things
you don't have to worry about when using
a decision tree it can handle
both numerical and categorical data as
we discovered earlier and non-linear
parameters
don't affect its performance so even if
the data doesn't fit
an easy curved graph you can still use
it to create
an effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree
the first disadvantage is overfitting
overfitting occurs when the algorithm
captures
noise in the data that means you're
solving for one specific
instance instead of a general solution
for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data
low bias tree a highly complicated
decision tree tends to have a low bias
which makes it difficult for the model
to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further
we need to look at some basic terms we
need to have
some definitions to go with our decision
tree in the different parts we're going
to be using we'll start with
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example
we have a group of animals in this
picture there's four different kinds of
animals and this data set
is considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals
as a big clump of uh entities so as we
start splitting it into subgroups we
come up with our
second definition which is information
gain
information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy
after the data set is split so in this
case based on the color yellow we've
split
one group of animals on one side as true
and those who aren't yellow
as false as we continue down the yellow
side we split based on the height
true or false equals 10 and on the other
side height is less than 10
true or false and as you see as we split
it the entropy continues to be less and
less and less
and so our information gain is simply
the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute
entropy finally we went on the different
parts of our tree and they call the leaf
node
leaf node carries the classification or
the decision so it's the final
end at the bottom the decision node has
two or more branches
this is where we're breaking the group
up into different parts and
finally you have the root node the
topmost decision node is known as the
root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals i'll get in the
jungle
today maybe you're the hunter with the
gun or if you're more into photography
you're a photographer with a camera so
let's look at this group of animals
and let's try to classify different
types of animals
based on their features using a decision
tree so the problem statement is to
classify the different types of animals
based on their features using a decision
tree the data set is looking quite messy
and the entropy is high in this case
so let's look at a training set or a
training data set
and we're looking at color we're looking
at height and then we have our different
animals we have our elephants our
giraffes our monkeys and our tigers
and they're of different colors and
shapes let's see what that looks like
and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data
in such a way that the information gain
is the highest
note gain is a measure of decrease in
entropy
after splitting so the formula for
entropy is the sum
that's what this symbol looks like that
looks like kind of like a e
funky e of k where i equals 1 to k
k would represent the number of animals
the different animals in there
where value or p value of i
would be the percentage of that animal
times the log
base two of the same the percentage of
that animal let's try to calculate the
entropy for the current data set
and take a look at what that looks like
and don't be afraid of the math you
don't really have to memorize this math
just be aware that it's there and this
is what's going on in the background
and so we have three giraffes two tigers
one monkey
two elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula
we get an entropy that equals three over
eight
so we have three giraffes a total of
eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two
of three over eight plus in this case it
says yellow fence
two over eight two elephants over total
of eight times log base two
two over eight plus one monkey over
total of eight
log base two one over eight and plus two
over eight of the tigers log base two
over eight
and if we plug that into our computer or
calculator i obviously can't do logs in
my head
we get an entropy equal to 0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set
similarly after every split to calculate
the gain now we're not going to go
through each set one at a time
to see what those numbers are we just
want you to be aware that this is a
formula or the mathematics behind it
gain can be calculated by finding the
difference of the subsequent entropy
values after a split
now we will try to choose a condition
that gives us the highest
gain we will do that by splitting the
data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split
can you guess what that first split will
be just by looking at this image
as a human is probably pretty easy to
split it let's see if you're right
if you guessed the color yellow you're
correct let's say the condition that
gives us the maximum gain
is yellow so we will split the data
based on the color yellow
if it's true that group of animals goes
to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has to
decreased considerably however we still
need some splitting of both the branches
to attain an entropy value
equal to zero so we decide to split both
the nodes using
height as the condition since every
branch now contains single label type we
can say that entropy in this case has
reached the least
value and here you see we have the
giraffes the tigers the monkey and the
elephants
all separated into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the data set with 100
accuracy that was easy use case
loan repayment prediction let's get into
my favorite part and open up some python
and see what the programming code in the
scripting
looks like in here we're going to want
to do a prediction and we start with
this individual here who's requesting to
find out how good his customers are
going to be
whether they're going to repay their
loan or not for his bank and from that
we want to generate a problem statement
to predict if a customer will repay loan
amount
or not and then we're going to be using
the decision tree algorithm in python
let's see what that looks like and let's
dive into the code
in our first few steps of implementation
we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like
so the first thing i need is i need
something to edit my python and run it
in so let's flip on over
and here i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupyter notebook's really nice
for doing things on the fly
and let's go ahead and just paste that
code in the beginning and before we
start
let's talk a little bit about what we're
bringing in and then we're going to do a
couple things in here we have to make a
couple changes as we go through this
first part of the import
the first thing we bring in is numpy as
np that's very standard when we're
dealing with
mathematics especially with very
complicated machine learning tools you
almost always see the numpy come in for
your num
your number it's called number python it
has your mathematics in there in this
case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with
and then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the
pandas is a data frame setup and you can
liken this to
taking your basic data and storing it in
a way that looks
like an excel spreadsheet so as we come
back to this when you see
np or pd those are very standard uses
you'll know that that's the pandas and
i'll show you a little bit more when we
explore the data in just a minute
then we're going to need to split the
data so i'm going to bring in our train
test and split
and this is coming from the sk learn
package cross validation
in just a minute we're going to change
that and we'll go over that too
and then there's also the sk.tree import
decision tree classifier that's the
actual tool we're using
remember i told you don't be afraid of
the mathematics it's going to be done
for you
well the decision tree classifier has
all that mathematics in there for you so
you don't have to figure it back out
again and then we have sklearn.metrics
for accuracy score we need to score our
our setup that's the whole reason we're
splitting it between the training and
testing data and finally we still need
the sklearn
import tree and that's just a basic tree
function is needed for the decision tree
classifier
and finally we're gonna load our data
down here and i'm gonna run this
and we're gonna get two things on here
one we're gonna get an
error and two we're gonna get a warning
let's see what that looks like
so the first thing we had is we have an
error why is this error here well it's
looking at this it says
i need to read a file and when this was
written
the person who wrote it this is their
path where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full
file name and you'll see it's on my c
drive and this very lengthy
setup on here where i stored the
data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer will be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated
by simplylearn if you want a copy of
that you can comment down below
and request it here in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to
full file name so let's go ahead and run
it now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding understanding these
different warnings and these different
errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a
opportunity to understand what's going
on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation
is depreciated so it's a warning on it's
being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation
and if you research this and go to the
sklearn site you'll find out that you
can actually just swap it right in there
with model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning what they've done
is they've had two different developers
develop it in two different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one
that's all that is and very easy and
quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv let's talk a little bit
more about that and see what that looks
like both as a text file
because it's a comma separated variable
file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header
and it's got one two three four five
columns
and each column has data in it and let
me flip this over because we're also
going to look at this uh
in an actual spreadsheet so you can see
what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as
excel and zoomed in and you can see
we've got our columns
and our rows of data a little easier to
read in here we have a result
yes yes no we have initial payment last
payment credit score
house number if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then 1 000 lines of data
now as a programmer if you're looking at
a small amount of data i usually start
by pulling it up in different sources so
i can see what i'm working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be
too too large so you need to either
bring in a small amount that you can
look at it like we're doing right now
or we can start looking at it through
the python code so let's go ahead and
move on and take
the next couple steps to explore the
data using python
let's go ahead and see what it looks
like in python to print the length and
the shape of the data
so let's start by printing the length of
the database
we can use a simple lin function from
python
and when i run this you'll see that it's
a thousand long and that's what we
expected there's a thousand lines of
data in there if you subtract the
column head this is one of the nice
things when we did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row 0 so
it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines
it also tells me there's five columns so
we were looking at the data we had five
columns of data
and then let's take one more step to
explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape
let's go ahead and use the pandas
module for head another beautiful thing
in the data set that we can utilize
so let's put that on our sheet here and
we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there
and then we went ahead and gave a label
for our print job here of dataset just a
simple print statement
and we run that let's just take a closer
look at that let me zoom in here
there we go pandas do such a wonderful
job
of making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it
when you put it as the head it prints
the first five lines of the data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you wanna start with
the zero position
and that is what the data head does it
pulls the first five rows of data
puts in a nice format that you can look
at and view very powerful
tool to view the data so instead of
having to flip and open up an excel
spreadsheet
or open office cal or trying to look at
a
word doc where it's all scrunched
together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape
of a thousand long five wide so we have
five columns
and we do the full data head you can
actually see what this data looks like
the initial payment last payment credit
scores house number
so let's take this now that we've
explored the data and let's start
digging into the decision tree
so in our next step we're going to
train and build our data tree and to do
that
we need to first separate the data out
we're going to separate into two groups
so that we have something to actually
train the data with and
then we have some data on the side to
test it to see how good our model is
remember with any of the machine
learning you always want to have some
kind of test set to weigh it against
so you know how good your model is when
you distribute it let's go ahead and
break this code down
and look at it in pieces so first we
have our
x and y where do x and y come from
well x is going to be our data and y is
going to be the
answer or the target you can look at
source and target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in
and the data that we're actually trying
to guess what the answer is going to be
and so to separate it we can simply put
in
x equals the balance of the data.values
the
first brackets means that we're going to
select all the lines
in the database so it's all the data and
the second one says we're only going to
look at columns one through
five remember i always start with zero
zero is a yes or no
and that's whether the loan went default
or not so we want to start with one
if we go back up here that's the initial
payment and it goes all the way through
the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for y
which is the answers
and we're going to set that just equal
to the zero row
so it's just the zero row and then it's
all rows going in there so now we've
divided this into
two different data sets one of them with
the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data and here
you'll see that we have it split into
four different parts the first one is
your x
training your x test your y train
your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it
and we have to know the answer to train
it with and then we have
x test where we're going to test that
data and we have to know in the end what
the y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules
this does it all for us and you can see
they set the test size equal to 0.3
so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there
and then finally we get to actually
build our decision tree
and they've called it here clf
underscore entropy
that's the actual decision tree or
decision tree classifier
and in here they've added a couple
variables which we'll explore in just a
minute
and then finally we need to fit the data
to that
so we take our clf entropy that we
created
and we fit the x train and since we know
the answers for x trade or the y train
we go ahead and put those in and let's
go ahead and run this
and what most of these sklearn modules
do
is when you set up the variable in this
case we set the clf entropy called
decision tree classifier it
automatically prints out what's in that
decision tree
there's a lot of variables you can play
within here and it's quite beyond the
scope
of this tutorial to go through all of
these and how they work
but we're working on entropy that's one
of the options we've added that it's
completely a random state
of 100 so 100 percent and we have a max
depth of 3.
now the max depth if you remember above
when we were doing the different graphs
of animals
means it's only going to go down three
layers before it stops
and then we have minimal samples of
leaves is five so it's going to have at
least five leafs at the end so i'll have
at least
three splits i'll have no more than
three layers and at least
five end leaves with the final result at
the bottom
now that we've created our decision tree
classifier not only created it but
trained it let's go
ahead and apply it and see what that
looks like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction
and see what that looks like we're going
to paste our predict code in here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our variable clf
entropy that we created and then you'll
see dot predict
and it's very common in the sk learn
modules
that their different tools have to
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use in
actual commercial use and
distributed it this would be the new
loans you're putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be uh pay
them back or not
in this case so we need to test out the
data and just see how good our
sample is how good of our tree does at
predicting the loan payments
and finally since anaconda jupiter
notebook is it works as a command line
for python we can simply put the y
predict e in to print it i could just as
easily have put the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out
we'll go ahead and do that it doesn't
matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly
300 in here remember it's 30 percent of
a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our
test went in there and this is what our
y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data
and try to figure out just how good a
model we have so here we go since
sklearn does all the heavy lifting for
you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is
and let's go ahead and go through that
and see what that means and what that
looks like let's go ahead and paste this
in
and let me zoom in a little bit there we
go
so you have a nice full picture and
we'll see here we're just going to do a
print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see
where that's coming from that's coming
from here down here from sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score and you could
probably run a script make your own
script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
did we get right
and so we put in our y test that's the
one we ran the predict on
and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got
and we're just going to multiply that by
a hundred because this is just going to
give us an answer as a decimal
and we want to see it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit
we can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that
we now have accuracy set up on here and
so we have created a model that uses the
decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not
the accuracy of the model is about 94.6
percent
the bank can now use this model to
decide whether it should approve the
loan
request from a particular customer or
not and so this information is really
powerful
we may not be able to as individuals
understand all these numbers because
they have thousands of numbers that come
in but you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank
to use a tool like this to help them to
predict how good their
profit's going to be off of the loan
balances and how many are going to
default or not how does a random forest
work as a whole
so to begin our random forest classifier
let's say we already have
built three trees and we're gonna start
with the first tree that looks like this
just like we did in the example this
tree looks at the diameter if it's
greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger
diameter and if the color is orange
it's going to go to the right true we're
using oranges now instead of lemons
and if it's red it's going to go to the
left false we build a second tree very
similar but split differently instead of
the first one being split by a diameter
this one when they created it if you
look at that first bowl it has a lot of
red objects
so it says is the color red because
that's going to bring our entropy down
the fastest and so of course if it's
true it goes to the left
if it's false it goes to the right and
then it looks at the shape
false or true and so on and so on and
tree three is a diameter equal to one
and it came up with this because there's
a lot of cherries in this bowl
so that would be the biggest split on
there is is the diameter equal to one
that's going to drop the entropy the
quickest
and as you can see it splits it into
true if it goes false and they've added
another category
does it grow in the summer and if it's
false it goes off to the left if it's
true it goes off to the right
let's go ahead and bring these three
trees you can see them all in one image
so this would be three completely
different trees categorizing a fruit
and let's take a fruit now let's try
this
and this fruit if you look at it we've
blackened it out you can't see the color
on it so it's missing data remember one
of the things we talked about earlier
is that a random forest works really
good if you're missing data if you're
missing pieces so this fruit has an
image but
maybe the person had a black and white
camera when they took the picture
and we're going to take a look at this
and it's going to have
they put the color in there so ignore
the color down there but the diameter
equals three
we find out it grows in the summer
equals yes and the shape is a circle
and if you go to the right you can look
at what one of the decision trees did
this is the third one is the diameter
greater than equal to three
is the color orange well it doesn't
really know on this one but if you look
at the value it'd say true and go to the
right
tree two classifies it as cherries is
the color equal
red is the shape a circle true it is a
circle
so this would look at it and say oh
that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says
is the diameter equal one well that's
false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges
so how does this random forest work the
first one says
it's an orange the second one said it
was a cherry
and the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess
if you have two oranges and one says
it's a cherry when you add that all
together
the majority of the vote says orange so
the answer is
it's classified as an orange even though
we didn't know the color and we're
missing data on it
i don't know about you but i'm getting
tired of fruit so let's switch
and i did promise you we'd start looking
at a case example and get into some
python
coding today we're going to use the case
the iris flower analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves
and actually look at some python coding
before we start the python coding we
need to go ahead and create a problem
statement
wonder what species of iris do these
flowers belong to
let's try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in
python let's see how it can be done so
here we begin to go ahead and implement
our python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about
organizing and exploring the data coming
in let's go ahead and take
this first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda
jupiter notebook which is one of my
favorites certainly there's notepad plus
plus
and eclipse and dozens of others or just
even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore
this python coding so here we go let's
go ahead and flip over to our jupyter
notebook
and i've already opened up a new page
for python 3 code
and i'm just going to paste this right
in there and let's take a look and see
what we're bringing into our python the
first thing we're going to do is from
the sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module
that allows us to bring in the data the
load iris
and the iris is so popular it's been
around since 1936 when ronald fisher
published a paper on it and they're
measuring the different parts of the
flower
and based on those measurements
predicting what kind of flower it is and
then if we're going to do a random
forest classifier
we need to go ahead and import a random
forest classifier from the sk learn
module
so sklearn.ensemble import random fourth
classifier
and then we want to bring in two more
modules and these are
probably the most commonly used modules
in python and data science
with any of the other modules that we
bring in
and one is going to be pandas we're
going to import pandas as pd
pd is a common term used for pandas and
pandas is basically
creates a data format for us where
when you create a pandas data frame it
looks like
an excel spreadsheet and you'll see that
in a minute when we start digging deeper
into the code
panda is just wonderful because it plays
nice with all the other modules in there
and then we have numpy which is our
numbers python
and the numbers python allows us to do
different
mathematical sets on here we'll see
right off the bat we're going to take
our np
and we're going to go ahead and seed the
randomness with it with 0. so
np.random.seed
is seating that is 0. this code doesn't
actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on
here the next six slides including this
one
are all about exploring the data
remember i told you half of this is
about
looking at the data and getting it all
set so let's go ahead and take
this code right here the script and
let's get that over
into our jupiter notebook and here we go
we've gone ahead and
run the imports and i'm going to paste
the code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading
the iris data and if you remember up
here we loaded the module that tells it
how to get the iris data
now we're actually assigning that data
to the variable iris
and then we're going to go ahead and use
the df to define
data frame and that's going to equal pd
and if you remember that's pandas as
pd so that's our pandas and panda data
frame and then we're looking at iris
data and columns equals iris feature
names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created
what looks like an excel spreadsheet and
in this excel spreadsheet we have set
the columns
so up on the top you can see the four
different columns
and then we have the data iris.data down
below it's a little confusing without
knowing where this data is coming from
so let's look at
the bigger picture and i'm going to go
print i'm just going to change this for
a moment
and we're going to print all of iris and
see what that looks like
so when i print all of iris i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary you'll have a
key or a label and this label pulls up
whatever information comes after it
so feature names which we actually used
over here under columns
is equal to an array of sepal length
steeple width petal length
petal width these are the different
names they have for the four different
columns
and if you scroll down far enough you'll
also see data down here oh goodness it
came up right towards the top
and data is equal to the different data
we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names
the target names which is further down
and we'll show you that also in a minute
let's go ahead and set that back to the
head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head
it'll print the first five lines of the
dataset in there along with the headers
if you have it in this case we have the
column header set to iris features
and in here you'll see that we have zero
one two
three four in python most arrays always
start at zero so when you look at the
first
five it's going to be zero one two three
four not one two three four five
so now we've got our iris data imported
into a data frame
let's take a look at the next piece of
code in here and so in this section
here of the code we're gonna take a look
at the
target and let's go ahead and get this
into our notebook this piece of code
so we can discuss it a little bit more
in detail so here we are in our jupyter
notebook i'm going to put the code in
here
and before i run it i want to look at a
couple things going on so we have
df species and this is interesting
because right here you'll see where i
have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column
and here we have iris.target now these
are both in the
pandas setup on here so in pandas we can
do
either one i could have just as easily
done iris
and then in brackets target depending on
what i'm working on
both are acceptable let's go ahead and
run this code
and see how this changes and what we've
done is we've added the target
from the iris data set as another column
on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict
so we have our data which tells us the
answer for all these different pieces
and then we've added a column with the
answer that way when we do
our final setup we'll have the ability
to program our
our neural network to look for these
this different data and know what a
setosa is
or a vera color which we'll see in just
a minute or virginica those are the
three that are in there
and now we're going to add one more
column i know
we're organizing all this data over and
over again it's kind of fun
there's a lot of ways to organize it
what's nice about putting everything
onto
one data frame is i can then do
a print out and it shows me exactly what
i'm looking at and i'll show you that
where you where that's different where
you can alter that and do it slightly
differently
but let's go ahead and put this into our
script up to debt
now and here we go we're going to put
that down here
and we're going to run that and let's
talk a little bit about what we're doing
now we're exploring data and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model
is did your model work and to do this we
need to split the data and we split it
into
two different parts they usually call it
the training and the testing
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and put that in our database so you can
see it clearly and
we've set it df remember you can put
brackets this is creating another column
is train so we're going to use part of
it for training and this equals
np remember that stands for
numpy.random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0
and 1 and we're going to do it for each
of the rows that's where the length df
comes from so each row gets a generated
number
and if it's less than 0.75 it's true
and if it's greater than 0.75 it's false
this means we're going to take 75
of the data roughly because there's a
randomness involved
and we're going to use that to train it
and then the other 25
we're going to hold off to the side and
use that to test it later on
so let's flip back on over and see what
the next step is so now that we've
labeled our database for which is
training and which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables
train and test and let's take this code
and let's bring it into our project
and here we go let's paste it on down
here and before i
run this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here
is we have up above we created remember
there's our
def dot head which prints the first five
rows and we've added a column
is train at the end and so we're going
to take that we're going to create
two variables we're going to create two
new data frames one's called
train one's called test 75
in train 25 percent and test and then to
sort that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it
and if df is trained equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is trained equals false it goes in
the test
and so when i run this we're going to
print out the number in each one
let's see what that looks like and
you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module
and it puts 32 in the testing module
which lets us know that there was 150
lines of data in here so if you went and
looked at the original data you could
see that there's 150 lines
and that's roughly 75 in one and 25
percent for us to test
our model on afterward so let's jump
back to our code and see where this goes
in the next two steps we want to do one
more thing with our data
and that's make it readable to humans i
don't know about you but i hate looking
at
zeros and ones so let's start with the
features and let's go ahead and take
those and make those readable to humans
and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple
very basic things we know that the
columns in our data frame again this is
a panda thing the df
columns and we know the first four of
them
zero one two three that'd be the first
four are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns
and so when i run this you'll see down
here that it creates an index
sepa length sepa width pedal length and
pedal width
and this should be familiar because if
you look up here here's our column
titles going across and here's the first
four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupyter notebook or
you're running command line in the
terminal window
if you just put the name of it it'll
print it out this is the same as doing
print
features and the short hand is you just
put features in here
if you're actually writing a code and
saving the script and running it by
remote
you really need to put the print in
there but for this when i run it you'll
see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features
because it doesn't really matter and
this is one of the fun thing about
jupiter notebooks is i'm just building
the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing
is we're going to go ahead and convert
the species on here
into something the computer understands
so let's put this code into our script
and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd.factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas
right here pd factorize what's
factorized doing i'm going to come back
to that in just a second
let's look at what train species is and
why we're looking at
the group zero on there and let's go up
here
and here is our species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa setosa setosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see
virginica and veracolor we need to
convert that into something the computer
understands zeros and ones
so the trained species of zero
because this is in the format of a of an
array of arrays
so you have to have the zero on the end
and then species
is just that column factorize goes in
there and looks at the fact
that there's only three of them so when
i run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set
and it's zeros ones and twos
representing the three different kinds
of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally
we get to actually start doing the
predicting so here we go
we have two lines of code oh my goodness
that was a lot of work
to get to two lines of code but there is
a lot in these two lines of code
so let's take a look and see what's
going on here and put this into
our full script that we're running and
let's paste this in here
and let's take a look and see what this
is we have we're creating a variable
clf and we're going to set this equal to
the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with
as far as these two are concerned
they're very standard in
jobs all that does is to prioritize it
not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that
and then the random state is just how it
starts 0 is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more
clf dot fit so we're fitting
we're training it we are actually
creating our
random forest classifier right here this
is a code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set
remember we kept our test off to the
side and we're going to take our
training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target
the y so the y is 0 1 and 2
that we just created and the features is
the actual data going in
that we put into the training set let's
go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out
the random force classifier
and everything around it and so when
you're running this
in your terminal window on a script like
this
this automatically treats us like just
like when we were up here
and i typed in y and printed out y
instead of print y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out
but if you're actually running your code
that wouldn't be the case
and what is printed out is it shows us
all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these
different meanings of all these
different settings on here some of them
are self-explanatory if you kind of
think about it a little bit like max
features is
auto so all the features that we're
putting in there is just going to
automatically take all four of them
whatever we send it it'll take some of
them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there
at that point you probably want to limit
the maximum features that you're going
to process
and leaf nodes that's the end nodes
remember we have the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this
we're looking at a lot of stuff here so
you might have in this case there's
probably only think three leaf nodes
maybe four
you might have thousands of leaf nodes
at which point you do need to put a cap
on that and say okay it can only go so
far and then we're going to use all of
our resources on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is
limiting the process and making sure we
don't uh
overwhelm a system and there's some
other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them warm start equals false
warm start is if you're programming it
one piece at a time externally
since we're not we're not going to have
like we're not going to continually
train this particular learning tree and
again like i said there's a lot of
things in here that you'll want to look
up more detail from the sk
learn and if you're digging in deep and
running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit or train our features and our target
y
so now we have our training model what's
next
if we're going to create a model we now
need to test it
remember we set aside the test feature
test group 25 of the data so let's go
ahead and take this code and let's put
it into
our script and see what that looks like
okay here we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos
which represents the three type of
flowers the setosa the virginica and the
versacolor
and what we're putting into our predict
is the test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length simple width pedal
length pedal width
so when we put it in this way it
actually loads all these different
columns that we loaded into features
so if we did just features let me just
do features in here seeing what features
looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames
you'll see that it's an index so when
you put an index in like this
into test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case we're going to go ahead
and put those into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5 0.2
and we're going to put those in and
we're going to predict what our
new forest classifier is going to come
up with and this is what it predicts it
predicts
0 0 0 1 2 1 1 2 2 2
and and again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor
so now that we've taken our test
features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us
so the first thing we can do with our
predix is we can actually generate
a different prediction model when i say
different we're going to view it
differently
it's not that the data itself is
different so let's take this next piece
of code and put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh
predict and we've added underscore proba
for probability
so there's our clf.predict probability
so
we're running it just like we ran it up
here but this time
with this we're gonna get a slightly
different result and we're only going to
look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them which was
what 27 you'll see right down here that
this generates a much larger
field on the probability and let's take
a look and see what that looks like
and what that means so when we do the
predict
underscore prabha for probability it
generates
three numbers so we had three leaf nodes
at the end and if you remember from all
the theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting
a 1 for setosa it predicts
a 0 for virginica and it predicts a 0
for versa color and so on and so on and
so on and let's uh you know what i'm
going to change this just a little bit
let's look at 10 to 20
just because we can and we start to get
a little different of data
and you'll see right down here it gets
to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one
so it says setosa gets zero votes
virginica gets 0.5 votes
versacolor gets 0.5 votes but let's just
go with the
virginica since these two are equal and
so on and so on down the list you can
see how they vary on here
so now we've looked at both how to do a
basic predict of the features
and we've looked at the predict
probability let's see what's next on
here
so now we want to go ahead and start
mapping names for the plants
we want to attach names so that it makes
a little more sense for us
and this we're going to do in these next
two steps we're going to start
by setting up our predictions and
mapping them to the name so let's see
what that
looks like and let's go ahead and paste
that code in here
and run it and this goes along with the
next piece of code
so we'll skip through this quickly and
then come back to it a little bit so
here's
iris dot target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the
the names that we've been talking about
this whole time the setosa virginica
versus color
and then we're going to go ahead and do
the prediction again
we've run we could have just set a
variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we're going
to run it again
clf dot predict test features remember
that
returns the zeros the ones and the twos
and then we're going to set that equal
to
predictions so this time we're actually
putting it in a variable
and when i run this it distributes
it it comes out as an array and the
array is setosa satosa satosa satosa
setosa
we're only looking at the first five we
could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there
and you'll see that it starts mapping it
to all the different flower types the
versacolor and the virginica in there
and let's see how this goes with the
next one so let's take a look at the
top part of our species in here and
we'll take this code and put it in our
script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together the first one
is our predictions and i went ahead and
did uh predictions through 25
let's just do five and so we have setosa
satoshi satosa satoshi that's what we're
predicting from
our test model and then we come down
here we look at test
species i remember i could have just
done test.species.head
and you'll see it says setosa satosa
satosa setosa
and they match so the first one is what
our forest is doing and the second one
is what the actual data is now is we
need to combine these so that we can
understand what that means we need to
know how good our forest is how good it
is at predicting the features
so that's where we come up to the next
step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals
so we have a nice chart to look at and
let's go ahead and put that in our
script in our jupiter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm gonna
because i'm on the jupiter notebook i
can do a control minus so you can see
the whole line there
there we go resize it and let's take a
look and see what's going on here
we're going to create in pandas remember
pd stands for pandas
and we're doing a cross tab this
function takes two sets of data
and creates a chart out of them so when
i run it you'll get a nice chart down
here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica
and the actual species setosa versacolor
virginica
and so the way to read this chart and
let's go ahead and take a look on how to
read this chart here
when you read this chart you have setosa
where they meet
you have versus color where they meet
and you have virginica where they meet
and they're meeting where the actual and
the predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here
where it says virginica but it was
supposed to be versacolor
this is inaccurate so now we have two
two inaccurate
predictions and 30 accurate predictions
so we'll say that the model accuracy is
93
that's just 30 divided by 32 and if we
multiply it by 100
we can say that it is 93 percent
accurate so we have a 93
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting
before we wrap it up so let's flip back
on over to my script
in here we're going to take this line of
code from up above
i don't know if you remember it but
predix equals the iris.target underscore
names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features
but you know we're not just testing it
we want to actually deploy it
so at this point i would go ahead and
change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create
data maybe let's just do two flowers so
maybe i'm processing more data coming in
and we'll put two flowers in here and
then
i actually want to see what the answer
are is so let's go ahead and
type in preds and print that out and
when i run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as
versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since they put the same
data in for each one
this would be the actual end product
going out to be used on data that you
don't know the answer for
so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this so
in this example last week my son and i
visited a fruit shop
dad is that an apple or a strawberry so
the question comes up
what fruit do they just pick up from the
fruit stand after a couple of seconds
you can figure out that it was a
strawberry so let's take this model a
step further and let's uh
why not build a model which can predict
an unknown data and in this
we're going to be looking at some sweet
strawberries or crispy apples
we want to be able to label those two
and decide what the fruit is and we do
that
by having data already put in so we
already have a bunch of strawberries we
know our strawberries and they're
already labeled as such
we already have a bunch of apples we
know our apples and are labeled as such
then once we train our model that model
then can be given the new data
and the new data is this image in this
case you can see a question mark on it
and it comes through and goes it's a
strawberry in this case we're using
the support vector machine model svm is
a supervised
learning method that looks at data and
sorts it into one of two categories
and in this case we're sorting the
strawberry into the strawberry site
at this point you should be asking the
question how does the prediction work
before we dig into an example with
numbers let's apply this to our fruit
scenario
we have our support vector machine we've
taken it and we've taken labeled sample
of data
strawberries and apples and we draw on a
line down the middle between the two
groups
this split now allows us to take new
data
in this case an apple and a strawberry
and place them in the appropriate group
based on which side of the line they
fall in and that way we can predict the
unknown as colorful and tasty as the
fruit example is
let's take a look at another example
with some numbers involved and we can
take a closer look at how the math works
in this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with
a set of people with a different height
and a different weight
and to make this work we'll have to have
a sample data set
a female where you have their height and
weight 174
65 174 88 and so on and we'll need a
sample data set of the male
they have a height 179 90 180 to 80
and so on let's go ahead and put this on
a graph so we have a nice visual
so you can see here we have two groups
based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first
we can split our data by choosing any of
these lines
in this case we draw in two lines
through the data in the middle that
separates them in from the women but to
predict the gender of a new data point
we should split the data in the
best possible way and we say the best
possible way
because this line has a maximum space
that separates
the two classes here you can see there's
a clear split between the two
different classes and in this one
there's not so much a clear split
this doesn't have the maximum space that
separates the two that is why
this line best splits the data we don't
want to just do this by eyeballing it
and before we go further we need to add
some technical terms to this
we can also say that the distance
between the points in the line should be
as far as
possible in technical terms we can say
the distance between the support vector
and the hyperplane should be as far as
possible
and this is where the support vectors
are the extreme points in the data set
and if you look at this data set they
have circled two points which seem to be
right on the outskirts of the woman and
one on the outskirts of the men
and hyperplane has a maximum distance to
the support vectors of any class
now you'll see the line down the middle
and we call this the hyperplane because
when you're dealing with multiple
dimensions
it's really not just a line but a plane
of intersections
and you can see here where the support
vectors have been drawn in dashed lines
the math behind this is very simple we
take d
plus the shortest distance to the
closest positive point which would be on
the min side
and d minus is the shortest distance to
the closest negative point which is on
the women's side
the sum of d plus and d minus is called
the distance
margin or the distance between the two
support vectors that are shown in the
dashed
lines and then by finding the largest
distance margin we can get the optimal
hyperplane
once we've created an optimal hyperplane
we can easily see
which side the new data fits in and
based on the hyperplane we can say the
new data point belongs to the male
gender
hopefully that's clear how that works on
a visual level as a data scientist
you should also be asking what happens
if the hyperplane is not optimal
if we select a hyperplane having low
margin then there is a high chance of
misclassification
this particular svm model the one we
discussed so far
is also called referred to as the ls vm
so far so clear but a question should be
coming up
we have our sample data set but instead
of looking like this
what if it looked like this where we
have two sets of data
but one of them occurs in the middle of
another set you can see here where we
have the blue and the yellow
and then blue again on the other side of
our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like this
it's necessary to move away from a 1d
view of the data to a two-dimensional
view of the data and for the
transformation we use what's called a
kernel function the kernel function will
take the 1d input and transfer it to a
two-dimensional output as you can see in
this picture here the 1d when
transferred to a two-dimensional
makes it very easy to draw a line
between the two data sets
what if we make it even more complicated
how do we perform an svm for this type
of data set
here you can see we have a
two-dimensional data set where the data
is in the middle
surrounded by the green data on the
outside in this case we're going to
segregate the two classes we have our
sample data set
and if you draw a line through it's
obviously not an optimal hyperplane in
there
so to do that we need to transfer the 2d
to a 3d array and when you translate it
into a three-dimensional array using the
kernel you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data
before we start looking at a programming
example and dive into the script
let's look at the advantage of the
support vector machine we'll start with
high dimensional
input space or sometimes referred to as
the curse of dimensionality we looked at
earlier one dimension two dimension
three dimension when you get to a
thousand dimensions a lot of problems
start occurring with most algorithms
that have to be adjusted for
the svm automatically does that in high
dimensional space
one of the high dimensional space one
high dimensional space that we work on
is sparse document vectors
this is where we tokenize the words in
documents so we can run our machine
learning algorithms over them i've seen
ones get as high as 2.4 million
different tokens
that's a lot of vectors to look at and
finally we have
regularization parameter the relation
parameter or
lambda is a parameter that helps figure
out whether we're going to have a bias
or overfitting of the data whether it's
going to be over fitted to a very
specific instance or it's going to be
biased to a high or low value
with the svm it naturally avoids the
overfitting and bias problems that we
see in many other algorithms
these three advantages of the support
vector machine make it a very powerful
tool to add to your repertoire of
machine learning tools
now we did promise you a used case study
we're actually going to dive into some
python programming and so we're going to
go into a problem statement and start
off with the zoo
so in the zoo example we have family
members going to the zoo when we have
the young child going dead
is that a group of crocodiles or
alligators well that's hard to
differentiate and zoos are a great place
to start looking at science and
understanding how things work
especially as a young child and so we
can see the parents sitting here
thinking well what is the difference
between a crocodile and an alligator
well one
crocodiles are larger in size alligators
are smaller in size
snout widths the crocodiles have a
narrow snout and alligators have a wider
snout
and of course in the modern day and age
the father is sitting here thinking how
can i turn this into a lesson for my son
and he goes let a support vector machine
segregate the two groups
i don't know if my dad ever told me that
but that would be funny now
in this example we're not going to use
actual measurements and data we're just
using that for imagery and that's very
common in a lot of machine learning
algorithms and setting them up
but let's roll up our sleeves and we'll
talk about that more in just a moment
as we break into our python script so
here we arrive
in our actual coding and i'm going to
move this into a python editor
in just a moment but let's talk a little
bit about what we're going to cover
first we're going to cover in the code
the setup how to actually create our svm
and you're going to find that there's
only two lines of code that actually
create it and the rest of it is done
so quick and fast that it's all here in
the first page
and we'll show you what that looks like
as far as our data because we're going
to create some data i talked about
creating data just a minute ago and so
we'll get into the creating data here
and you'll see this nice correction of
our two blobs and we'll go through that
in just a second
and then the second part is we're going
to take this and we're going to bump it
up a notch
we're going to show you what it looks
like behind the scenes but let's start
with
actually creating our setup i like to
use the anaconda jupiter notebook
because it's very easy to use but you
can use any of your favorite python
editors
or setups and go in there but let's go
ahead and switch over there and see what
that looks like
so here we are in the anaconda python
notebook or anaconda jupiter notebook
with python we're using
python 3. i believe this is 3.5 but it
should be work
in any of your 3x versions and you'd
have to look at the sklearn and make
sure if you're using
a 2x version an earlier version let's go
and put our code in there
and one of the things i like about the
jupyter notebook is i go up to view
and i'm going to go ahead and toggle the
line numbers on to make it a little bit
easier
to talk about and we can even increase
the size because this is edited
in this case i'm using google chrome
explorer and that's how it opens up for
the editor
although anyone any like i said any
editor will work now the first step is
going to be our imports
and we're going to import four different
parts the first two
i want you to look at are line one and
line two are numpy as
np and matplot library dot pi plot as
plt now these are very standardized
imports when you're doing work the first
one is the numbers python
we need that because part of the
platform we're using uses that for the
numpy array
and i'll talk about that in a minute so
you can understand why we want to use a
numpy array versus the standard python
array and normally it's pretty standard
setup to use np for numpy the map plot
library is how we're going to view our
data
so this has you do need the np for the
sk learn module but the map plot library
is purely for our use for visualization
and so you really don't need that for
the svm but we're going to put it there
so you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like
that's really important at the end when
you finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at
and then finally we're going to i'm
going to jump one ahead to
line number four that's the
sklearn.datasets.samplesgenerator
import make blobs and i told you that we
were gonna make up data and this is a
tool that's in the sk learning to makeup
data i personally don't wanna go to the
zoo
get in trouble for jumping over the
fence and probably get eaten by the
crocodiles or alligators as i
work on measuring their snouts and width
and length
instead we're just going to make up some
data and that's what that make blobs is
it's a wonderful tool if you're ready to
test your your
setup and you're not sure about what
data you're going to put in there you
can create this blob and it makes it
real easy to use
and finally we have our actual svm the
sklearn
import svm on line three so that covers
all our imports
we're going to create remember i use the
make blobs to create data
and we're going to create a capital x
and a lowercase y
equals make blobs in samples equals 40.
so we're going to make 40 lines of data
it's going to have two centers with a
random state equals 20
so each each each group's going to have
20 different pieces of data in it and
the way that looks
is that we'll have under x um an x y
plane so i have two numbers under x
and y will be 0 1 that's the two
different centers so we have
yes or no in this case alligator or
crocodile that's what that represents
and then i told you that the actual sk
learner the svm
is in two lines of code and we see it
right here with clf
equals svm dot svc kernel equals linear
and i set sql to one although in this
example since we are not uh regularizing
the data
because we want to be very clear and
easy to see i went ahead you can set it
to a thousand a lot of times when you're
not doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example
we only have the two dimensions and
it'll be a nice linear
hyperplane it'll be a nice linear line
instead of a full plane so we're not
dealing with a huge amount of data
and then all we have to do is do clf dot
fit
x comma y and that's it clf has been
created
and then we're going to go ahead and
display it and i'm going to talk about
this display here in just a second but
let me go ahead and run this code
and this is what we've done is we've
created two blobs you'll see the blue on
the side and then kind of an orangish
on the other side that's our two sets of
data they represent one represents
crocodiles and one represents alligators
and then we have our measurements in
this case we have like the
width and length of the snout and i did
say i was going to come up here and talk
just a little bit about
our plot and you'll see plt that's what
we imported we're going to do a scatter
plot
that means we're just putting dots on
there and then look at this notation i
have the capital x
and then in brackets i have a colon
comma 0.
that's from numpy if you did that in a
regular array you'll get an error in a
python array
you have to have that in a numpy array
it turns out that our make blobs returns
a numpy array and this notation is great
because what it means
is the first part is the colon means
we're going to do all the rows that's
all the data in our blob we created
under capital x and then the second part
has a comma 0.
we're only going to take the first value
and then
if you notice we do the same thing but
we're going to take the second value
remember we always start with zero and
then one
so we have column zero and column one
and you can look at this
as our x y plots the first one is the x
plot and the second one is the y
plot so the first one is on the bottom 0
2
4 6 8 and 10 and then the second one
x of the one is the 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 going
up the left hand side
s equals 30 is just the size of the dot
so we can see them instead of real tiny
dots
and then c map equals plt.cm.paired
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color
we're using two colors zero one and
that's why we get the nice blue
and the two different colors for the
alligator and the crocodile
now you can see here that we did this
the actual fit was done in two lines of
code
a lot of times will be a third line
where we regularize the data we set it
between like minus one and one
and we reshape it but for this it's not
necessary and it's also kind of nice
because you can actually see what's
going
on and then if we wanted to we wanted to
actually run a prediction
let's take a look and see what that
looks like and to predict some new data
and we'll show this again as we get
towards the end of digging in
deep you can simply assign your new data
in this case i am giving it a
width and length 3 4 and a width and
length 5 6
and note that i put the data as a set of
brackets
and then i have the brackets inside and
the reason i do that is because
when we're looking at data it's designed
to process
a large amount of data coming in we
don't want to just process one line at a
time
and so in this case i'm processing two
lines and then i'm just going to print
and you'll see clf dot predict
new data so the clf and the dot predict
part
is going to give us an answer and let's
see what that looks like and you'll see
0 1. so predicted the first one the 3 4
is going to be
on the one side and the 5 6 is going to
be on the other side
so one came out as an alligator and one
came out as a crocodile now that's
pretty short explanation
for the setup but really we want to dug
in and see what it's going on behind the
scenes
and let's see what that looks like so
the next step is to dig
in deep and find out what's going on
behind the scenes
and also put that in a nice pretty graph
we're going to spend more work on this
than we did actually generating the
original model and you'll see here
that we go through a few steps and i'll
move this over to our editor in just a
second
we come in we create our original data
it's exactly identical to the first part
and i'll explain why we redid that
and show you how not to redo that and
then we're going to go in there
and add in those lines we're going to
see what those lines look like and how
to set those up
and finally we're going to plot all that
on here and show it and you'll get a
nice graph
with the what we saw earlier when we
were going through the theory behind
this
where it shows the support vectors and
the hyperplane
and those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line
i want you to notice line 13 has plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here
and i'm going to paste that code in and
you'll see that the plot show has moved
down below
let's scroll up a little bit and if you
look at the top here of our new section
one two three and four is the same code
we had before
and let's go back up here and take a
look at that we're gonna fit the values
on our svm and then we're gonna plot
scatter it and then we're gonna do a
plot
show so you should be asking why are we
redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot
so once i've done this plot show i have
to reload that data
now we could do this simply by removing
it up here re-running it
and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code
now in this it doesn't matter too much
and you'll see the plot show was down
here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out
our screen we want to move on to the
next setup so we can go ahead and just
skip the first four lines because we did
that before
and let's take a look at the ax equals
plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here
okay so this is how we display a nice
graph with our
results in our data ax is very standard
note used variable when you talk about
plt
and it's just setting it to that axis
the last axis in the plt
it can get very confusing if you're
working with many different layers of
data on the same graph
and this makes it very easy to reference
the ax so this
reference is looking at the plt that we
created and we already mapped out
our two blobs on and then we want to
know the limits so we want to know how
big the graph is
we can find out the x limit and the y
limit simply with the
get x limit and get y limit commands
which is part of our metplot
library and then we're going to create a
grid and you'll see down here we have
we've set the variable xx equal to
np.line space
x limit 0 x limit 1 comma 30 and we've
done the same thing for the y
space and then we're going to go in here
and we create a mesh grid and this is a
numpy
command so we're back to our numbers
python
let's go through what these numpy
commands mean with the line space and
the mesh grid
we've taken x x small s x x equals n p
line space and we have our x limit zero
and our x limit
one and we're going to create 30 points
on it
and we're going to do the same thing for
the y axis now this has nothing to do
with our evaluation
it's all we're doing is we're creating a
grid
of data and so we're creating a set of
points between 0
and the x limit we're creating 30 points
and the same thing with the y
and then the mesh grid loops those all
together so it forms a nice grid
so if we were going to do this say
between the limit 0 and 10 and do 10
points
we would have a 0 0 1 1 0 1
0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and so on you can just
imagine a point
at each corner one of those boxes and
the mesh grid combines them all so we
take the yy and the xx we created and
creates the full grid
and we've set that grid into the yy
coordinates and the xx coordinates
now remember we're working with numbi
and python we like to separate those we
like to have instead of it being
x comma 1 you know x comma y
and then x 2 comma y 2 and this in the
next set of data
it would be a column of x's and a column
of y's
and that's what we have here is we have
a column of y's and we put it as a
capital yy and a column of x's capital
xx
with all those different points being
listed and finally we get down to the
numpy v stack just as we created those
in the mesh grid
we're now going to put them all into one
array x
y array now that we've created the stack
of data points
we're going to do something interesting
here we're going to create a value
z and the z equals the clf
that's our that's our support vector
machine we created
and we've already trained and we have a
dot decision
function we're going to put the x y in
there so here we have all this data
we're going to put that x
y in there that data and we're going to
reshape it and you'll see that we have
the x
dot shape in here this literally takes
the xx
resets it up connected to the y and the
z
value lets us know whether it is the
left hand side is going to generate
three different values the z value does
and it'll tell us whether that data is a
support vector to the left
the hyperplane in the middle or the
support vector to the right
so it generates three different values
for each of those points
and those points have been reshaped so
they're right on a line on those three
different lines
so we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different
areas and we've reshaped it and we've
just taken 30 points in each direction
if you do the math you have 30 times 30
so it's 900 points of data and we
separated between the three lines and
reshaped it to fit those three lines
we can then go back to our map plot
library we've created the ax
and we're going to create a contour and
you'll see here we have contour
capital xx capital yy these have been
reshaped to fit those lines
z is the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals k
and i told you we had three different
labels but we have three
levels of data the alphas just makes it
kind of
see-through so it's only 0.5 of the
value in there so when we graph it the
data will show up from behind it
wherever the lines go
and finally the line styles this is
where we set
the two support vectors to be dash
dashed lines
and then a single one is just a straight
line that's what all that setup does
and then finally we take our ax dot
scatter we're going to go ahead and plot
the support vectors but we've programmed
it in there so that they look
nice like the dash dash line and the
dashed line on that grid
and you can see here when we do the clf
dot support vectors
we are looking at column 0 and column 1
and then again we have the s equals 100
so we're going to make them larger
and the line width equals 1 face colors
equals none let's take a look and see
what that looks like when we show it
and you can see we get down to our end
result it creates a really nice graph
we have our two support vectors and
dashed lines
and they have the near data so you can
see those two points or in this case the
four points where those lines
nicely cleave the data and then you have
your hyperplane down the middle which is
as far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout
and we've easily separated the two
groups of crocodile and alligator
congratulations
you've done it we've made it of course
these are pretend data
for our crocodiles and alligators but
this hands-on example will help you to
encounter
any support vector machine projects in
the future and you can see how easy they
are to set up
and look at in depth so what is k-means
clustering
k-means clustering is an unsupervised
learning algorithm in this case you
don't have
labeled data unlike in supervised
learning so you have a set of data
and you want to group them and as the
name suggests you want to
put them into clusters which means
objects that are similar in nature
similar in characteristics need to be
put together
so that's what k means clustering is all
about
the term k is basically is a number
so we need to tell the system how many
clusters we need to perform
so if k is equal to two there will be
two clusters if k is equal to three
three clusters and so on and so forth
that's what the k stands for
and of course there is a way of finding
out what is the best
or optimum value of k for a given data
we will look at that
so that is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but
let's take an example of cricket the
game of cricket
let's say you received data of a lot of
players from
maybe all over the country or all over
the world
and this data has information about
the runs scored by the people ordered by
the player
and the wickets taken by the player and
based on this information
we need to cluster this data into
two clusters batsman and bowlers so this
is an interesting example
let's see how we can perform this so we
have
the data which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the
wickets so the bowlers basically take
wickets and the batsmen
score runs there will be of course a few
bowlers who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will
who would have taken a few wickets but
with this information we want to
cluster those players into batsmen and
bowlers
so how does this work let's say this is
how the data
is so there are information there is
information
on the y-axis about the run scored
and on the x-axis about the wickets
taken by the players
so if we do a quick plot this is how it
would look
and when we do the clustering
we need to have the clusters like shown
in the third diagram rtms we need to
have a cluster which consists of
people who have scored high runs which
is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken
a lot of wickets which is typically the
bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to two
and we will have two clusters which is
batsman and bowlers so how does this
work
the way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering
is the allocation of two centroids
randomly so two points are assigned
as so-called centroids so
in this case we want two clusters which
means
k is equal to two so two points have
been
randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind these points can be
anywhere there are random points they
are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means
it's a central point of a given data set
but in this case when it starts off
it's not really the centroid okay so
these points though
in our presentation here we have shown
them
one point closer to these data points
and another closer to these data points
they can be assigned randomly anywhere
okay so that's the first step the next
step is to determine the distance of
each of the data points from
each of the randomly assigned centroids
so for example we take this point and
find the distance from the centroid
and the distance from this centroid this
point is taken
and the distance is found from this
centroid and the center and so on and so
forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from
both the centroids and then whichever
distance is less
that point is assigned to that centroid
so for example in this case
visually it is very obvious that all
these data points are assigned to this
centroid
and all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and that's what is
represented here in blue color
and in this yellow color the next step
is to
actually determine the central point or
the actual centroid for these two
clusters
so we have this one initial cluster this
one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the
central position of this data set
central position of this data set
so that is what needs to be determined
as the
next step so the central point of the
actual centroid is determined
and the original randomly allocated
centroid
is repositioned to the actual centroid
of these
new clusters and this process is
actually repeated now what might happen
is some of these points may get
reallocated in our example that is not
happening probably
but it may so happen that the distance
is found between each of these data
points once again
with these centroids and if there is if
it is required some points may be
reallocated we will see that in a later
example
but for now we will keep it simple so
this process is continued
till the centroid repositioning stops
and that is our final cluster
so this is our so after iteration
we come to this position this situation
where the centroid doesn't need
any more repositioning and that means
our
algorithm has converged convergence has
occurred
and we have the cluster two clusters we
have the clusters
with a centroid so this process is
repeated the process of calculating the
distance and repositioning
the centroid is repeated till the
repositioning stops which means that
the algorithm has converged and
we have the final cluster with the data
points
and the centroids so this is what you're
going to learn from this session
we will talk about the types of
clustering what is k-means clustering
application of k-means clustering
k-means clustering is done using
distance
measure so we will talk about the common
distance measures
and then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works
and go into the details of k-means
clustering algorithm
and then we will end with a demo and a
use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering
there are primarily two categories of
clustering hierarchical clustering
and then partitional clustering and each
of these categories are further
subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering
are in hierarchical clustering the
clusters have
a tree-like structure and hierarchical
clustering is further divided into
agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom-up
approach we begin with
each element as a separate cluster and
merge them into successively
larger clusters so for example we have a
b c d
e f we start by combining b and c form
one cluster
d e and e form one more then we combine
d e and f
one more bigger cluster and then add bc
to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering
is a top down approach we begin with the
whole set and proceed to divide it into
successively smaller clusters so we have
abcdef we first take that as a
single cluster and then break it down
into a b
c d e and f then we have partitional
clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering
and fuzzy c means in k-means clustering
the objects are divided into the number
of
clusters mentioned by the number k
that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics
are compared and all objects having
similar characteristics
are clubbed together so that's how k
means clustering is done
we will see it in more detail as we move
forward and fuzzy c means is very
similar to
k means in the sense that it clubs
objects that have similar
characteristics together but
while in k means clustering two objects
cannot belong to
or any object a single object cannot
belong to two different clusters
in c means objects can belong to more
than one cluster
so that is the primary difference
between k-means and fuzzy c means
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering
k-means clustering is used in a variety
of
examples or variety of business cases in
real life
starting from academic performance
diagnostic systems
search engines and wireless sensor
networks and many more so let us take a
little
deeper look at each of these examples
academic performance so
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b
c and so on clustering forms a backbone
of search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together
the search engines very often use
clustering to do this
and similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks
the clustering algorithm plays the role
of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective
cluster so clustering especially k means
clustering
uses distance measure so let's take a
look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of
clustering in this video we will focus
on
k-means clustering so distance measure
tells how similar some objects
are so the similarity is measured using
what is known as distance measure and
what are the various types of distance
measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance
then we have squared euclidean distance
measure and
cosine distance measure these are some
of the distance measures supported by
k-means clustering let's take a look at
each of these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points
so we have learnt in high school how to
find the distance between two points
this is a little sophisticated formula
for that
but we know a simpler one is square root
of
y2 minus y1 whole square plus x2 minus
x1 whole square
so this is an extension of that formula
so that is the
euclidean distance between two points
what is the squared
euclidean distance measure it's nothing
but
the square of the euclidean distance as
the name suggests
so instead of taking the square root we
leave
the square as it is and then we have
manhattan distance measure
in case of manhattan distance it is the
sum
of the distances across the x-axis
and the y-axis and note that we are
taking the absolute value
so that the negative values don't come
into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure
then we have cosine distance measure in
this case
we take the angle between the two
vectors
formed by joining the points from the
origin so that is the
cosine distance measure okay so that was
a quick
overview about the various distance
measures that are supported by
k-means now let's go and check how
exactly k-means clustering
works okay so this is how
k-means clustering works this is like a
flowchart
of the whole process there is a starting
point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want
now there are a couple of ways of doing
this we can
do by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe k is equal to 3
or 4 or 5 to start with and then as we
progress
we keep changing until we get the best
clusters
or there is a technique called elbow
technique
whereby we can determine the value of k
what should be the best value of k how
many clusters should be formed
so once we have the value of k we
specify that
and then the system will assign that
many
centroids so it picks randomly that to
start with
randomly that many points that are
considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of
each of the data points from these
centroids and assigns those points to
the corresponding
centroid from which the distance is
minimum so each data
point will be assigned to the centroid
which is
closest to it and thereby we have
k number of initial clusters
however this is not the final clusters
the next step
it does is for the new groups
for the clusters that have been formed
it calculates the main position
thereby calculates the new centroid
position
the position of the centroid moves
compared to the randomly allocated one
so it's an iterative process once again
the distance of each point is measured
from this new centroid point
and if required the data points are
reallocated to the new centroids
and the mean position or the new
centroid is calculated once again
if the centroid moves then the iteration
continues
which means the convergence has not
happened the clustering has not
converged
so as long as there is a movement of the
centroid
this iteration keeps happening but once
the centroid stops moving which means
that the cluster
has converged or the clustering process
has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have
the final position of the centroid and
the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest
centroid i know it's a little difficult
to understand from this
simple flowchart so let's do a little
bit of
visualization and see if we can explain
it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop
so let's say we have a data set for a
grocery shop
and now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across
so how do we find the optimum number of
clusters
there is a technique called the elbow
method so when
these clusters are formed there is a
parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower
this value is the better the cluster
is that means all these points are very
close to
each other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find
the optimum number of clusters that can
be formed for a given data set
so we create clusters or we let the
system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10 10 clusters and for each
value of k the within ss is
measured and the value of k which has
the least
amount of within ss or wss
that is taken as the optimum value of k
so this is the diagrammatic
representation so we have
on the y axis the within sum of squares
or wss
and on the x-axis we have the number of
clusters so
as you can imagine if you have k is
equal to 1 which means
all the data points are in a single
cluster the within s value
will be very high because they are
probably scattered all over
the moment you split it into two there
will be a drastic
fall in the within ss value that's what
is
represented here but then as the value
of k
increases the decrease the rate of
decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but
probably the rate of decrease will not
be high so
that gives us an idea so from here we
get an
idea for example the optimum value of k
should be either 2 or 3 or at the most
4 but beyond that increasing the number
of clusters
is not dramatically changing the value
in wss because that pretty much gets
stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points
the next step is basically to assign
two centroids randomly so let's say c1
and c2 are the centroids assigned
randomly now the distance of each
location
from the centroid is measured and each
point is assigned
to the centroid which is closest to it
so for example these points are very
obvious that these are
closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1
and these points or locations which are
close to c2 will be assigned to c2
and then so this is the how the initial
grouping is done
this is part of c1 and this is part of
c2 then the next step
is to calculate the actual centroid of
this data because
remember c1 and c2 are not the centroids
they have been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done
was the data points which are closest to
them
have been assigned but now in this step
the actual centroid will be calculated
which may be for each of these data sets
somewhere in the middle so that's like
the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned
or repositioned there same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position
and c1 is in this new position once
again
the distance of each of the data points
is calculated
from these centroids now remember it's
not necessary that the distance still
remains the
or each of these data points still
remain in the same group
by recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated
like so you see this so this point
earlier was closer to c2 because c2 was
here
but after recalculating repositioning
it is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2
so this is the new grouping so some
points will be reassigned
and again the centroid will be
calculated
and if the centroid doesn't change so
that is the repetitive process iterative
process and if the centroid doesn't
change once the centroid stops changing
that means the algorithm has converged
and this is our final cluster with this
as the centroid
c1 and c2 as the centroids these data
points as a part of each cluster
so i hope this helps in understanding
the whole process
iterative process of k-means clustering
so let's take a look at the k-means
clustering algorithm let's say we have
x1
x2 x3 n number of points as our inputs
and we want to split this into k
clusters
or we want to create k clusters so the
first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point
but they are just called centroids and
we calculate the distance of each and
every
input point from each of the centroids
so the distance of x1 from
c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances we
calculate
and then find out which distance is the
lowest
and assign x1 to that particular random
centroid
repeat that process for x2 calculate its
distance
from each of the centroids c1 c2 c3 up
to ck
and find which is the lowest distance
and assign x2 to that particular
centroid same with x3 and so on
so that is the first round of assignment
that is done
now we have k groups
because there are we have assigned the
value of
k so there are k centroids and
so there are k groups all these inputs
have been split into k
groups however remember we picked the
centroids randomly so they are not
real centroids so now what we have to do
we have to calculate the actual
centroids for
each of these groups which is like the
mean position
which means that the position of the
randomly selected
centroids will now change and they will
be the main positions of these newly
formed
k groups and once that is done
we once again repeat this process of
calculating the distance right so this
is what we are doing as a part of step
four
we repeat step two and three so we
again calculate the distance of x1
from the centroid c1 c2
c3 and then c which is the lowest value
and assign
x1 to that calculate the distance of x2
from c1 c2 c3 or whatever up to ck
and find whichever is the lowest
distance and assign x2 to that centroid
and so on in this process there may be
some reassignment
x1 was probably assigned to cluster c2
and after doing this calculation maybe
now x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen
so we repeat the steps 2 and 3
till the position of the centroids don't
change or stop changing and that's when
we have
convergence so let's take a detailed
look at
each of these steps so we randomly pick
k
cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not
initially they are not really the
centroids so we
let us name them c1 c2 up to ck and then
step two
we assign each data point to the closest
center so what we do we calculate the
distance of
each x value from each
c value so the distance between x1
c1 distance between x1 c2
x1 c3 and then we find which is the
lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign
x1 to that particular centroid then we
go next to x2
find the distance of x2 from c1 x2 from
c2
x2 from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value
and so on so that is step number two in
step number three
we now find the actual centroid for each
group so what has happened
as a part of step number two we now have
all the points all the data points
grouped into
k groups because we we wanted to create
k clusters
right so we have k groups each one may
be having
a certain number of input values they
need not be equally
distributed by the way based on the
distance we will have
k groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups
right we assigned them randomly so now
in step 3 we actually calculate
the centroid of each group which means
the
original point which we thought was the
centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups
okay and we again calculate the distance
so we go back to step
two which is what we calculate again the
distance of
each of these points from the newly
positioned
centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the
new centroids so as i said earlier
there may be a reallocation so we now
have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was
in step two here okay
so that might change then we perform
step three once again
to find the new centroid of this new
group
so we have again a new set of clusters
new centroids and new assignments we
repeat this
step two again once again we find and
then
it is possible that after iterating
through
three or four or five times the centroid
will stop
moving in the sense that when you
calculate the new value of the centroid
that will be same as the original value
or there will be very marginal change
so that is when we say convergence has
occurred and that is our final
cluster that's the formation of the
final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see
some live demos in python notebook using
pattern notebook
but before that let's find out what's
the problem that we are trying to solve
the problem statement is let's say
walmart wants to open
a chain of stores across the state of
florida
and it wants to find the optimal
store locations now the issue here is
if they open too many stores close to
each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales
so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce
giant they already have the addresses
of their customers in their database so
they can
actually use this information or this
data
and use k-means clustering to find the
optimal
location now before we go into the
python notebook and show you the live
code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary
of the code in the slides and then we
will go into the
python notebook so in this block
we are basically importing all the
required libraries
like numpy matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available
in the form of let's say the addresses
for simplicity sake we will just take
them as some data points
then the next thing we do is quickly do
a scatter plot to see
how they are related to each other with
respect to each other
so in the scatter plot we see that there
are a few distinct
groups already being formed so you can
actually get an idea about
how the cluster would look and how many
clusters what is the optimal
number of clusters and then starts the
actual
k-means clustering process so we will
assign each of these points to the
centroids and then check whether they
are the optimal distance
which is the shortest distance and
assign each of the
points data points to the centroids
and then go through this iterative
process till the whole
process converges and finally we get an
output like this
so we have four distinct clusters and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across
florida state and the centroids
are like the location where the store
should be
the optimum location where the store
should be
so that's the way we determine
the best locations for the store and
that's how we can help
walmart find the best locations for
their stores
in florida so now let's take this
into python notebook let's see how this
looks when we are running
running the code live all right so this
is the code for
k-means clustering in jupiter notebook
we have a few examples here which we
will
demonstrate how k-means clustering is
used and even
there is a small implementation of
k-means clustering as well
okay so let's get started okay so this
block
is basically importing the various
libraries that are required
like matplotlib and numpy and so on and
so forth
which would be used as a part of the
code then
we are going and creating blobs which
are
similar to clusters now this is a very
neat feature which is available in
scikit learn
make blobs is a nice feature which
creates
clusters of data sets so that's a
wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some
test data kind of thing okay so that's
exactly what we are doing here we are
using
make blobs and we can specify how many
clusters we want so centers we are
mentioning here
so it will go ahead and so we just
mentioned four so it will go ahead and
create some test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can
figure out that there are four distinct
classes or clusters
in this data set and that is what
make blobs actually provides
now from here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so
we really don't have to implement
k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available
you just need to feed the data and we'll
create the clusters
so this is the code for that we import
k-means
and then we create an instance of
k-means
and we specify the value of k this n
underscore clusters is the value of k
remember k means in k means k is
basically the number of
clusters that you want to create and it
is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k
is equal to 4 and so that instance is
created
we take that instance and as with any
other
machine learning functionality fit is
what we use the function
or the method rather fit is what we use
to train the model here there is no real
training
kind of thing but that's the call okay
so we are calling fit
and what we are doing here we are just
passing the data so x has these values
the data that has been created right so
that is what we are passing here and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters
and then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which uh basically assigns for each of
these
observations which cluster where it
belongs to
all right so it will name the clusters
maybe this is cluster 1 this is 2
3 and so on or i will actually start
from 0
cluster 0 1 2 and 3 maybe and then
for each of the observations it will
assign based on which cluster it belongs
to
it will assign a value so that is stored
in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these
uh y underscore k means or with the
cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number
assigned for observation 1 maybe this is
for observation 2 observation 3 and so
on so
we have how many about i think 300
samples right so all the 300 samples
there are 300 values here each of them
the cluster number is given and the
cluster number goes from 0
to 3. so there are four clusters so the
numbers go from 0
1 2 3. so that's what is seen here
okay now so this was a quick example of
generating some
dummy data and then clustering that okay
and this can be applied if you have
proper data you can just
load it up into x for example here and
then
run the cable so this is the central
part of the
k-means clustering program example so
you basically
create an instance and you mention how
many
clusters you want by specifying this
parameter and underscore clusters
and that is also the value of k and then
pass the data
to get the values now the next section
of
this code is the implementation of
a k-means now this is kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means algorithm
so we will just
walk you through i will walk you through
the code uh at each step what it is
doing
and then we will see a couple of more
examples of
how k-means clustering uh can be used
in maybe some real-life examples
real-life use cases
all right so in this case here what we
are doing is
basically implementing k means
clustering
and there is a function for a library
calculates for a given two pairs of
points
it will calculate the the distance
between them
and see which one is the closest and so
on so this is like this is pretty much
like what
k means does right so it calculates the
distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid
and then based on whichever is the
lowest this particular data point is
assigned to that
centroid so that is basically available
as a standard function and we will be
using that here
so as explained in the slides the first
step that
is done in case of k-means clustering
is to randomly assign some
centroids so as a first step we randomly
allocate
a couple of centroids which we call here
we are calling as centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function
pairwise distance argument for each of
the points we find out
which one which center or which randomly
selected centroid
is the closest and accordingly we
assign the data or the data point
to that particular centroid or cluster
and once that is done for all the data
points
we calculate the new centroid
by finding out the mean position because
the center position right so we
calculate the new centroid and then we
check
if the new centroid is the coordinates
or the position
is the same as the previous centroid
the positions we will compare and if it
is the same
that means the process has converged so
remember we do this process
till the centroids or the centroid
doesn't move anymore
right so the centroid gets relocated
each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop
while true is an infinite loop it only
breaks when
the centers are the same the new center
and the old center positions are the
same and once that is uh done we return
the centers and the labels now of course
as explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is
the centroid the position will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case
also with that is actually convergence
right so for example the change is point
zero zero zero one
we can consider that as convergence
otherwise what will happen is this will
either take forever or it will be never
ending so
that's a small flaw here so that is
something additional checks may have to
be added here but again as
mentioned this is not the most
sophisticated implementation
uh this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k means clustering
okay so if we execute this code this is
what we get
as the output so this is the definition
of this particular
function and then we call that find
underscore clusters and we pass our data
x and the number of clusters which is 4
and if we
run that and plot it this is the output
that we get so this is of course each
cluster is represented by
a different color so we have a cluster
in green color yellow color and so on
and so forth
and these big points here these are the
centroids this is the final position of
the centroids and as you can see
visually also
this appears like a kind of a center of
all these points here right similarly
this is like the center of
all these points here and so on so this
is the
example or this is an example of an
implementation
of k means clustering and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how
k means clustering is used in
maybe some real life scenarios or use
cases
in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform
color compression we will take a couple
of images
so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress
the colors this is a common situation in
image processing when you have an image
with
millions of colors but then you cannot
render it
on some devices which may not have
enough memory uh so that is the
scenario where something like this can
be used
so before again we go into the python
notebook
let's take a look at quickly the the
code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the
image and then we will flatten it
so the reshaping is basically we have
the
image information is stored in the form
of pixels
and if the image is like for example 427
by 640
and it has three colors so that's the
overall
dimension of the of the initial image
we just reshape it and then
feed this to our algorithm
and this will then create clusters of
only 16 clusters so this this colors
there are millions of colors
and now we need to bring it down to 16
colors so we
use k is equal to 16 and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks
and after compression to 16 colors
this is how the new image looks as you
can see there is
not a lot of information that has been
lost
though the image quality is definitely
reduced a little bit so this is
an example which we are going to now see
in python notebook let's go into the
python node
and once again as always we will import
some libraries
and load this image called
flower dot jpg okay so let we
load that and this is how it looks this
is the original image which has i think
16 million
colors and this is the shape of this
image which is basically
what is the shape is nothing but the
overall size
right so this is 427 pixel by 640 pixel
and then there are three layers which is
this three basically is for rgb which is
red green blue
so color image will have that right so
that is the shape of this
now what we need to do is data let's
take a look at how
data is looking so let me just create a
new cell
and show you what is in data basically
we have captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so let's take a look at china
what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values
okay so this is like a matrix and each
one has
about four for this 427 by 640 pixels
all right so this is how it looks now
the issue here is these values are large
the numbers are
a large so we need to normalize them to
between zero and one
right so that's why we will basically
create one more
variable which is data which will
contain the values between zero and one
and the way to do that is divide by
255 so we divide china by 255
and we get the new values in data so
let's just run this
piece of code and this is the shape so
we
now have also yeah what we have done is
we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional
into a two-dimensional data set and let
us also take a look at how
let me just insert probably
a cell here and take a look at how data
is looking
all right so this is how data is looking
and now you see
this is the values are between zero and
one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between 0 and 1. this
is one of the things we
need to do all right so after that the
next thing that we need to do is to
visualize this
and we can take random set of maybe 10
000 points
and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this and
so this is how the original the color
the pixel distribution is
these are two plots one is red against
green and another is red against
blue and this is the original
distribution of the color
so then what we will do is we will use k
means clustering to
create just 16 clusters for the various
colors
and then apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors
using regular k-means may be a little
time consuming so there is another
version of k-means which is
called mini batch gaming so we will use
that which is which processes in
the overall concept remains the same but
this basically
processes it in smaller batches that's
the only thing okay
so the results will pretty much be the
same so
let's go ahead and execute this piece of
code
and also visualize this so that we can
see that there are
these this is how the 16 colors would
look
so this is red against green and this is
red against
blue there is a quite a bit of
similarity between this original
color schema and the new one right so it
doesn't look
very very completely different or
anything like that now
we apply this the newly created colors
to the image and we can take a look uh
how this is looking now we can compare
both the images so this is our original
image
and this is our new image so as you can
see
there is not a lot of information that
has been
lost it pretty much looks like the
original image
yes we can see that for example here
there is a little bit
uh it appears a little dullish compared
to this one
right because we kind of took off some
of the finer
details of the color but overall
the high level information has been
maintained at the same time
the main advantage is that now this can
be this is an image which can be
rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated
now let's take one more example with a
different image
in the second example we will take an
image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process
this is a high definition color image
with millions of colors and also
three dimensional now we will reduce
that to
16 colors using k means clustering
and we do the same process like before
we reshape it and then we cluster the
colors
to 16 and then we render the image
once again and we will see that the
color the quality
of the image slightly deteriorates as
you can see here
this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because
there are some devices which may not be
able to handle
this kind of high density images so
let's
run this chord in python notebook all
right so
let's apply the same technique for
another picture which is
even more intricate and has probably
much complicated color schema so
this is the image now once again we can
take a look
at the shape which is 427 by 640 by
3 and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this
compared to the flower image so we have
some new values here
and we will also bring this as you can
see the numbers are much big
so we will much bigger so we will now
have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and
do that and reshape it okay
so we get a two-dimensional
matrix and we will then as a next step
we will go ahead and visualize this how
it looks
does the 16 colors and this is basically
how it would look
16 million colors and now we can
create the clusters out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how
the distribution of the pixels would
look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and apply this
and visualize how it is looking for
with the new just the 16 color so once
again as you can see
this looks much richer in color but at
the same time
and this probably doesn't have as we can
see
it doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless
the information is not lost the shape
and all that stuff
and this can be also rendered on a
slightly
a device which is probably not that
sophisticated
okay so that's pretty much it so we have
seen two examples of how
color compression can be done using
k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples
of how to implement k-means the code to
roughly how to implement
k-means clustering and we use some
sample data using blob to
just execute the k-means clustering
dimensionality reduction
dimensionality reduction refers to the
technique that reduces the number of
input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders
made at an automobile parts retailer
the retailer sells different automobile
parts from different companies
and you can see we have company b-packs
iso max
and they have the item the tire the axle
an order id
a price number and a quantity in order
to predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes
from five to three and clearly we don't
really care about the part number
i don't think the part number would have
an effect on how many tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those
and we just have the item the tire the
price and the quantity
one of the things you should be taking
away from this is in the scheme of
things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data
and we're pre-processing the data what
can we do to clean it up
why dimensionality reduction well number
one less dimensions for a given data set
means
less computation or training time that
can be
really important if you're trying a
number of different models
and you're re-running them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data
that can start taking days to go through
all those different models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set redundancy is removed after
removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data
it might give them a higher weight than
they would if it was just once we want
to get rid of that redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in space required to store
the data is reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it
why would we want to store two whole
extra columns when we added into that
pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2d
and 3d plots
this is my favorite part very important
you're in your shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing
leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four
it makes data easy for plotting you have
a better interpretation when we're
looking at it
principle component analysis so what is
it
uh principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets
increasing interpretability but at the
same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables
we run it through the pca we reduce the
variables we end up with the reduced
variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because
if you look at the end result we have
the different colors all lined up
so what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this
we say okay this is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling
a lot of the people in the class are
missing so we have a huge amount off to
the right of blank space
maybe from up here again we have the
back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from
might be this bottom left angle you look
at it you say hey that makes sense it's
a
good configuration of all the people
in the picture now when we're talking
about data
it's not you really can't do it by what
you think is going to be the best we
need to have some kind of mathematical
formula so it's consistent and so it
makes sense in the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data set it's
probably one of the
most common ones out there where they
have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal
we could just as easily do the
width-to-length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my iris
pedal example when we look at the
similarity
in pca we find the best picture or
projection
of the data points and so we look down
at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there we can see
these data points based on in this case
just two variables now keep in mind
we're usually talking about 36
40 variables almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27 different
variables they're looking at same thing
with like a bank loan model we're
talking 26 to 36 different variables
they're looking at that are going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the xy
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this
x y this time from a different direction
here for our
e's we can consider that we get two
principal components namely pc1 and
pc2 comparing
both the principal components we find
the data points are sufficiently spaced
in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2
and that's what they're coming up with
what is going to give us the best look
for these data points when we combine
them and we're looking at them from just
a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc one and not
the pc2 as the data points are more
spaced
now obviously the back end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable this gives you an
idea though that when we're talking
about this we're talking about the
perspective
which would help in understanding how
pca
analysis works we want to go ahead and
do is dive into the important
terminologies
under uh pca and important terminologies
are views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation
and they're not taking the time to
reduce it to something that the average
person shareholders can understand you
might hear them refer to it as the
different views what view are we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
and we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions
i was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27 different
features
minimal and then you have the principal
component new variables that are
constructed as
linear combinations or mixtures of the
initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination
if you remember my flower example it
would be
the width over the length of the pedal
as opposed to putting both width and
length in you just put in the
ratio instead which is a single number
versus two separate numbers
projections the perpendicular distance
between the principal component
and the data points and that goes to
that line
we had earlier it's that right angle
line of where those point
all those points fall onto the line
important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense you're not
going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through
principal components are orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line
same thing with pc2 we want to make sure
that pc1 does not equal pc2
we don't want to have the same two
principal points
when we do two points the priority of
principal components
decreases as their numbers
increase this is important to understand
if you're going to create one
principle component everything is
summarized
into that one component as we go to two
components
the priority how much it holds
value decreases as we go down so if you
have five different points
each one of those points is going to
have less value than just the one point
which has everything summarized in it
how pca works i said there was more in
the back end we talk about
the math this is what we're talking
about is how does it actually
work so now we have understanding that
you're looking at a perspective now we
want to see how that math side works
pca performs the following operations in
order to evaluate
the principal components for a given
data set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the i gene vector
is like a translation for moving the
data
from x equals one to x equals two or
whatever we're altering it
and the ign value is the final value
that we generate
when we talk about standardization the
main aim of this step
is to standardize the range of the
attributes so that each one of them
lie within similar boundaries this
process involves removal
of the mean from the variable values and
scaling the data
with respect to the standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean
over the standard deviation the
covariance matrix
computation covariance matrix is used to
express the correlation between
any two or more attributes in
multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
tribute values
the variance is denoted by var and the
covariance is denoted by
cov on the right we can see the
covariance matrix for two attributes and
their values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance
and then the covariance of x to y
on the right side we can see the
covariance table for more than two
attributes in a multi-dimensional data
set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature two features we're usually
looking at
25 30 features going on
and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related
positive covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is directly
proportional to the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is
inversely proportional to the other
variable that is always important to
note whenever we're doing any of these
matrixes that we're going to be looking
at that positive and negative whether
it's inverted or not
and then we have the iogene values and
the i gene vectors
eigenvalues and hygiene vectors are the
mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables
which further lead to the construction
of the principal components
igen vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
i gene values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the i gene
vectors and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change uh
the vector b to the b prime as denoted
on the chart and so we have like
multiple variables
how do we calculate that new variable
and then we have
feature vectors feature vectors is
simply a matrix that has igen vectors of
the components that we decide to keep as
the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps
this becomes really important as we
start
looking at the back end of this and
we'll do this in the
demo but one of the more important steps
to understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k
columns or variables now for this matrix
we would construct a variable space with
as many dimensions
as the variable but for our simplicity
let's consider this three dimensions for
now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k-dimensional variable
space
such that the rows in the data table
form a swarm of points
in this space now we find the mean of
all the observations and then place it
along the data points on the plot
the first principal component is a line
that best accounts for the shape of the
point swarm
it represents the maximum variance
direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1
this value is known as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set
thus a second principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source
of variation in the data while being
orthogonal to pc1 pc2
also passes through the average point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means
inside our python scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in python 3.6
for this example i believe there's even
like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use
especially with the neural networks are
stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our jupiter i'm in
chrome
and we go ahead and create a new python
three
and for ease of use our team in the back
was nice enough to put this together for
me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries the first thing i like to do
whenever i'm looking at
any new setup uh well you know what
let's do let's do the libraries first
we're going to do our basic libraries
which is matplot library
the plt from the matplot library pandas
our data frame
pd numpy our numbers array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the
plot that actually sits on that plot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook matplot
library in line
the newer version actually doesn't
require that but i put it in there
either
anyway just because i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the
data and in this case we're going to
pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
and one of the reasons the cancer data
set is it has like 36 35 different
features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set
as we have our data we have our target
our frame target names description
feature names and file name
so what we're looking for in all this
is let's take a look at the description
let's go in here
and pull up the description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain
we want to focus on our pca setup
what's important is you start looking at
what the different attributes are what
they mean
if you were in the medical field you'd
want to note all these different things
whether what they're measuring where
it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different measurements they're taking
no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data
in this case our target and if you dig
deep enough to the target
let's actually do this let's go ahead
and print
target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target names
run that yeah
so the target name is is it malignant or
is it b9
so in other words is this dangerous
growth or is it something we don't have
to worry about that's the bottom line
with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data and uh you know let me go up a
just a notch here for easy of reading
it's hard to get that just right that's
all you have to do
uh so let's go ahead and look at our
data uh our we're going to use our
pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data
columns equals cancer feature equals
feature names so remember up here we
already loaded the the
names up of our of the features in there
what is going to come out of this let me
just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and i'll print the head and you can see
here we have the mean radius the mean
texture
mean perimeter i don't know about you
this is a wonderful data set if you're
playing with it because
like many of the data that most of the
data that comes in half the time we
don't even know we're looking at
uh we're just handed a bunch of stuff as
a data scientist going what the heck is
this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there we have no idea what
these feature means or where they come
from
we want to just look at the data and
figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it
as we've noticed before it's difficult
to visualize high dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components
and visualize the data this new
two-dimensional space
with a single scatter plot before we do
this we need to go ahead and scale our
data
now i haven't run this to see if you
really have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any
modeling even if it's pre-modeling as
we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization
it's already going to scale it when we
do the means and deviation inside the
pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit
learn uses very similar process to other
pre-processing functions that come with
scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method
then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform
we can also specify how many components
we want to
keep when creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead let me
go and run this code
so the code for this is
from sk learn decomposition import pca
pca equals pca in components equals 2
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else
if you're showing this to the
shareholders the whole idea is to reduce
it to something people can see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the
scaled data that we generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals 2.
now whenever i use a new tool i like to
go in there and actually see what i'm
using so let's go to
the scikit webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different
setups you have on there probably the
biggest one to look at would be
well the biggest one is your components
how many components do you want
which you have to put in there pretty
much and then you also might look at the
svd solver it's on auto right now but
you can override that and do different
things with it
it does a pretty good job as it is
and if we go down all the way down to
um
there we go to our methods if you notice
we have
fit we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not
used for prediction it's used to look at
the data again we're in the describe
setup
we're fitting the data we're taking a
look at it we've already looked at
our minimum maximum we've already looked
at what's in each quarter
we've done a full description of the
data this is part of describing
the data that's the biggest thing i take
away when i come
zooming in here and of course i have
examples of it down here if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full or randomized there's different
things
it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two
principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform
scaled data so there we go there's our
first transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape
and the xpca data shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us uh
what's going on here we've taken 30
features
i think i said 36 or something like that
but it's 30
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows data sets we still have
569 rows of data
but instead of computing 30 features
we're now only doing our
model on two features
so let's go ahead and plot these and
take a look and see what's going on
and
we're just going to use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here
here's our scatter plot xpca
x underscore pca of of one
these are two different perceptions
we're using
uh and then you'll see right here c for
color
cancer equals target and so remember we
have
zero we have one and if i remember
correctly
0 was malignant 1 was b9
so everything in the zero column is
going to be one color and the other
color is going to be
1 and then we're going to use the plasma
map just kind of tell you what color it
is
add some labels first principal
component second principle component
and we'll go ahead and run this and you
can see here
instead of having a chart one of those
heat maps with 30
different columns in it we can look at
this and say hey this one actually did a
pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple of things when i'm looking
at this that i notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together
where it's going to be benign and we
have a huge area
it's still clumped together more spread
out where it's going to be malignant
or i think i had that backwards and then
in the middle
because we're dealing with something in
this particular case
cancer we would try to separate i would
be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps and we're not going
to have a clear result
on it just because those are the people
you want to go in there and have extra
tests
or treat it differently versus going in
and saying just cutting into the can
into the cancer so the body absorbs it
and it dissipates
versus actively going in there removing
it testing it going through chemo and
all the different things
that's a big difference you know as far
as what's going to happen here in that
middle line where the overlap is going
to be huge
that's domain specific going back to the
data
we can see here clearly by using these
two components we can easily separate
these two classes so the next step is
what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction
comes the cost of not being able to
easily understand what these components
represent
i don't know what principle component
one looks work represents or second
principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features
the components themselves are stored as
an attribute of the filtered pca
object and so we talk look at that we
can go ahead and do
look at the pca components this is in
our model we built
we've trained it we can run that and you
can see here's the actual components
uh it's the two components have each
have their own array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores are using
and these actually give weight to what
features
are doing what so in this
numpy matrix array each row represents a
principal component and each column
relates back to the original features
what's
really neat about this is we can now go
in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing what this means and so
let me go ahead
and just put this down up here to get it
down here
we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our df comp data
frame
and we do our pca components and i want
you to notice how easy this
is we're going to set our columns equal
to cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy and we're
dumping it into a data frame what's neat
about a data frame
is when we get to seaborn it will pull
that data frame apart
and and set it up for us what we want
and so we're just going to do the see
the seaborne heat map
of our data frame composition and we'll
use the plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little color graph
here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom
on the right uh we have a scale so we
can see we have the dark colors all the
way to
the really light colors which are what's
really shining there this is like the
primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map and the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features
and the principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here
and we might notice that the mean radius
look how how on the bottom of the map it
is
on some of this so you have some
interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to a post
scribe you can also use this to try to
guess as what these things mean and what
you want to change to get a better
result
why reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data
which might not always be available to
us further the data provided
might not be reliable learning from a
small subset of actions will not help
expand the vast realm of solutions that
may work for a particular problem
you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and
you'll start asking questions like if
i'm taking one step forward and left
what happens if i pick up a 50 pound
object
how does that change how a robot would
walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until
it's actually tried out learning from a
small subset of actions will not help
expand the vast realm of solutions that
may work for a particular problem
and we'll see here learned how to walk
this is going to slow the growth
that technology is capable of machines
need to learn to perform
actions by themselves and not just learn
off humans and you see the objective
climb a mountain real interesting point
here
is that as human beings we can go into a
very
unknown environment and we can adjust
for it and kind of explore and play with
it
most of the models the non-reinforcement
models in
computer machine learning aren't able to
do that very well
there's a couple of them that can be
used or integrated
to see how it goes is what we're talking
about with reinforcement learning
so what is reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is a
sub-branch of machine learning that
trains a model to return an
optimum solution for a problem by taking
a sequence of decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another
the robot is given a scenario must
arrive at a solution by itself
the robot can take different paths to
reach the destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each path and might even come
up with a
unique solution all by itself and that's
really important is we're looking for
unique solutions
we want the best solution but you can't
find it unless you try it
so we're looking at uh our different
systems our different model we have
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning
and with the supervised learning that is
probably the most controlled environment
we have a lot of different supervised
learning models whether it's linear
regression
neural networks there's all kinds of
things in between decision trees
the data provided is labeled data with
output values
specified and this is important because
we talk about supervised learning you
already know the answer for all this
information
you already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so your supervised
learning you already know that um
the outcome for tomorrow for you know
going back a week you're looking at
stock
you can already have like the graph of
what the next day looks like so you have
an
answer for it and you have labeled data
which is used you have an external
supervision
and solves problems by mapping labeled
input to no one output
so very controlled unsupervised learning
and unsupervised learning is really
interesting because it's now taking part
in many other models they start with and
you can actually insert an unsupervised
learning model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning as part of the
system
which is really cool data provided is
unlabeled data
the outputs are not specified machine
makes its own predictions
used to solve association with
clustering problems
unlabeled data is used no supervision
solves problems by understanding
patterns and discovering output
so you can look at this and you can
think um
some of these things go with each other
they belong together
so it's looking for what connects in
different ways and there's a lot of
different algorithms that look at this
when you start getting into those are
some really cool images that come up
of what unsupervised learning is how it
can pick out say
the area of a donut one model will see
the area of the donut and the other one
will divide it into
three sections based on its location
versus what's next to it
so there's a lot of stuff that goes in
with unsupervised learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest
industry in today's market in machine
learning or growing market it's very
it's very infant stage as far as how it
works and what's going to be capable of
the machine learns from its environment
using rewards and errors
used to solve reward based problems no
predefined
data is used no supervision follows
trail and error problem solving approach
so again we have a random first you
start with a random i try this
it works and this is my reward doesn't
work very well maybe
or maybe doesn't even get you where
you're trying to get it to do and you
get your reward back
and then it looks at that and says well
let's try something else
and it starts to play with these
different things finding the best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement
model and this has become pretty
standardized over the last
few years so these are really good to
know we have the
agent agent is the model that is being
trained via reinforcement learning
so this is your actual entity that has
however you're doing it with using a
neural network or
a cue table or whatever
combination thereof this is the actual
agent that you're using this is the
model
and you have your environment uh the
training situation that the model must
optimize to is called its environment
and you can see here i guess we have a
robot who's trying to get
chest full of gems or whatever and
that's the output and then you have your
action
this is all possible steps that can be
taken by the model
and it picks one action and you can see
here it's picked three different
routes to get to the chest of diamonds
and gyms
we have a state the current position
condition returned
by the model and you could look at this
if you're playing like a video game this
is the screen you're looking at
so when you go back here the environment
is a whole
game board so if you're playing one of
those mobius games
you might have the whole game board
going on uh but then you have
your current position where are you on
that game board what's around that
what's around you if you were talking
about a robot
the environment might be moving around
the yard
where it is in the yard and what it can
see what input it has in that location
that would be the current position
condition returned by the model
and then the reward to help the model
move in the right direction
it is rewarded points are given to it to
appraise some kind of action
so yeah you did good or didn't do as
good
trying to maximize the reward and have
the best reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time it acts as
a mapping between action
and present state this is part of the
model
what is your action that you're you're
going to take what's the policy you're
using
to have an output from your agent one of
the reasons they separate
policy as its own entity
is that you usually have a prediction
of a different options and then the
policy well how am i going to pick
the best based on those predictions i'm
going to guess
at different options and we'll actually
weigh those options in and find the best
option we
think will work so it's a little tricky
but the policy thing is actually pretty
cool how it works
let's go and take a look at a
reinforcement learning example
and just in looking at this we're going
to take a look consider what a dog
that we want to train so the dog would
be like the
agent so you have your your puppy or
whatever
and then your environment is going to be
the whole
house or whatever it is where you're
training them and then you have an
action we want to teach the dog to fetch
so action equals fetching and then we
have a little biscuit so we can get the
dog perform various actions by offering
incentives such as a dog biscuit as a
reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence
will follow every command and might even
learn new actions like
begging by itself uh so you have you
know so we start off with fetching it
goes oh i get a biscuit for that
it tries something else you get a
handshake or begging or something like
that
and it goes oh this is also reward based
and so kind of explores things to find
out what will bring is
biscuit and that's very much like how
reinforced model goes as it
looks for different rewards how do i
find can i try different things and find
a reward that works
the dog also will want to run around and
play in explorer's environment
uh this quality of model is called
exploration
so there's a little randomness going on
in exploration
and explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa
doesn't get a reward in fact it usually
gets kicked off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process
markov's decision process is a
reinforcement learning policy used to
map a current state to an action
where the agent continuously interacts
with the environment to produce new
solutions and receive rewards
and you'll see here's all of our
different vocabulary we just went over
we have a reward our state our agent our
environment interaction
and so even though the environment kind
of contains
everything that you really
when you're actually writing the program
your environment's going to put out
a reward in state that goes into the
agent
the agent then looks at this state or it
looks at the reward usually um
first and it says okay i got rewarded
for whatever i just did
or it didn't get rewarded and it looks
at the state
and then it comes back and if you
remember from policy the policy comes in
and then we have a reward the policy is
that part that's connected at the bottom
and so it looks at that policy and says
hey what's a good action
that will probably be similar to what i
did or
sometimes they're completely random but
what's a good action that's going to
bring me a different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces
as they go is pretty important in most
of the models today
um and so a lot of them actually have
templates
based on this you can pull in and start
using
pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works
uh you can see your environment sends it
says hey this is
the agent did this if you're a character
in the game this happened
and it shoots out a reward in a state
the agent looks at the reward looks at
the new state
and then takes a little guess and says
i'm going to try this action
and then that action goes back into the
environment it
affects the environment the environment
then changes depending on what the
action was and then it has a new state
and a new reward that goes back to the
agent
so in the diagram shown we need to find
the shortest path between node a
and d each path has a reward associated
with it
and the path with a maximum reward is
what we want to choose
the nodes a b c d denote the nodes to
travel from node
a to b is an action reward is the cost
of each path
and policy is each path taken
and you can see here a can go uh to b
or a can go to c right off the bat or it
can go right to d
and if you explored all three of these
you would find that a going to d
was a zero reward a going to c
and d would generate a different reward
or you could go a c b d there's a lot of
options here
and so when we start looking at this
diagram you start to realize
that even though today's reinforced
learning models do really
good at finding an answer they end up
trying almost all the different
directions you see
and so they take up a lot of work or a
lot of processing time for reinforcement
learning
they're right now in their infant stage
and they're really good at solving
simple problems and we'll take a look at
one of those in just a minute in the
tic-tac-toe game
but you can see here once it's gone
through these and it's explored
it's going to find the a c d is the best
reward he gets a full
30 points for it so let's go ahead and
take a look at a reinforcement
learning demo
in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a
tic-tac-toe
game you'll be playing this game against
the machine learning model
and we'll go ahead and we're doing it in
python so let's go ahead and go through
i always not always actually have a lot
of python tools
let's go through anaconda which will
open up a jupiter notebook
seems like a lot of steps but it's worth
it to keep all my stuff separate and
it's also has a nice display when you're
in the jupiter notebook for doing python
so here's our anaconda navigator i open
up the
notebook which is going to take me to a
webpage and i've gone in here and
created a new
python folder in this case i've already
done it and enabled it to change the
name to tic-tac-toe
and then for this example we're going to
go ahead and
import a couple things we're going to
import numpy as np we'll go ahead and
import pickle
lumpy of course is our number array and
then pickle is just a nice way sometimes
for
storing different information different
states that we're going to go through on
here
and so we're going to create a class
called state
we're going to start with that
and there's a lot of lines of code to
this class that we're going to put in
here
don't let that scare you too much
there's not as much here
it looks like there's going to be a lie
here but there really is just a lot of
setup going on in the in
our class state and so we have up here
we're going to initialize it
we have our board it's a tic tac toe
board so we're only dealing with nine
spots on the board
we have player one player two uh
is end we're gonna create a board hash
we'll look at that in just a minute
we're just going to store some
information in there
symbol player equals one so there's a
few things going on as far as the
initialization
then something simple we're just going
to get the hash of the board
you get the information from the board
on there which is columns and rows
we want to know when a winner occurs uh
so if you get three in a row that's what
this whole section here is for
uh let me go ahead and scroll up a
little bit
and you can get a copy of this code if
you send a note over to
simplylearn we'll send you over this
particular file and you can play with it
yourself and see how it's put together
i don't want to spend a huge amount of
time on this
because this is just some real general
python coding
but you can see here we're just going
through all the rows
and you add them together and if it
equals three three in a row
same thing with columns diagonals so you
gotta check the diagonal that's what all
this stuff does here is it just goes
through the different areas actually let
me go ahead and put
there we go and then it comes down here
we
do our sum and it says true minus three
just says
did somebody win or is it a tie so you
gotta add up all the numbers on there
anyway just in case
they're all filled up and next we also
need to know available positions
these are ones that don't no one's ever
used before
this way when you try something or the
computer tries something
it's not going to give it an illegal
move that's what the available positions
is doing
then we want to update our state and so
you have your position going in
we're just sending in the position that
you just chose and you'll see there's a
little user interface we put in there we
can
pick the row and column in there
and again i mean this is a lot of code
uh so really it's kind of a thing you'd
want to go through and play with a
little bit and just
read through it get a copy of it a great
way to understand how this works
and here is a given reward
so we're going to give a reward result
equals self
winner this is one of the hearts of
what's going on here
is we have a result self.winner
so if there's a winner then we have a
result that the result equals one
here's our feedback if it doesn't equal
one
then it gets a zero so it only gets a
reward in this particular case
if it wins and that's important to know
because different systems of reinforced
learning
do rewarding a lot differently depending
on what you're trying to do this is a
very simple example
with a three by three board imagine if
you're playing a video game
certainly you only have so many actions
but your environment is
huge you have a lot going on in the
environment
and suddenly a reward system like this
is going to be just
it's going to have to change a little
bit it's going to have to have different
rewards and different setup
and there's all kinds of advanced ways
to do that as far as
weighing you add weights to it and so
they can add the weights up depending on
where the reward comes in so it might be
that you actually get a reward
in this case you get the reward at the
end of the game
and i'm spending just a little bit of
time on this because this is an
important thing to note
but there's different ways to add up
those rewards it might have like if you
take a certain path
the first reward is going to be weighed
a little bit less than the last reward
because the last reward is actually
winning the game or scoring or whatever
it is
so this reward system gets really
complicated in some of the more advanced
uh setups in this case though
you can see right here that they give a
a 0.1 and a 0.5 reward
just for getting picking the right value
and something that's actually valid
instead of picking an invalid value
so rewards again that's like key it's
huge how do you
feed the rewards back in then we have a
board reset
that's pretty straightforward it just
goes back and resets the board to the
beginning
because it's going to try out all these
different things while it's learning
it's going to
do it by trial and error so you have to
keep resetting it
and then of course there's the play we
want to go ahead and play
rounds equals 100 depends on what you
want to do on here
you can set this different you can
obviously set that to higher level
but this is just going to go through and
you'll see in here
that we have player 1 and player 2.
this is this is the computer playing
itself
one of the more powerful ways to learn
to play a game
or even learn something that isn't a
game is to have
two of these models that are basically
trying to beat each other
and so they always they keep finding
explore new things
this one works for this one so this one
tries new things
it beats this we've seen this in chess i
think with some big one where they had
the two players in chess with
reinforcement learning
it was one of the ways they trained one
of the top computer chess playing
algorithms
uh so this is just what this is it's
going to choose an action it's going to
try something
and the more it try stuff um the more
we're going to
record the hash we actually have a board
hash where they self get the hash
setup on here where it stores all the
information
and then once you get to a win one of
them wins it gets the reward
uh then we go back and reset and try
again and then
kind of the fun part we actually get
down here is we're going to play
with a human so we'll get a chance to
come in here and see what that looks
like
when you put your own information in and
then it just comes in here and does the
same thing it did above
it gives it a reward for its things or
sees if it wins or ties
looks at available positions all that
fun of fun stuff
and then finally we want to show the
board so it's going to print the board
out each time
really as an integration is not that
exciting what's exciting
uh in here is one looking at this reward
system whoops play one more up
the reward system is really the heart of
this how do you reward the different
setup and the other one is when it's
playing it's got to take an
action and so what it chooses for an
action is also
the heart of reinforcement learning how
do we choose that action
and those are really key to right now
where reinforcement learning is
in today's technology
is figuring this out how do we reward it
and how do we guess the next best action
so we have our
environment and you can see the
environment is we're going to be or the
state
which is kind of like what's going on
we're going to return the state
depending on what happens
and we want to go ahead and create our
agent in this place
our player so each one is let me go and
grab that until we look at a class
player
this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what
how is this player figuring out how to
maneuver around the board and then the
board of course returns a state
that it can look at and reward so we
want to take a look at this we have
name self state this is class player
when you say class player we're not
talking about a human player we're
talking about
just the computer players and this is
kind of interesting so remember i told
you depending on what you're doing
there's going to be
a decay gamma
explore rate these are what i'm talking
about is how do we
train it um as you try different moves
it gets to the end
the first move is important but it's not
as important as the last one
and so you could say that the last one
has the heaviest weight
and then as you as you get there the
first one let's see the first move gives
you
a five reward the second gives you a two
reward
and the third one gives you a 10 reward
because that's the final ending you got
it
the 10's gonna count more than the first
step
uh and here's our we're going to get the
board information coming in
and then choose an action this was the
second part that i was talking about
that was so important
so once you have your training going on
we have to do a little randomness and
you can see right here is our np
random uniform so it's picking out a
random number take a random action
this is going to just pick which row and
which column it is
um and so choosing the action this one
you can see we're just doing random
states
um choice length of positions action
position
and then it skips in there and takes a
look at the board
for p in positions it's actually storing
the different
boards each time you go through so it
has a record of what it did so it can
properly weigh the values
and this simply just depends a hash
state what's the last date
pinned it to the to our states on here
here's our feedback rewards the reward
comes in
and it's going to take a look at this
and say is it none
what is the reward and here is that
formula
remember i was telling you about up here
that was important because it has
decay gamma times the reward this is
where
as it goes through each step
and this is really important this is
this is kind of the heart of this
of what i was talking about earlier uh
you have step one
and this might have a reward of two you
have step
two i should probably should have done
abc this has a step three
uh step 4 and so on
until you get to step in and this might
have a reward of 10.
so reward a 10
we're going to add that but we're not
adding uh
let's say this one right here let's say
this reward here right before 10
was um let's say it's also 10 that just
makes the
math easy so we had 10 and 10.
we had 10 this is 10 and 10 in whatever
it is
but it's time it's 0.9 so instead of
putting a full 10 here
we only do 9 that's a 0.9
times 10.
and so this formula as far as the decay
times the reward
minus the cell state value it basically
adds in it says here's one
or here's two i'm sorry i should have
done this abc would have been easier
uh so the first move goes in here and it
puts two in here
uh then we have our self set up on here
you can see how this gets pretty
complicated in the math but this is
really the key is how do we
train our states and we want the
the final state the win to get the most
points if you win you get most points
and the first step gets the least amount
of points
so you're really training this almost in
reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now where's
need to sum up my rewards
and i want to sum them up going in
reverse and i want to find the answer in
reverse
kind of an interesting uh play on the
mind when you're trying to figure this
stuff out
and of course we want to go ahead and
reset the board down here
save the policy load policy
these are the different things that are
going in between the agent and the
state to figure out what's going on
let's go ahead and load that
up and then finally we want to go ahead
and create a human player
and the human player is going to be a
little different in that
you choose an action row and column
here's your action
uh if action is if action in positions
meaning positions that are available you
return the action
if not it just keeps asking you until
you get the action that actually works
and then we're going to go ahead and
append to the hash state which we don't
need to worry about because it returns
the action up here
and feed forward uh again this is
because
it's a human um at the end of the game
bat propagate and update state values
this part isn't being done because it's
not programming uh the model
the model is getting its own rewards so
we've gone ahead and loaded this
in here so here's all our pieces and the
first thing we want to do
is set up p1 player 1 p2
player 2 and then we're going to send
our players to our state
so now it has p1 p2 and it's going to
play
and it's going to play 50 000 rounds
now we can probably do a lot less than
this and it's not going to get the full
results in fact you know what
let's go ahead and just do five just to
play with it because i want to show you
something here
oops somewhere in there i forgot to load
something
there we go i must just forgot to run
this
run
oops forgot a reference there for the
board rows and columns three by three
there is actually in the state it
references that we just tack it on on
the end
it was supposed to be at the beginning
so now i've only set this up with
let's see where we go in here i've only
set this up to train
five times and the reason i did that
is we're going to
come in and actually play it and then
i'm going to change that and we can see
how it differs on there
there we go and then you make it through
a run and we're going to go ahead and
save the policy
so now we have our player 1 and our
player 2 policy
the way we set it up it has two separate
policies loaded up in there
and then we're going to come in here and
we're going to do uh player 1 is going
to be the computer
experience rate 0 load policy 1
human player human and we're going to go
ahead and play this
i remember i only went through it just
one round of training
in fact minimal training and so it puts
an x there
and i'm going to go ahead and do row 0
column 1. you can see this is very
basic on here and so i
put in my zero and then i'm going to go
zero block it zero
zero and you can see right here it let
me win
uh just like that i was able to win zero
two and whoo human wins
so i only trained it five times we're
going to run this again
and this time instead of five
let's do five thousand or fifty thousand
i think that's what the
guys in the back had and this takes a
while to train it
this is where reinforcement learning
really falls apart
look how simple this game is we're
talking about a three by three set of
columns
and so for me to train it on this
um i could do a q table which would take
which would go much quicker
you could build a quick q table with
almost all the different options on
there
and you would probably get a the same
result much quicker
we're just using this as an example so
when we look at
reinforcement learning you need to be
very careful
what you apply it to it sounds like a
good deal until you do like a large
neural network
where you're doing you set the neural
network to a learning increment of one
so every time it goes through it learns
and then you
do your actions you pick from the
learning setup
and you actually try actions on the
learning setup until you get what you
think is going to be the best action
so you actually feed what you think is
right back through the neural network
there's a whole
layer there which is really fun to play
with
and then it has an output well think of
all those processes
i mean that is just a huge amount of
work it's going to do
let's go ahead and skip ahead here give
it a moment it's going to take a
minute or two to go ahead and run
now to train it we went ahead and let it
run
and it took a while this this took i got
a pretty
powerful processor and it took about
five minutes plus to run it
and we'll go ahead and run our
player setup on here oops brought in the
last
whoops i brought in the last round so
give me just a moment to re
do the policy save there we go i forgot
to save the policy back in there
and then go ahead and run our player
again
so we've saved the policy then we want
to go ahead and load the policy for p1
as the computer and we can see the
computer's gone in the bottom right
corner
i'm going to go ahead and go 1-1 which
is the center
and it's gone right up the top and if
you ever played tic-tac-toe
you know the computer has me but we'll
go ahead and play it out
row zero column two
there it is and then it's gone here and
so i'm going to go ahead and go
row zero one two
no zero one there we go and column zero
that's where i want it oh and it says
okay you
your action there we go boom uh so you
can see here we've got a
didn't catch the win on this it said tie
kind of funny that didn't catch the win
on there
but if we play this a bunch of times
you'll find it's going to win more and
more
the more we train it the more the
reinforcement happens
this lengthy training process
is really the stopper on reinforcement
learning
as this changes reinforcement learning
will be one of the more powerful
packages evolving over the next decade
or two
in fact i would even go as far as to say
it is the most important
machine learning tool and artificial
intelligence tool out there
as it learns not only a simple tic tac
toe board
but we start learning environments and
the environment would be like in
language
if you're translating a language or
something from one language to the other
so much of it is lost if you don't know
the context it's in what the
environments it's in
and so being able to attach environment
and context and all those things
together
is going to require reinforcement
learning to do
so again if you want to get a copy of
the tic tac toe board it's kind of fun
to play with
uh run it you can test it out you can do
you know test it for different
values you can switch from p1 computer
where we loaded the policy 1 to load the
policy 2 and just see how it varies
there's all kinds of things you can do
on there
in this video we will learn the top job
roles that you can get
after becoming a data science
professional so what really is data
science
data science is the art of discovering
patterns and trends from vast volumes of
data
using modern analytical tools and
techniques it helps you draw meaningful
insights to make business decisions
as you can see on the screen data
science uses vast volumes of data which
is fed to a machine
that runs several algorithms to process
the data and finally derive insights
data science continues to evolve as one
of the most promising and in demand
career paths for skilled professionals
data science involves knowledge of
programming mathematics and algorithms
as well as domain expertise data science
is being used in almost every sector of
business these days
with companies generating vast volumes
of data on a regular basis
they want to make sense of this data so
now
let's look at the various applications
of data science
data science is transforming the
healthcare sector and is playing a
pivotal role in monitoring a patient's
health and deciding the necessary steps
to be taken
in order to prevent potential diseases
from taking place
the primary use of data science in the
health industry
is through medical imaging there are
various imaging techniques like x-ray
mri and ct scan all these techniques
visualize the inner parts of the human
body
data science is also used for drug
discovery and genomics
which is the study of sequencing and
analysis of genomes
retail sectors use data science to
analyze their customer data
and build sophisticated models to
understand the customer behavior
and find his or her sore points thereby
a customer tends to be easily influenced
by the tricks developed by the retailers
data science is widely used for
inventory management which refers to the
stalking goods
in order to use them in the time of
crisis
data science proves to be really
efficient in deciding the location to
set up a new store
merchandising has become an essential
part of retail business
the merchandising mechanisms go through
the data pick up the insights and form
the priority sets for the customers
taking into account seasonality
relevancy and trends
data science is mostly applied in the
marketing domain for profiling
search engine optimization customer
management responsiveness
and running real-time marketing
campaigns predictive analytics is used
in marketing to understand customers
behavior
cluster models collaborative filtering
and regression analysis
are applied to spot the correlation
patterns in the customer's behavior to
predict future tendencies in purchasing
data science is also used to qualify and
prioritize leads
bring the right product to the market
and for targeting new customers
data science in automotives isn't just
about self-driving cars
advancement in technologies can help
keep auto organizations competitive
by improving everything from research to
design manufacturing to marketing
processes
image recognition and anomaly detection
can quickly detect
and eliminate faulty parts before they
get into the vehicle manufacturing
workflow
root cause analysis predictive
maintenance and supply chain
optimization are done using data science
in the automobile sector
next we have fraud detection frauds
can happen in many forms and it affects
virtually every industry
it has become a billion dollar business
and it is increasing every year
the pwc global economic crime survey of
2018
found that half that is around 49
percent of the 7200 companies they
surveyed had experienced fraud
of some kind fraud regularly happens in
the banking and insurance sector
as well as in e-commerce data science
techniques and algorithms can help you
overcome these frauds
the last application is regarding
recommender systems
data science helps companies make better
decisions and recommender systems help
data scientists succeed in it
recommender systems are tools designed
for interacting with large and complex
information spaces
and privatizing items in these spaces
that are likely to be of interest to the
user
personalized recommendations are an
important part of many online e-commerce
applications like amazon.com
netflix and pandora now that we have
looked at the various applications of
data science
let's see the different job roles you
can get into after becoming a data
science professional
so the first job role we have is of a
data analyst
a data analyst is responsible to collect
process and perform analysis on large
data sets
they bring technical expertise to ensure
the quality and accuracy of that data
then process design and present it in
ways to help
people businesses and organizations make
better decisions
they also have to perform queries on the
databases from time to time
they should have technical expertise in
sql business intelligence and
programming languages such as java and
python
now coming to the salary a data analyst
in the united states earns around 62
453 dollars per annum while in india you
can expect to earn nearly 5 lakhs 21 000
rupees per annum
some of the companies hiring for data
analysts are electronic arts
microsoft bloomberg amazon accenture and
siemens
the second job role we have is of a
business analyst
business analysts are people who are
responsible for bridging the gap between
it and the business
using data analytics to assess processes
determine requirements and deliver data
driven recommendations
and reports to executives and
stakeholders
they create a detailed business analysis
outlining problems
opportunities and solutions for a
business a business analyst should have
good communication and problem solving
skills
also they need to know python r bi tools
sql and excel
now moving to their salaries a business
analyst earns
around 68 346 dollars per annum
in the united states while in india they
earn nearly 7 lakh rupees per annum
the companies that can help you start
your career as a business analyst at
dell
gen pact philips iqvia and honeywell to
name a few
next we have data engineer or data
architect
a data engineer or architect develops
constructs
tests and maintains architectures such
as databases and large-scale processing
systems
they discover opportunities for data
acquisition develop data set processes
for data modeling
data mining and production they also
recommend ways to improve data
reliability
efficiency and data quality they should
be well versed with big data analytics
hadoop scala data warehousing data
modeling
etl and linux operating systems
a data engineer earns around hundred and
three thousand dollars
in the united states while in india they
earn around eight lakhs eighty five
thousand rupees per annum
companies hiring for data engineers and
architects are fidelity investments
capgemini gen pact accenture
standard charter and hewlett packard
enterprise
at number 4 we have machine learning
engineer
a machine learning engineer uses
different algorithms and statistical
modeling
to make sense of vast volumes of data
they are also expected to perform eb
testing
build data pipelines and implement
common machine learning algorithms such
as regression
classification clustering etc they
should know programming
probability and statistics sql data
visualization and machine learning
coming to their salary a machine
learning engineer
earns around hundred and fourteen
thousand dollars per annum in the united
states while in india they can earn
around 8 lakh rupees per annum
some of the companies that can help you
excel in your career as a machine
learning engineer are apple
oracle cloudex lab rapido qualcomm
and amazon and finally we have the most
exciting job role in the field of data
science that is of a data scientist
a data scientist makes value out of data
they proactively fetch information from
various sources
and analyze it for better understanding
about how the business performs
and builds ai tools that automate
certain processes within the company
a data scientist understands the
challenges in business
and comes up with the best solutions
using modern tools and techniques
to analyze visualize and build
prediction models to make business
decisions
they need to have experience querying
databases and using statistical computer
languages
such as r python sql etc
they should have knowledge of advanced
statistical techniques and concepts such
as
regression properties of distributions
and statistical tests
as per current trends a data scientist
can earn around 113 000 dollars per
annum in the united states
while in india they can earn an average
of 10 lakhs 47 000 rupees
per annum companies hiring for data
scientists are amazon
ibm apple rakuten general electric
philips and google now let me repeat the
list once again
first we cover data analyst then
business analyst
followed by data engineer or architect
machine learning engineer and finally
data scientist so with that
we have covered the top five job roles
in data science
apart from these job roles you can also
become a statistician
a database administrator an analytics
consultant
and business intelligence professional
let's go ahead and take a look
at building a resume always exciting
putting ourselves out selling ourselves
and if you looked at some of our other
videos dealing with
resumes you'll see a trend here uh the
top part
is so different than what resumes were
in the 90s
uh in the 2000 to 2010
they've evolved they've really evolved
it used to be
2000 2010 maybe linkedin
maybe one other reference now you're
going to see that we want those
references
this is a sales tactic which now has
come into resumes
used to be that if you're a real estate
agent every real estate agent i knew i
used to deal with real estate software
for the real estate industry back in the
90s every real estate agent won their
picture
on their business card they wanted them
their picture if they could
put on their contracts they want people
to see the face
so that's really a big change is to make
sure that it stands out you stand out
here's a picture of somebody so you're
more than just a couple letters
and a name but of course you need your
contact information should always be at
the top uh you have your summary
what are you focusing on be a little
careful with your summary because if you
have everything in your summary and then
they scroll down to experience and
education and skills
they're gonna stop the second you repeat
yourself in your resume
that usually means to the reader hey
this person doesn't have anything more
to offer me i'm done
so be a little careful how you word your
summary most
companies appreciate when you come in
here
and you've adjusted this summary to be
both about you
and how you're going to serve that
company so it's worth researching
that company to find out how those
connect and
put that in the summary take some time
to do that that's actually a pretty big
deal and the references are huge also
especially
in data science when you're talking
about any of the programming or data
science data analytics
having a place to go where they can look
it up and scroll down and see different
things you're doing whether it's
linkedin in this case which is the
business profile most commonly used
github where you have stuff published
facebook i'm always hesitant because
that tends to push more
towards uh social media type jobs and
other jobs
but certainly there's people who have
facebook who do marketing and stuff like
that but these links
having these basic links here is
important uh people are starting to look
for that for
some other uh setup maybe you have a
personal website
this is a good place to put that so that
they now have a multitude of links
that go back to you and highlight who
you are
and then the next part or next four
parts so for the next four parts
we have a combination of experience
education
skills certifications and you can see
they're organized
if you have you know a lot of people
like to see what kind of degree you have
they want to know where it came from
and if you just got out of college
you're going to put education at the top
and then maybe you'll put skills after
that and then your experience at the
bottom
if you've been in the field for years
you know my degree just to give you my
age goes back to the nine
early 90s so i usually put education at
the very bottom
and then because a lot of the stuff i'm
trying to sell myself on right now
is my skills i actually put that at the
top and i'll put my education my
certifications at the bottom my skills
and then my experience is since it's a
huge part of my resume
goes next you can organize these in
whatever order you want that's going to
work best for you
and sell you so remember you're selling
yourself this is your image
probably don't wear um an old tie-dye
t-shirt with holes in it
you know something nice because it is
professional and of course your summary
your and then what do you have to offer
the company and again
when i put out resumes and i haven't
done a resume in a while you go in there
and you can take this and reorganize
this so if the company's looking for
something specific
you might put the experiences specific
to that company
you might even take experience if you
have like a long job history like i do
i've gone into a lot of different things
you might leave out those companies or
those experiences that had nothing to do
with data science
because it just becomes overwhelming
resume should only take about
30 seconds to glance over maybe a minute
tops
because after that point you've lost the
person's interest and if they want to
dig deeper they now have links they have
your website they have linkedin
and they can now take this and they come
back to it and they go okay let's look
at this person a little closer
so quick overview this is your sell
sheet selling you
to the company so always tie it to the
company so that
you have that what am i going to give
this company what are they going to get
from me
welcome to data science interview
questions before we dive in and start
going through the questions one at a
time
we're going to start with some of the
logical kind of concept that's enters in
a lot of interviews
in this one you have two buckets one of
three leaders and the other five leaders
you're expected to measure exactly
four leaders how will you complete the
task
and no you only have the two buckets you
don't have a third bucket or anything
like that just the two buckets
and the object of the question like this
is to see how well you are
thinking outside the box in this case
you're in a larger box you have two
buckets and also the
pattern which you go on and what that
means is if you look at the two buckets
and we'll show you their answer in just
a second you have a bucket with three
liters and a bucket with five liters
and the first thought is what happens if
you go from left to right
so we have a direction and what happens
if you pour the three liters
into the five liter bucket well if you
pour the three liters into five liter
bucket you have an empty bucket of three
liters and what's really important here
is
i was thinking outside the box you
realize that you have a five-liter
bucket that has three liters in it and
two empty leaders so you have two
additional leaders you can fill up
if we continue that process we can pour
from the left to right from the small
bucket to the large bucket you can now
measure
in two additional liters into the five
liter bucket
and three minus two is one and you can
keep doing that you can empty the five
liter bucket in
pour those three liters in that one
liter in and then you can pour three
liters in what's cool about these
questions
is you explore them as you realize
there's multiple ways usually to solve
i went from small bucket to big bucket
the simply learned team their solution
that they pulled out was you fill the
five liter bucket and empty it into the
three liter bucket
now you're left with two liters in the
five liter bucket so that's great we can
empty the three liter bucket so now
we're going from large to small remember
we went from small to large
so you can go both either way but you
have to go one way or the other it turns
out and you can empty the three
liter bucket and pour the contents of
the five liter bucket in it
so the three liter bucket now has two
liters and if it has two liters that
means it has an empty one liter and by
now you probably have guessed
that if you have an empty space you can
start using that empty space of one
liter as a measuring so we fill the five
liter bucket again
and we pour the water in the three liter
bucket it already has the two liters
and so we're only pouring one liter in
there and five minus one is
four so interview questions they break
up into all kinds of different patterns
we have logic like this one which is a
lot of fun
we have questions that come up that are
more vocabulary lists the difference
between supervised and
unsupervised learning probably one of
the fundamental breakdowns
in data science and supervised learning
uses known and labeled data as input
supervised
learning has a feedback mechanism most
commonly used supervised learning
algorithms are decision tree
logistic regression support vector
machine and you should know that those
are
probably the most common used right now
and there certainly are so many coming
out so that's a very evolving thing and
be aware of a lot of the different
algorithms that are out there outside of
the deep learning because a lot of these
work faster on raw data numbers
than they do than a deep neural network
would unsupervised learning uses
unlabeled data as input
unsupervised learning has no feedback
mechanism
most commonly used unsupervised learning
algorithms are
k-means clustering hierarchical
clustering the appropriate
algorithm and there certainly are more
i'm going to say k-means
definitely is at the top of the list in
the hierarchical clustering
those two are used so many times so
really important to understand what
those are and how they're used
and most important is understand that
supervised learning is you have
your data set where you have training
data and you have
all those different pieces moving around
but you you're able to train it you know
the answers
and unsupervised we're just grouping
things together that look like they go
together
how is logistic regression done logistic
regression
measures the relationship between the
dependent variable our label
what we want to predict and the one or
more independent variables are features
by estimating probability using its
underlying logistic function
sigmoid and whenever i draw these charts
i always end up drawing them the right
hand side first because you want to know
what your output is what is you want out
of here
and the left hand side what do you have
going in so you have your in and out
you can see we have a nice labeled image
here to help you remember this
we have our inputs we have our linear
model we have our probabilities what are
the probabilities
of it being a certain way based on these
features coming in
the sigmoid function and it's important
to note that the sigmoid function
is maybe the most commonly used but it's
only one of a number of functions that
are out there
and the sigmoid function turns our
probabilities into a value between 0 and
1
or very close to 0 and very close to 1
between 0.1 and 0.009
and based on that we generate an answer
in this case a 0 or 1.
how is logistic regression done so last
time we talked about the sigmoid
function
generally depending on what your
interview and level of math and what
expertise you're going in for the market
you'll have to understand that formula
of the probability equals 1
over 1 plus e to the negative y and
that's e to the base 2.
so you have your probability function or
your sigmoid function which pushes it
as you can see we have a nice visual of
that that helps a lot to have that
visual
on the sigmoid function you definitely
should know your y equals m
times x plus c your base euclidean
geometry of forming a line
in the slope plus the intercept the
y-intercept
and then you have your natural log and
the natural log
is to the e as opposed to a base 2 or
base 10
so your natural log to the e of the
probability over 1 minus a probability
equals your
m times x plus c or your euclidean line
that helps a lot as far as the graphing
and understanding the sigmoid function
so we'll just keep pushing on to
question number three explain the steps
in making
a decision tree and i noticed last time
we brought up the decision tree in the
forest a lot
of questions came up what is the
difference so let's go through that when
you make a decision tree you're going to
take the entire
data set as input you're going to
calculate entropy of the target variable
as well as the predictor attributes i
remembered entropy is just how chaotic
is it
so if you have like you know banana and
grapes and oranges if you're mixing in
fruit and that's your data coming in
you have all these different objects
that are so separate from each other and
the more they become
uniform the lower the entropy and we
call that information gain so we gain
information on sorting different objects
from each other so you have your entropy
you have to calculate your information
gain of all attributes
and then you choose the attribute with
the highest information gain as the root
node so if you can separate your group
and each
group chaos and each group is lowered
whichever split lowers the chaos the
most that's where you split it and
that's your root node at that point you
repeat the same procedure on every
branch till the decision node of each
branch
finalized so understanding that setup is
pretty important
as far as decision trees and you can see
here we have a nice visual of decision
tree for example if you want to build a
decision tree to decide whether we
should accept or decline a job offer
since these are interview questions
that's a good one to ask
and just as a tip you should be pretty
aware of the formula for entropy
and information gain so you need to look
those up if you don't remember those
and the salary if it's greater than 50
000 no decline the offer yes
it's got a good salary the commute is
greater than an hour
yes decline the offer no offers
incentives
yes except the offer no incentives
decline the offer
so we use decision tree pretty much for
everything if you want
and if you have a decision tree then you
also should understand how do you build
a random forest model
and remember that a random forest is
built up of a
number of decision trees so if you split
your data up into a lot of different
packages
and you do a decision tree in each of
those different groups of data the
random forest is bringing all those
trees together
so how do you build a random forest
model randomly select
k features from a total of m features
where k
is less than m among the k features
calculate the node d
using the best split point split the
node into daughter nodes using the best
split repeat steps two and three steps
until leaf nodes are finalized
build force by repeating steps one to
four for n number times to create n
number of
trees so you can see it's got the same
build pattern as the tree
but instead you're building a number of
different trees little small trees so it
all have an end leaf node
random forest has a vote at the end and
whoever gets the most votes wins
that's the answer how can you avoid
overfitting of your model
very important question in any kind of
mathematical scientific
data science setup in any of them there
are three main methods to avoid
overfitting and you should really
understand overfitting overfitting means
that your model is only set for a very
small amount of data
and ignores the bigger picture keep the
model simple
take into account fewer variables
thereby removing
some of the noise and the training data
good advice for any programming at all
use cross-validation techniques such as
k-folds cross-validation
use regularization techniques such as
lasso that penalize certain model
parameters if they're likely to cause
overfitting
and you should also be well aware that
your cross validation techniques that's
like a pre
data or your lasso and your
regularization techniques are usually
during the process so when you're
prepping your data that's when you're
gonna do a cross validation such as like
splitting your data into three groups
and you train it on two groups and test
it on one and then switch which two
groups you tested on that kind of thing
so can you solve another one of these i
love these things
there are nine balls out of which one
ball is heavy
in weight and the rest are of the same
weight
and how many minimum weighings will you
find the heavier ball
and when we say weighing think of a
scale where you can put
objects on one side and the other and
you can see which side is heavier
and you want to minimize that you want
to split the balls up in such a way that
you're going to do as
few measurements as you can you will
need to perform two wangs
so you can get it down to just two wings
and i always think if there's nine balls
and divide them into
three groups of three place three balls
on each side so you can just randomly
pick
six of the balls and three on one side
three on the other and if they balance
out both sides are equal then you know
the heavy weight isn't in any of those
so out of the remaining three balls from
step one take
two balls and place one ball on each
side
a little tricky there because i always
want to put all three i want to put two
on one side and one on the other but no
just take
randomly pick two of those put one on
each side if they balance out then the
left
out ball the one you didn't measure will
be the heavier one otherwise you'll see
it in the balance you'll see which one's
heavier because it'll take one of the
balls down now we go to scenario b
where they did not balance out so now we
know which side has a heavier ball in it
and it's just very similar to what we
did before if the balls in step one do
not balance out
then take those three balls that have
the heavier side on them and reproduce
step two to find out the heavier ball
difference between univariate bivariate
and multivariate analysis and hopefully
if you know a little latin you'll kick
in there that you have uni and you have
bi and you have multi because the answer
is in the words themselves
so the first one this type of data
contains only one
variable so that's see univariate
purpose of the univariate analysis is to
describe the data and find patterns that
exist within it so when you only see one
one variable coming in in this case
we're using height of students
you're limited as far as what you can do
with that data so you can come up and
draw different patterns and conclusions
from those patterns using the means the
median the mode
dispersion range minimum maximum so
we're
describing the data so all those words
would describe the data and that's about
all you can do with
data like that there's no correlation
there's nothing to go beyond that as far
as guessing or predicting anything
so we move into bivariate you know uni
means one
by means two bivariate this type of data
involves two different variables
the analysis of this type of data deals
with causes and relationships and the
analysis is done to find out the
relationship among the two variables
and this is always a favorite one
because everybody loves ice cream in the
summer when it's hot and very few people
go for ice cream in the winter when it's
really cold so it's easy to see the
correlation in the data the temperature
and ice cream cells in summer season
and you can see here where the
temperature goes from 20 to 35
and as the temperature goes up so does
the sales of ice cream it goes from
2 000 i'm not sure 2 thousand what's i'm
guessing it's a very large
chain because if they're selling two
thousand ice cream cones and they have a
lot of business good for them
a little vendor on the corner selling
two thousand ice cream cones a day and
thirty one hundred the next day
here the relationship is visible from
the table that temperature in cells are
directly proportional to each other so
the hotter the temperature we can
predict an increase in cells
so the word prediction should come up so
we have description and prediction when
the data involves three or more
variables it is categorized under
multivariate it is similar to bivariate
but contains more than one dependent
variable
in this example another really common
one the data for house price prediction
the patterns can be studied by drawing
conclusions using mean median and mode
dispersion or range minimum maximum etc
and so you can start describing the data
that's what all that was
and then using that description to guess
what the price is going to be so this is
very good if you're in the market and
you
have already looked at the area and you
already know that a two bedroom
zero floor 900 square foot house is
usually runs about 40 000
you can guess what the next one that
looks similar to it is and i'll just
throw in another word in there
i don't see very often unless you're
really a hardcore data science
we talked about describing the data
descriptive we talked about predictive
and there's also postscriptive
postscriptive means we're going to
change
the variables to try to guess what the
outcome is if we change what's going on
so that would be the next step but that
usually doesn't show up unless you're
dealing with some really
hardcore data science groups what are
the feature selection methods
to select the right variables there are
two main methods for feature selection
there's
filter methods and wrapper methods and
when you're filtering your
before we discuss the two methods real
quick the best analogy
for uh selecting features is bad
data in bad answer out so when we're
limiting or selecting our features it's
all about cleaning up the data coming in
so it's cleaner and is more
representative of what we're trying to
predict
filter method filter methods as they
come in we have linear discrimination
analysis
anova chi squared chi square is probably
the most common one
and these are all part of pre-processing
we're taking out all the
outliers all the things that have a
difference that is very different from
the data we're looking at the odd ones
and sometimes you take the odd ones out
and then you analyze them separately to
see why they're odd but remember your
filter methods you want to pull all that
weird stuff
out wrapper methods on the other hand
are
forward selection backward selection
recursive
feature elimination and one of the most
important things to remember about
wrapper methods is they're very
labor-intensive
you have to have some pretty high-end
computers if you're doing a lot of data
analysis with the wrapper method
and um just quickly forward selection
means you
have all your different features they're
off to the side and we test just one
feature at a time we keep adding them in
until we get a good fit
backward as we have all the features and
we start we run a test on that to see
how well it does and then we start
removing features to see what works
and recursive which is the most
processing hungry
algorithm out there goes through and
just recursively looks through all the
different features and how they pair
together
but again we have filter method and
wrapper method and it's important to
understand that we're
sorting the data out and finding out
which features are going to represent
the data the best and which ones are not
going to really add any value to
our models let's jump number eight in
your choice of language
write a program that prints the numbers
from one to fifty but for multiples of
three print fizz
instead of the number and for the
multiples of five print abuzz
for numbers which are multiples of both
three and five
print fizz buzz and this really is
testing
your knowledge and iterating over data
very important my sister who runs
at the university the data science team
is in charge of their department
it's the first question she asks in her
interview of anybody who comes in
is how do they iterate through data
so if this question comes up a lot and
it's very important you have an
understanding
and there's actually a slight error on
this code which i'll point out in just a
second
the concept is we have fizz buzz in
range and you have range 51
which in this case goes from 0 to 51 and
i'm gonna
challenge you to see if you can catch
the error and i'll tell you at the end
of the code where the error is
what that means is that we're going to
go through all the numbers 0 1 2 3 4 and
we're going to process through this loop
if the remainder of fizzbuzz divided by
3 equals 0 and fizzbuzz
divided by 5 also equals 0 then print
fizzbuzz continue and elseif fizzbuzz
divided by three equals zero
then print fizz print fizz continue else
if
is buzz divided by five equals zero
print buzz continue and print
fizzbuzz you fit the print the answer in
this case
fizzbuzz is either gonna be the number
we generated which is 0
or it'll be the fizz buzz fizz or buzz
that's a mouthful now if you didn't
catch the error in the code
which is always a fun game find the
error it has to do with the range
and it's important to remember the range
here says range to 51 that's 0
to 51 which is is correct we want to go
to 51 because it stops
it gets to 50 and it stops so that's 0
to 50. but if you remember the question
asked from
1 to 50. so the range should be one
comma
51 not just 51 which does 0 to 51.
in this particular script in python you
can leave out the continue
but the continue in the script skips the
next lcf so it doesn't keep processing
it going down and in programming
a lot of scripts you don't need the
continuance this would depend on what
script you chose and there's probably
some other ways to do this it's a lot of
fun
and you can see here from the output we
end up with fizz buzz for zero
which shouldn't be there one two fizz
four buzz fizz seven eight
fizzbuzz eleven fizz and so on sounds
like a
drinking game from my college days so
long ago many decades ago
you are given a data set consisting of
variables having more than thirty
percent
missing values how will you deal with
them oh the
joy of messy data coming in ways to
handle missing data values
data set is huge we can just simply
remove the rows with missing data values
there's the quickest way
i.e we use the rest of the data to
predict the values you just go in there
and say any row
of our data that has a n a in it get rid
of it that doesn't work with smaller
data
so a smaller data you start running into
problems because you lose a lot of data
and so we can substitute missing values
with the mean or average of the rest of
the data using pandas data
frame and python there's different ways
to do this obviously in different
languages and even in
python there's different ways to do this
but in python it's real easy you can do
the df.mean
so you get the mean value so if you set
mean equal to that then you can do a
df.fill in a
with the mean value very easy to do in a
python panda script
and if you're using python you should
really know pandas and numpy
number python and pandas data frames for
the given points
how will you calculate the euclidean
distance in
python so back to our basic algebra from
high school
euclidean distance is the line on the
triangle
and so if we're given the points plot
one equals one comma three
plot two equals two comma five we know
that from this
we can take the difference of each one
of those points
square them and then take the square
root of everything so the euclidean
distance equals the square root of
plot 1 0 minus plot 2 of 0 squared plus
plus one of one minus plot two of one
squared mouthful there and you can
remember if you have multiple dimensions
that go past two dimensions you could
have plot three
can simply be the distance from plot one
you only need to do one side of that
or plot two you can do either way and
square that and take the square root
of that another mind bender how to
calculate some how to figure out the
solution to something
what is the angle between the hour and
minute hands
of a clock when the time is halfed past
six so you want to kind of imagine that
clock where the
large hand is pointed down to the 30 and
the other half
is gonna be right between the six and
the seven because it's half past six
there's actually a couple ways to solve
this but let's take a look and see how
they did it
note a clock is a complete circle having
360 degrees
in one hour the hour hand covers 360
over 12 so it equals 30 degrees for each
hour
in one minute the minute hand covers 360
degrees over 60 minutes
or 6 degrees per minute the minute hand
has traveled for 30 minutes
so it has covered 30 times 6 which
equals 180 degrees
so we know that's 180 degrees from the
12. the hour hand is traveled
for six point five hours six and a half
six point five so it's covered six point
five times thirty which equals 195
degrees
the difference between the two will give
the angle between the two hands
thus the required angle equals 195 minus
180 equals 15
degrees and this is nice the way they
solved it because you can now punch in
any kind of time within reason the hard
part is on the hours
is you have to be able to convert the
hours into decimals explain
dimensionality
reduction and list its benefits
dimension reduction refers to the
process of converting a set of data
having vast dimensions
into data with lesser dimensions fills
to convey
similar information concisely it helps
in data compressing and reducing the
storage space
it reduces computation time as less
dimensions lead to less computing it
removes redundant features for example
there's no point in storing a value in
two different
units meters and inches and i certainly
rented a lot with this with
text analysis i've been known to run a
text analysis over a series of documents
ends up with over
1.4 million different features that's a
lot of different words being used
and if you do what they call a buy
connect them you connect two words
together
now you're up to 4.8 million different
features
and you start having to figure ways to
bring that down what can we get rid of
that kind of thing so you can see where
that can get really high in on
processing and learning how to reduce
the list
dimensions is very important how will
you calculate
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of a three
by three
matrix and what they're really looking
for here is when you write it out
for the eigen is that you know that
you're going to use the lambda that's
the most common one obviously you can
use any symbol you want but lambda is
usually what they use and that you do it
down the middle diagonal and so when you
take that matrix and you
take the characteristic equation you end
up with the determinant
and that's the minus 2 minus lambda
minus four two
minus two one minus lambda two four two
five minus lambda and that's what
they're looking for and you know that's
equal to zero so when you're doing a
matrix in the eigen set up with the
eigenvectors
that's all going to come out equal to 0
and then you can go ahead and write the
whole equation out so we can expand the
determinant
as you can see right here the minus 2
minus lambda times
it's a mouthful i'll leave it up here
for a second so you can look at it when
you
break it down into the algebraic
functions you end up with
minus lambda cubed plus 4 lambda squared
plus 27 lambda minus
90 equals 0. so now we have a nice
algebraic
equation built from the eigenvectors
and always remember you can hit the
pause button and you can also send a
note send a note to
simply learn if you have more questions
on vectors or on this definitely have
that
resource available to you um or post
down in below
on the youtube video comments and so
when we calculate the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of a three by three matrix
as we continue on down the math of this
and to be honest i really don't like
working with matrixes like this
it's important to understand the math
behind it and it's important to know the
code
just enough so that you're not lost when
someone's explaining it or it comes up
when i'm working on different data
science models
of course if you're dealing with the
high-end math side of it then you better
know this
first is by hitting trial so you try in
different variables to solve for zero
and you can come in here and you'll find
that if we put in the three in there
we end up with a zero at the end and
substitute the three
hence we end up with lambda minus three
as one of the factors
and you can do the math going out on
that where we have lambda cubed minus
four lambda squared minus 27 lambda plus
90
equals lambda minus 3 times lambda
squared minus lambda minus 30.
so eigenvalues based on that one are 3
minus 5
and 6. and then from there we can
calculate the eigenvector
for lambda equals three and you can see
here where the matrix as we
write it out is the minus five minus
four two minus two minus two minus two
four two two that's from the beginning
put in the x y and z
equals zero zero zero and so when we put
in those numbers and we calculate
them out we have for x equals one we
have the
minus five minus four y plus two z
equals zero
minus two minus two y plus two z equals
zero and subtracting the two equations
we just had
we get three plus two y equals zero y
equals minus three over two and z
equals minus one over two that's going
back to the first equation and similarly
we can calculate the eigenvectors for
minus five
and six how should you maintain your
deployed
model oh distribution time my favorite i
spent
10 years in software distribution so
first thing and this is true not just of
your data science model but of any
computer code going out there this
basic setup can work although usually
there's a little added steps in there
first we're going to monitor
it so we have a constant monitoring of
all the model is needed to determine
the performance accuracy of the models
so yeah we want to just keep an eye on
it we want to make sure they're accurate
we want to make sure that whatever
they're
supposed to predict or i threw in that
bonus word
post script where you change something
and you want to figure out how your
changes are going to affect things we
need to monitor it and make sure it's
doing what it's supposed to do
evaluation metrics of the current model
is calculated to determine
if new algorithm is needed and then we
compare it the new
models are compared against each other
to determine which model performs the
best
and then we do a rebuild the best
performing model is rebuilt on the
current state of data
this is interesting i found this out
just recently if you're in weather
prediction
the really big weather areas have about
seven or eight
different models depending on what's
going on and so you actually have almost
a
little force going on there where
they're like which model is going to fit
best and this is what we're going to use
to predict the weather with
so not only do you don't necessarily get
rid of the models but you figure out
which
models fit data of what's going on or
the current state of data
what are recommender systems most
commonly used nowadays in marketing
so very big industry understanding
recommender systems
predicts the rating or preference a user
would give to a product
and they they're split into two
different areas one is collaborative
filtering and a good example of that is
the last.fm
recommends tracks that are often played
by other users
with similar interests so people who if
you're on amazon
people who bought this also bought that
this got me a few times
and then there's contact based filtering
and we're looking at content instead of
looking at who else is listening to the
music
leave the example pandora which uses the
properties of a song
to recommend music with similar
properties so you have collaborative
filtering and content based filtering
how to find rmse and msc in linear
regression
model hopefully you remember what the
two acronyms mean because that is like
half the answer
we have the root mean square error and
the mean square
error in linear regression model so
we're looking for error
the rmse and the msc are the two of the
most common measures of accuracy for a
linear regression model and you can see
here we have the root mean square error
rmse equals and this is the square root
of
the sum of the predicted minus the
actual
squared over the total number so we're
just looking for the
average mean so we're looking for the
average over the end and
the reason you need to know about the
difference between rmse versus msc
is when you're doing a lot of these
models and you're building your own
model why do you need to take the square
root of it
it doesn't change the value as far as
the way you're using it because you're
looking as to see whether the error is
greater or less than
so why add that extra computation in so
a lot of models use the
msc which indicates the mean square
error or the average
error and it's the same formula minus
the square root at the end
or across the whole thing another riddle
to solve
if it rains on saturday with a
probability of 0.6
and it rains on sunday with a
probability 0.2
what is the probability that it rains
this weekend
and the trick in probabilities on this
case is we're not we need to know
what is the probability of it not
raining what's it not what's the chance
of it not raining
on saturday and if it doesn't rain on
saturday we want to take that and
combine that with the chance of it not
raining on sunday
the total probability which in this case
we're just going to use 1
minus the probability that it will not
rain on saturday so it's 1 minus 0.6
we're going to take that as a union
which we simply just multiply them
together
of the probability they will not rain on
sunday
and it's important to recognize the
union here or the
and you can see by the formula down here
we end up with 0.68 or
68 chance that it will rain on the
weekend and
there are a couple other ways to solve
this but this is probably the most
traditional way of doing that
how can you select k for k means so
first you better understand that what k
means is and that k
is the number of different groupings and
most commonly we use is the elbow method
to select k for k means the idea of the
elbow method is to run k-means
clustering on the data set where k is
the number of clusters
within the sum of squares wss is defined
as the sum of the square distance
between
each member of the cluster and its
centroid and you should know all the
terms for your
k means on there and with the elbow
point and again here's our iteration in
our code we talked about that earlier
you iterate starting with um usually you
don't start right at one but
you just might start with two three or
four and you just see where it comes out
and you can see the nice elbow there
which is easy to see graphically where
the
number of k clusters and the wss value
drops
and then it just kind of flattens out
and there's no reason to take the k
means any further
what is the significance of p-value oh
good one especially if you're dealing
with r because that's the first thing
that pops up
p-value typically less than or equal to
0.05
indicates a strong evidence against the
null hypothesis
and you should know what a difference
why we use null hypothesis instead of
the hypothesis so you reject the null
hypothesis
very important that term null hypothesis
in any scientific
setup and also in data science it
doesn't mean that it's true
it means that there's a high correlation
that it's true
so if your null hypothesis means it's
not true your hypothesis
is has a high correlation that it's
probably true and if the p-value
is typically greater than 0.05 it
indicates a weak evidence against the
null hypothesis
so you fail to reject the whole null
hypothesis and if you reject that then
your
actual hypothesis is probably not true
the correlation of your data with what
you think it's saying is is probably
incorrect
and if you're right at the cutoff of
0.05 it's considered to be marginal
could go either way and again you can
use that p value
on different features to decide whether
you're going to include your features
as far as something worth exploring in
your data science model
how can outlier values be treated oh
good one
you can drop outliers only if it is a
garbage value
so sometimes you end up with like one
outlier that just is probably someone's
measurement sway off
height of an adult equals abc feet this
cannot be true as height cannot be a
string value
in this case outliers can be removed if
the outliers have extreme values they
can be removed
for example if all the data points are
clustered between 0 to 10
but one point lies at 100 then we can
remove this point
and again sometimes you just look for
the outlier so you can see what's going
on if there's something unusual there so
maybe the equipment's not calibrated
correctly
if you cannot drop outliers you can try
the following
try a different model data detected as
outliers by linear model can be fit by
non-linear model
so we be sure you are choosing the right
model
so if it has like more of a curved look
to it instead of a straight line you
might need to use something other than
just a straight line linear model
try normalizing the data this way the
extreme data points are pulled to a
similar range
if you can use algorithms which are less
affected by outliers example random
forest
so there is another solution is you can
come up with the random force which a
lot of times completely
bypasses your outliers how can you say
that a time
series data is stationary oh that's an
interesting term stationary meaning it's
not moving but it's a time series
we can say that a time series is
stationary when the variance and
mean of the series is constant with time
and this graphic example is very easy to
see we have our
the variance is constant with time so we
have our first variable y and x
and x being the time factor and y being
the variable
as you can see goes through the same
values all the time it's not
changing in the long period of time so
that's stationary and then you can see
in the second example the waves get
bigger and bigger
so that's non-stationary here the
variance is changing with time
again we have y which stays constant so
that if you look at the bigger picture
it's the same wave over and over again
and then of course we have uh where
the wave is growing in size going up
it can also go down so it'd also be
non-stationary how can you calculate
accuracy using confusion matrix
oh great one confusion matrixes are so
useful
when you're taking that first look at
data and also when you're showing the
shareholders
and you want to ask them for money how
can you calculate accuracy using
confusion matrix
so you have your total data that we're
looking at is 650
and you have your predicted values and
your actual values and you have your
predicted p
and your actual p and so we look at this
you'll note that if the
predicted p and the actual p are 262
but our predicted p also had 15 that
weren't
correct so you can see there's a false
positive there of 15
and the same thing with the n you can
see where n predicts n and it has a
false negative of 26 out of the
total number of n values in there and so
we can do an accuracy on there
the true positive plus the true negative
is our total observations
so you have a total of 0.93 accuracy or
93 percent
and just a quick note on this this is so
important because it's one thing if
someone is being diagnosed with
uh say cancer you know this is life
death or is my nuclear reactor going to
blow up
suddenly if the p is the probability of
it blowing up
and this can say you have 15 that's a
lot less than
say the 26 chances of it blowing up you
know
so the actual domain of your data is
very important
so if you're non-positive you don't
really care about the predicted value
having non-positive as positive because
they're going to do a biopsy on the
cancer or whatever anyway but you're
very interested if you have a positive
an actual positive value which is looked
at as negative
a false negative that's really important
in that domain depending on what domain
you're in
write the equation and calculate
precision and recall rate
and so continuing with our confusion
matrix
i was just talking about the different
domains we have the precision
equals 262 over 277 so your precision is
the true positive
over the true positive plus false
positive and the recall rate is your
true positive over the total positive
plus false negative and you can see here
we have that 262 over
277 equals a 94 percent and the
recall over here is the 262 over 280
which equals 9.9 or 90 percent and oh
good we're going to take a pause for
another brain teaser
if a drawer contains 12 red socks
16 blue socks and 20 white socks
how many must pull out to be sure of
having a matching
pair the last time i went through these
kind of brain teaser
things was like 20 years ago and i had
six people sitting across the table
waiting for my answer that's kind of
mind-numbing when you're in an interview
like that hopefully
you're not stuck in an interview like
that but uh on this
you need to ask yourself how many
different colors of socks
are there so they've thrown a lot of
extra data in here
that you don't need to solve the answer
the answer is four
an example your first pick is white your
second pick is red
third pick is blue so no pairs yet and
that means when you get to the fourth
pick
there's a hundred percent chance you're
going to have a match so the most is
going to be four that you ever have to
pull out of your drawer if it was four
colors
the answer would be five and so on it
doesn't matter how many white socks you
have or how many red socks or blue socks
different pairs you have it's the
different colors a number of different
colors
people who bought this also bought
recommendations seen on amazon
as a result of which algorithm we
covered this earlier
recommendation engine is done with
collaborative
filtering collaborative filtering
exploits the behavior of other users in
their purchase history
in terms of ratings selection etc it
makes predictions on what you might
interest a person based on the
preference of many other users
and this algorithm features of the items
are not known
and we have a nice example here where
they took a snapshot of a cells
page it says for example suppose x
number of people buy a
new phone and then also buy tempered
glass with it
next time when a person buys a phone
he'll be recommended to buy tempered
glass along with it
and if you remember the vocabulary words
we covered earlier this is the
recommendation this is collaborative the
other word was
content based so looking at things with
similar content versus collaborative
which is similar people
remember you know you're not going to
know every vocabulary word but it also
doesn't hurt to get your three by five
cards out and make yourself a vocabulary
stack of cards
buy an app on your phone for it sql
query i remember back in the
90s it was so important to know sql
query and only a few people
got it nowadays it's just part of your
kit you have to know some basic sql so
write a basic sql query to list all
orders
with customer information and you can
kind of make up your own name for the
database
and you can pause it here if you want to
write that down on a paper and let's go
ahead and look at this we have
to list all orders with customer
information and so usually you have an
order table and a customer table and you
have an order id
a customer id order number total amount
and then from your customer table you
have id
first name last name city county and so
if we're going to write in sql with this
we're going to
select keyword there for sql selecting
order number
total amount first name last name city
country so that's the columns we're
going to look at
we're going to do that from our order
where we're going to join it with our
customer and we're going to join it on
the order customer id
equals the customer id so very basic sql
query that's going to return
a table of data for us you are given a
data set on
cancer detection you built a
classification model and achieved an
accuracy of 96 percent whoo
96 why shouldn't you be happy with your
model performance
what can you do about it that's an
interesting one because this comes up
that's one of the standard data sets on
there is for
cancer detection cancer detection
results in imbalanced
data in an imbalanced data set accuracy
should not be based
as a measure of performance because it
is important to focus on the remaining
four percent which are the people who
are wrongly diagnosed
we talked a little bit about this
earlier you have to know your domain you
know this is the medical
cancer domain versus weather domain you
know whether channel they get by with 50
wrong in cancer you don't want four
percent of the people being wrongly
diagnosed
wrong diagnosis is of a major concern
because there can be people who have
cancer but we're not
predicted so in an imbalanced data set
accuracy should not be used as a
measurement performance
which of the following machine learning
algorithm can be used for inputting
missing values of both
categorical and continuous variables so
we have a couple choices here we have k
means clustering we have linear
regression we have the k
n n nearest neighbor and decision tree
in which of the following machine
learning algorithms can be used for
inputting
missing values of both categorical and
continuous variables
now certainly you can use some
pre-processing to do some of that but
you should have gone with the
k nearest neighbor because it can
compute the nearest neighbor and if it
doesn't have the value it just computes
the nearest neighbor based on all the
other
features where when you're dealing with
k-means clustering or linear regression
you need to do that in your
pre-processing
otherwise it'll crash decision trees
also although there's some variants on
that too
can you solve another riddle always fun
ones given a box of matches
and two ropes not necessarily identical
measure a period of 45 minutes
and in this particular setup the ropes
are not uniform in nature and the rope
takes exactly
60 minutes to completely burn out so
each rope takes up to 60 minutes to burn
out
and there's actually a couple different
solutions to this but let me go ahead
and one of the things is they're not
uniform in nature so even though they
take 60 minutes
anyways let's go ahead and see what they
did to solve it and then we can also
look at different options
we have two ropes a and b light a from
both ends
and b from one end okay when a is
finished burning we know that 30 minutes
have elapsed and b
has 30 minutes remaining now light the
other end of b
also so that the remaining part of b
will burn taking 15 minutes to burn
this we have gotten 30 plus 15 equals 45
minutes
excellent solution mine which i like
was to take one rope fold it in two so
we know it's a half hour
take the other rope fold it in four
places so we know that that one's 15
minutes and then you can just connect
the two and burn it straight across
i think they're trying to cover that by
saying they're not regular the ropes are
have some irregularities maybe that's
what they meant by that you couldn't do
something like that
that's my solution below are the eight
actual values of target variable
in the train file so we have a training
file not to be confused with the train
on the tracks we have zero zero zero one
one one one
what is the entropy of the target
variable
we mentioned earlier that you should
know your entropy and how to calculate
the entropy what is the entropy of the
target variable
so we have a couple options here we have
minus five over eight
logarithm of five over eight plus three
over eight logarithm of three over eight
okay let's just see where they got those
numbers from we have
uh one which is going to be five ones
and
three zeros and then we have a total of
eight
okay and then we have the option of five
which is number of ones five eight
logarithm of five eighths
plus three eighths logarithm of three 8
and we also have 3 8 logarithm of 5 8
plus 5 8 logarithm of 3 8
and then we kind of reverse those
numbers around and let's see what you're
going to get here which one did you
think it was
you should check the first one so what
is the entropy of the target
variable the key there is a target
variable
so we're looking at the target in this
case is going to be one usually that's
what you're looking for and so the
entropy of that one we want to subtract
out the entropy of the non-targeted
variable whoops i had that backwards we
want to we're looking at 0 so we want to
subtract out the 5 8 from there so 5 8
logarithm 5
8 or negative 5 8 logarithm 5 8 plus 3 8
logarithm 3
8. and they have the hint on the bottom
entropy equals i
of p of n so we have a negative p plus p
and n times the logarithm
base 2 of p over p plus n minus
the n over p plus n times logarithm 2 of
n over p
plus n we want to predict the
probability of death from heart disease
based on three risk factors
age gender and blood cholesterol level
what is the most appropriate algorithm
for this case
so we have three features and we want to
know the predictability of
death okay a little morbid there choose
a right algorithm do we want to use
logistic regression for this
linear regression k means clustering or
the appropriate
algorithm and if you selected logistic
regression
then you've probably got the right
answer linear regression remember deals
with
like you take your line and draw a line
through the data and of course you don't
necessarily have to use a straight line
there's other means for that but you're
dealing with a lot of numbers and
k-means means we're just going to
cluster objects together with the
logistic regression though you can mix
those things together in buckets so
really the logistic regression is what
you want to use in that model would be
the most
apt fit after studying the behavior of a
population
you have identified four specific
individual types who are valuable to
your study you would like to find all
users who are most
similar to each individual type which
algorithm is most appropriate for
this study certainly identifying census
and just about a lot of different
markets is common so
maybe they have a census or whatever it
means but let's take a look at some of
the different
algorithms we might use on this we have
k means clustering
linear regression association rules and
decision trees
and i'll give you a hint we're looking
for
grouping people together by similarities
and by four different similarities so
very specific
they gave you one of the values
specifically the k value
so k means clustering would be great for
this particular problem
you have run the association rules
algorithm on your data set
and the two rules banana apple is
associated with grape
and apple orange is associated with
grape have been found to be relevant
what else must be true so this would
change you to understand association
rules
you could picture in this particular one
you're going
shopping and you almost always see
somebody who has bananas they usually
have
grapes in their bag also and somebody
who has apples usually has grapes in
their bags
and then apples and oranges is also
associated with grapes and let's go and
take a look at that
and we have a couple different options
here first one is banana apple and grape
orange must be a frequent item set
not so much banana apples oranges must
be relevant rule
grape is common with banana apple must
be a relevant rule
and how about grape apple must be a
frequent item set
let's go back and take a look at that
and we notice that we have bananas
apples to grapes we have apple orange to
grape boy there's a lot of grapes and a
lot of apples in there
and so if you said the last one grape
and apple must be a frequent item set
then you got it correct your
organization has a website where
visitors
randomly receive one of two coupons it
is also possible that visitors to the
website will not receive a coupon you
have been asked to determine if offering
a coupon to visitors to your website has
any impact on their purchase decision
which analysis method should you use
and so let's go ahead and start by
giving you another hint and give you
some
limiting your selection we have a
one-way anova k means clustering
association rules and student
t test so obviously you should know what
each one of these means
but let's take a look at the question
again so you want to know which method
should you use to see if the coupons
valid for their purchase well we're not
clustering
and we're not associating things
together we want to know the end result
student t-test also drawing a little t
in boxes and
switch them around there's really only
one answer that works in here and that's
a one-way
anova in this video we will learn some
of the important questions that are
often asked in any data science
interview
we'll discuss questions related to
various aspects of data science such as
programming
sql mathematics statistics linear
algebra and probability
finally we'll get an idea about the top
machine learning and deep learning
interview questions that are frequently
asked in interviews
so let's begin our first question is
how do you get a list of all the keys in
a dictionary
now in python for data science data
structures play an important role to
store and manipulate data
dictionary is one such data structure
that is declared using curly braces
and they are written as key value pairs
you can see on the screen i have my
dictionary called d
and it is assigned using curly braces
now to get a list of all the keys in a
dictionary we use
the dot keys function now let me take
you to my jupyter notebook
so here is my jupyter notebook and you
can see my first cell
i have my dictionary defined so
the name of the dictionary is d and
it has the key values the keys are the
country names and the values are
the capitals of each country so i have
india and the capital is new delhi
then i have usa the capital is
washington
similarly i have spain madrid and we
have
germany and berlin now india
usa france spain all these are my keys
so to get the keys i'll use the dot keys
function
so i'll write my dictionary name that is
d
dot i'll give keys
close the brackets and hit shift enter
you can see these are the list of my
keys
in the dictionary d all right
okay now let's move to our next question
so our next question is what do you mean
by list comprehension in python
so list comprehensions are a sought and
easy way to define and create new lists
based on existing lists so suppose
you want to iterate through a list and
find all the even numbers in the list
you can either use a for loop and an if
condition as
shown here or you can write a list
comprehension to do it in one line of
code
you can see this is my list
comprehension
so let me show you both the ways
all right so here on my jupyter notebook
let me declare my list as
l equal to i'll pass in a few numbers
let's say
5 comma 12 10
we have 14 43
11 7
9 and let's see the last element in the
list is 6
all right let me run this list
okay now let me create an empty list
let's say list 1
and let this be an empty list with
square brackets
then i'll use the looping construct to
find the even elements in the list so
i'll write a for loop
called for item
in my list l
i'll give colon then i'll give my
condition
if item
percentage 2 is equal to equal to 0
which means if the remainder is 0 then
i'll append the items
to my empty list which is list1 so i'll
write
list1 dot append
and i'll pass in the argument my item
now let me go ahead and
print my list i'll write print
the final list
using a for loop
i'll give colon give a comma
and pass in my new list name which is
list1
now let's run this you can see
using this for loop and the if condition
i have got all the even elements in my
list
which was l you can see my original list
and 12 10 14 and 6 where all the even
numbers present in my list
now this task you can do it using list
comprehensions as well
so let me show you how to do that so i
have my list
defined let me just copy this here i'll
paste it
and now i'll create another variable
which is list 1 i'll write equal to
now here
using square brackets i'll write item
for item in
l and i'll give my if condition as if
item percentage 2
is equal to equal to 0
then i'll print my resultant list so
i'll write
print let's say
resultant list
using list comprehension
i'll give a colon then a comma and i'll
pass in my new list which is list1
so here whatever is there
in my square brackets is called the list
comprehension technique
let me just print this and i'll get the
same result
so these are my even numbers
all right so let's move to the third
question so our third question is
given a list of numbers find the squares
of the numbers
using the map function in python
now the map function calls the specified
function for each element of an iterable
and returns a result
so let me show you an example to find
out squares of a list of numbers using
the map function
okay so let's first define a function
called
square so i'm using my def keyword
and i'll pass in my user defined
function name as
square and i'll give my parameter as x
and i want to return
the square of x which is x
star x
all right and then let me define my
list of numbers so i'll
pass in a variable called num and let's
say i want to find the squares of
five numbers one two three comma four
comma
five here
i'll pass in another variable which will
store the resultant
list so i'll write num underscore
squared equal to
here i'll use my map function so map
function takes in two parameters
first it will take in the user defined
function name which is
square here and the list of numbers
which is num
i'll run a for loop i'll write for let
me just scroll down
i'll write for num in
num underscore squared
print num
so this is my map function so
it will map all the elements in the list
to
this function which is square i'll just
print it
you can see we have the list of squares
from the num list which has the elements
1 2 3 4 and 5.
now moving ahead coming to our fourth
question
the fourth question is on to write a
program that will filter out the numbers
divisible by
3 from a tuple using the lambda
functions
so lambda functions are anonymous
functions that are not defined by the
def keyword
in python so here you can see i have the
example
so this is a tuple i have defined and
using filter along with the lambda
function i am trying to find out the
numbers that are divisible by
3 and finally i am printing those
numbers
so let's do it on our jupiter notebook
all right so we are on the jupiter
notebook
so first i'll define a tuple
let's say the variable name is my
underscore
top which stands for my tuple and
using brackets i'll pass in my double
values
let's say 5 12 10
18 we have 43 9
7 11 and
let's say 6 so you can see
these are the numbers present in my
tuple
now i'll create
another variable called new tuple
and i'll use my tuple function
and inside the tuple function i'll use
the filter function that will filter out
only the values that are divisible by 3
and now i'll write my lambda function so
notice this clearly
how to use a lambda function i'll use
the keyword
lambda and then i'll pass in a variable
x now this
should consider only those values
that are divisible by 3 so i'll write x
percentage 3
should be equal to equal to 0
and
i'll give my tuple
as the variable here all right
now we have declared our lambda function
let's just go ahead and print my new
tuple which is new underscore tup
so here you can see i have my tuple
function
inside the tuple function i'll use my
filter function that will filter only
those values divisible by 3
and to filter those values i have used
my lambda function here and passed in my
original tuple which is my tuple
it's actually my tup so let's delete
the last two letters let's just go ahead
and print this
there you go you can see we have 12 18
9 and 6 are the only numbers that are
divisible by 3
from this tuple moving to the next
question
so our next question is how to create a
data frame from a dictionary
now to create a data frame from a
dictionary you can use the pandas
library
and the dot data frame function now
pandas is a popular library in python
that is used for data manipulation
so let me show you how you can create an
employee dictionary and then convert
that into a data frame
okay so here on my jupyter notebook let
me go ahead and import my pandas library
so i'll write import pandas as
pd and next
let's create my employee dictionary so
i'll write
emp which stands for employee and
and within curly braces i'll give my key
value pairs
so my first column would be the name of
the employee
and let's pass in a list of
employee names i'll write ami
let's say we have angela
the third employee's name let's say we
have samuel
and let danny be our
fourth employee i'll give a comma
now the second attribute in our
dictionary will be the age of the
employee
so my key would be age and
let's create a list of age values
i'm assigning random values to those
employee
age 30 and let's say 32
and let's create another
variable called city
here variable refers to the column name
of the data frame let's say ami is from
new york
then we have angela from chicago
let's say samuel is from boston
and we have danny
from let's say seattle
okay so if i run this i have my
employee dictionary created so if you
want to see the dictionary you can write
print
and pass the variable name which is emp
here
so this is my dictionary now to convert
this dictionary into a data frame you
can simply write
df and you can give the pandas library
as pd and use the data frame function
so i'll write data frame
and i'll pass in my dictionary name
which is emp here
let's run it okay so we have
successfully created our
data frame now let me just print the
data frame i'll write df
there you go you can see i have a nice
table here which is actually a data
frame here you can see the indices
and you can see our column names as name
age and city and these are the
values or the rows all right
now let's see the sixth question we have
so the question is what is the
difference between
loc and iloc in python
now as data scientists you would often
want to analyze a chunk of data and not
all the rows
in it so loc and iluc functions can help
you fetch specific rows and columns
from your data frame loc function
uses row or column labels to select and
slice data from a data frame
while iloc uses integer index to select
specific rows and columns
remember iloc stands for index location
i'll use a car data frame to show how
loc and iloc works
now on your screens you can see the data
frame
so it has a column called brand which
has different brand names such as ford
there's hyundai
tata mahindra there's maruti the sky
motors
then we have the year in which the car
was manufactured
we have the number of kilometers the car
has run
we have the city and the mileage the car
gives
so let me first create this data frame
on my jupyter notebook
okay so here on my notepad i have my
code written to create the data frame
that is car i'll just copy this code and
i'll
paste it to this cell
okay let me just run it if i go on top
you can see we have successfully created
our
car data frame now let me go ahead and
print this data frame so i'll write
print in brackets i'll give my
data frame scar let me run it
all right so here is my data frame
now suppose you want to see the data
from second row till the fifth row
for brand and city columns so you can
use the loc function
so i want my data from the second row
till the fifth row for
brand and city columns so let me show
you how to do that
so first i'll write my data frame name
that is car
and then i'll give my function as
loc and
within brackets i'll give my
row index values so i'll give from two
to five
which is second row to fifth row and
i'll give my column names as brand
you give a comma and my second column
which i want is
city so here i'm using the
labeled beast indexing let me just run
it
there you go you can see we have the
information available for
the second row third row fourth row and
the fifth row
all right similarly let's see one more
example for
index location based slicing
so suppose you want to see the data from
second
third and fourth row for year kilometers
and city columns so for that you can use
the iloc function
so i want the value for second
third and fourth row and the columns
that i want
are years kilometers and the city column
so for that i'll give my data frame name
as
car dot this time i'll use iloc
and within square brackets i'll
give my row values and
the column values now
one thing you should notice here is
if you use iloc python
will exclude the last index which is the
fifth row and similarly here it will
exclude the
last index from the column which is the
fourth column
if i run this you get the desired result
now let's see another example
let's say this time i want to print the
rows that have mileage
less than 25 for brand and city columns
so you can use a print function
and i'll pass in my data frame as car
and use loc here
i'll give my condition as
car and i want my condition that is
mileage
should be less than 25
and i want
the brand name so i'll use a square
bracket
and give my brand column
and i also want the city column
okay let me
close it if you run this
now these are the brand names renault
tata and kia which have
mileage less than 25 let me just verify
this
you can see all these values are less
than
25 similarly you can use the
iloc function as well
i can write print i'll give car dot
iloc within square brackets
i'll give car
and my condition column is mileage
now this should be less than 25
i'll use dot values
and then i'll give my
column numbers as 0 comma 2
let me run it there you go
the same result we have got it using
iloc function this time and you can see
the columns were 0 comma 2 which means
we wanted the first column which is
brand
and the second column which was
kilometers
all right now moving to our seventh
question
in the list of questions that we have
the question is how is list dot append
different from list dot extend
now list dot append adds its arguments
as a single element to the end of the
list
the length of the list increases by 1
here
and list dot extend iterates over its
arguments and adds each element to the
list
the length of the list increases by the
number of elements in its arguments
so let me show you the difference
on my jupyter notebook okay so let's
create a list called list 1
equal to i'll create a list let's say it
has some country names like
india then we have
usa and i'll consider one more
country let's say canada
okay now let me print the length of this
list also
i'll use the length function for that
all right now
let me append one more list so i'll use
the append function
i'll write list one dot append
and within
brackets i'll give my new list which has
two more country names let's say france
and spain
okay and here let me print
list 1 and let's also print the length
of the list
again i'll use the length function
and my list name which is list1
so just mark we are using append here
let me run this there you go
so here you can see my original list
had three elements since the length is
three now when i appended this
new list which had two elements france
and spain
our size increased by 1 and the length
of the new list is
4. now
let me just copy this code
and instead of append
let me write extend so that we can
see the difference between append and
extend
just scroll down run it
here you can see our original list had
three elements but after we extended our
list with two more elements the length
of the new list became five
so these are the five elements in the
list
and here you can see there were total
four elements in the list
when we appended the new list
okay now moving to our eighth question
suppose you have a car data set which
has a mileage column
you need to create a new field called
mlg
that will accept two values if mileage
is less than 25
then the value should be low mlg and if
the mileage is
greater than or equal to 25 then the
mileage should be
high mlg or the value should be high mlg
now while analyzing data data scientists
often need to create extra columns in
the data frame
to add more values that will help you
make your data analysis more efficient
so this question is related to one such
instance or one such idea
so here you can see my data set
it has the brand name year kilometers
city and the mileage column now if
mileage is less than
25 i'll add the value low mlg
to my new column else if mileage is
greater than or equal to 25
i'll add high mlg to my new column so
here you can see
my final output wherever the mileage is
less than 25
it should print low mlg else it should
print high mlg
and now let's do this on my jupyter
notebook
so we'll use lambda functions that we
learnt earlier to perform this task
i'll write a function let's say f is
equal to
you can call this as a function or a
variable
i'll give the keyword lambda
and use x as my
parameter x
should be low mlg
if x
is less than 25 which is mileage here
else if it's not less than 25 it should
return
high mlg
now what i'll do is
i'll give my data frame scar
and i'll create my new column that is
mlg
then i'll write equal to
car dot i'll give my
column name from the original data frame
which is mileage
and i use my apply function and pass in
the variable
f now let's just
print this data frame
if i run it you can see the output here
we have created a new column which is
mlg
you can see our new column name was mlg
and these are the results so
for renault tata and kia for the last
three rows since the mileage is less
than 25 it returned
low mlg for the remaining it gave us
high mlg
now moving to the ninth question so this
is our next question
we want to create a 4 cross 4 matrix and
find the sum of all the diagonal
elements in the matrix
data scientists often work with multiple
dimensional arrays or multi-dimensional
arrays
and matrices to build models this
question is related to an operation on a
4 cross 4 matrix
so first we need to create an array
which
will be a numpy array of 4 cross 4
shape and then we'll see how to
calculate the
diagonal elements or the sum of the
diagonal elements
so i am on my jupyter notebook first
let's import the numpy library so i'll
write
import numpy or numpy as np
let me run it okay now
i'll create my 4 cross 4 trick so i'll
write
m is equal to
np dot array
and i'll create my 4 cross 4
matrix let's say the values are 1 2
3 4 in the first row
and in the second row i'll pass 5 comma
6 comma 7 comma 8.
in the third row we'll have 9 10 and 11
also 12 and finally
we'll have 13
14 15 and 16.
the fourth row i'll just run it
now if i print m you can see
this is a four cross four matrix so
this is one way of creating a four cross
four matrix which is a bit tedious and
lengthy
instead of that you can also use a range
function
so if i write m is equal to np dot
a range function and here i'll give my
values
starting from 1 till
17 so this will actually exclude 17 and
take from 1 to 16
and i'll give my shape
as 4 comma 4
let me print it there you go
it has printed the exact same matrix
that we saw above
all right now to print the diagonal
elements we'll use the diagonal function
so i'll write print m dot
diagonal
let me just run it so 1
6 11 and 16 are my diagonal elements you
can see this matrix
1 6 11 and 16 are my diagonal elements
now to print the sum of all the diagonal
elements i'll use the sum function
so i'll write m dot diagonal
along with that i'll pass my sum
function
if i run it so the sum of 1
6 11 and 16 is 34.
okay so coming to the last question on
this interesting session on programming
interview questions for data scientists
our question is given a vehicle data
frame
find the average and maximum mileage of
the vehicles using pandas
so here data scientists use statistical
measures to analyze that data
so it is important to have knowledge of
the statistical functions in python
here is my vehicle data set and
for each brand of vehicle we want to
find the average and the maximum mileage
so let me show you how to do it
okay so here on the notepad i have my
code written
to create the vehicle data frame i'll
just copy it
and paste it on this cell
you can see we have the brand column the
year column kilometers
city mileage here you can see the
different
brand of vehicles let me just create
this data frame first
and let me go ahead and print the
vehicle data frame so i'll write
vehicle and run it so here is the data
frame
now i want to find the average and
maximum mileage for
each of the brands so for this
we'll use the group by function and the
aggregate function that is available in
the pandas library of python
so let me show you how to do it i'll
give
a variable called result
and then i'll use my data frame name as
vehicle
followed by the group by function
i'll write group by and since i want to
check for all the brands so i'll group
all the
brand of vehicles then
i'll use an aggregate function which is
a g g
and within curly braces i'll give
my column as mileage
i'll give a colon
and pass in mean which is for average
and i'll use max to find the maximum
mileage now let's
print it i'll write print
i'll give a message as the
average and maximum
mileage
of vehicles
let me just print the result
i'll run it
you can see it has resulted in an error
the reason is in vehicle the v is
capital now if i run it
there you go here you can see on the
left
we have the brand names we have hyundai
there's maruti and tata because those
were the only
three brand of vehicles we had and for
each brand you can see
the mean mileage and the maximum mileage
for maruti it was 26.33
and the maximum mileage is 28 similarly
you can see for
data vehicle as well sql is a widely
used language for querying data from
databases
it allows you to store retrieve
manipulate and update data present in
the form of rows and columns
data scientists often work with
structured data that is stored in mysql
databases
microsoft sql servers oracle databases
or even nosql databases such as mongodb
today we will look at a variety of sql
questions
we'll be using the mysql database for
our demo throughout the video we'll be
using mysql workbench
and the mysql command line to solve the
sql queries let me show you the database
that we will be using for this demo
and the tables we are going to use okay
so here i am on my sql workbench and
below you can see
i have a local instance created i'll
just click on it
now it's asking me to enter the password
i'll give my password
and hit ok now this will take me to
the sql editor now this is the sql
workbench
so let me first create a new
sql query file all right
so first and foremost let me show you
the databases we have for that i'll use
the command
so databases if i hit tab it will auto
complete
i'll give a semicolon and hit ctrl
enter to run this there you go
here you can see the list of databases
that we already have
and from the list of databases we are
going to use
the sql underscore iq database so
to use this database i'll write the
command
use sql underscore
iq i'll give a semicolon
i'll select this and i'll click on this
execute button if i run this
you can see now i'm using sql underscore
iq database
now if you want to see all the tables
present in sql underscore iq database
we'll use the following command so i'll
write show
tables now this will list all the tables
present inside
sql underscore iq database if i run it
you can see here it has executed
successfully and it has given us seven
rows which means we have a total of
seven tables
in this database you can see there's an
author table
there's a table called books we have
customers email
employee players and weather table so
all these tables we are going to use
in the course of this video now if you
want to
have a look at the data present in one
of the tables you can just use the
select statement so i'll write select
star from let's say i want to see
the data present inside the employee
table so i'll write
employee so this is my table name i give
a semicolon
if i select this hit the execute button
there you go it shows me
that it has returned six rows
and these are the column names we have
the name of the employee the age of the
employee
we have the employee's salary and the
employee id
so there are total six employees in the
table
all right now i can do the same
operations on my sql command line as
well
now let me open the command line first
okay so this is the mysql command line
client
it is asking me to enter the password so
i'll give my password first
all right now here you can see i have
come inside
my sequel now the operations that we
performed on
the mysql workbench the same operations
can be performed on the command line as
well
so i'll write use
sql underscore iq
i'll hit enter you can see the message
it says
database changed now if you want to
display the tables present inside this
database i can use
show tables command
i have to give a semicolon and hit enter
there you go you can see the list of
tables we have
inside the database now if you want to
have a look at the content of one of the
tables i can just write select star
from let's say players
if i give a semicolon hit enter you can
see
the rows and columns in the data set all
right
and with that let's move on to our first
question on sql
okay so our question is what is the
difference between where and having
clause in sql
so where clause is used to filter the
records based on the specified condition
while the having clause is used to
filter the records from
groups based on specified conditions you
need not worry we'll do the demo for
wherein having clause using the employee
table
so where clause cannot have aggregate
functions
such as count sum min or maximum
functions
having clause can operate on aggregate
functions
now where clause is implemented on rows
while having clauses implemented on
columns
now let me show you an example of how a
where clause is different from an having
clause
so i'll take you to my my sequel
workbench
all right so we are on the sql workbench
so suppose
i want to get the records of the
employees whose age is greater than 30
for this i can use a where clause so
since i want to get the employees whose
age is greater than 30 i'll use a where
clause i'll write my
sql query as select star
from employee where
i'll write age is greater than
30. if i give a semicolon
and run this
it will return all the employees whose
age is greater than 30 you can see 36
36 and 35.
these are the employees whose age is
greater than 30.
now i have intentionally kept some
duplicate rows because we are going to
use this in our next questions
again i can also do the same task using
the having clause
so let me just copy this query
i'll paste it here now instead of
where i'll write having
so you will see that even this query
will return the same result if i run it
you can see
it gives me the same result now
let's say i want to find all the records
where the count of age
for all the employees is greater than 1.
in this case
i can't use a where clause it will throw
me an error
since where clause cannot be used with
aggregate functions
so let's try using an aggregate function
in the where clause so i'll write select
star from
employee
where count of age
is greater than 1 so the idea is to find
all the records where the count of age
for all the employees is greater than 1.
so if i run this sql query you can see
it has given me an error it says invalid
use of
group function now
instead we need to use a having clause
along with the group by clause to solve
the problem
so i'll group all the age values and
then find the count of each each value
so let me just paste this
and here i'll edit my sql query
instead of where i'll write having
and just after the table name i'll use
the group by clause so i'll write group
by
each now let's run it
all right you can see our sql query has
returned
only those employees whose age occurs
more than once now let me just
verify this if i run my
employee table
you can see angela's age that is 36 has
has been repeated twice you can see
angela here as well and similarly we
have
mic also repeated
twice all right
now let's see the second question
now this is a multiple choice question
where you need to answer the correct sql
query based on the question
so the question is the correct sql query
to select all the records of employees
with ari in their names is
so we have a list of four options given
and out of that
you need to find the correct option now
the answer to this question is
this so if you write select star from
the table name which is employ here
where name like then if you give this
condition it will return
all the records where employees have ari
in their names
now like is an operator in sql that is
used to search a specified pattern
so here our pattern is we want all those
employees who have eri in their names
the first percentage means that the name
can have any number of letters in the
beginning
followed by eri in the middle and the
last percentage means
the name can have any number of letters
in the end so let's
do this on our my sequel workbench
let me first display all the employees
in the table so i'll write
select star from employee
i'll run this if you see my table
i have one employee who has ari in its
name and that person is kerin
i now want to get this particular record
so what i can do is i'll write a select
query
select star from
employee where name
then i'll use the like operator where
name like
within double quotes i'll give
percentage
eri again a percentage
close the double quotes and give a
semicolon if i run this
you can see my sql query will return
only karen
now let's do one more example
suppose i want to find the employee
whose name starts with
d so the way to do is
something similar to what we saw just
now
so here in my condition i'll just
replace this with d this means
the name should start with d and after
that
it can contain any number of letters now
let's run it
there you go so our table had one
employee
called danny whose name started with d
now moving to our third question
so the question is we want to write a
query to find the players
with the least number of goals so there
are two methods to do it
one where you can use a sub query
and the other method to use the limit
operator
so let me show you both the methods
first let me go ahead and display all
the tables present
in my database that is sql or sql
underscore iq
all right if i scroll down you can see
we have a table called players so i am
going to use
the players table to find the player
with the least number of goals
so let me show you the first method that
is by using a sub query
so i'll write select star
from my table name which is players
where goals equal to
and in this i'll write my sub query
using
brackets so i'll select
minimum goals
from the table that is players
i'll close the bracket and then
i'll give a semicolon now let me go
ahead and run this
you can see matt was the player from
scotland who scored
the least number of goals that is three
now
let's break it down so what we did was
first my sql query found out
what was the minimum goal scored by a
player
so if i run this you will see it will
return me 3
so 3 was the least number of goals
scored by one of the players
now in my outer query what sql did was
it searched for
those goals where the value was equal to
3
so we wrote select star from players
where goals equal to 3
hence if i run this
you will find the player who scored only
3 goals
and that player is matt alright
now the other way to do is using the
limit operator
so this is more simpler than the
previous method
i can write select star from
players order by
goals now let me first run
this sql statement if i run this
you can see we have ordered this
in ascending order so the person
who has scored the least number of goals
appears
at the top and the person with the or
the player with the highest number of
goals appears at the bottom
and from this table i only want the
first row
and for that i can use the limit
operator so if i write
limit 1 it will display only the first
row
if i run it you can see it shows me only
the record for matt moving ahead now
let's see the fourth question in our
list
the question is write the sql query to
find the player
with the second highest number of goals
now again there are two methods to do it
one is by using limit and offset and the
other method is to use a sub query
so let's see both the methods
i'll first write my sql query using
limit and offset
so my query will be
select star from
players order by
goals descending
let me just run this
all right so here you can see my table
has been ordered
in descending order of goals so anthony
has scored the most number of goals
then comes daniel followed by sam and
at the end we have matt who scored the
least number of goals
now out of this i want the player who
scored the second highest number of
goals
which is daniel so i want my sql query
to return
this row that has player id 103
name is daniel country is england and
goals is 7.
for that mysql has two features
so i can use limit 1
followed by offset 1
so what this query does is
it will offset one row that is it is
going to offset the first row
or it is going to skip the first row and
then print only the second row because i
have set my limit
to one so let me just run it
you will see we get the desired result
the player name is daniel and the number
of goals
scored is 7. now the other method to do
is
using a sub query now let me write my
sub query
first i'll write my outer query which is
select star
from and here i'll write my sub query
select star from
players order by
my column name which is goals in
descending order
here i'll limit it to 2
then i'll give my alias name as t
then i'll use order by
goals limit
one let me just run it first
if i run this you see here i get the
same result
now let's first break it down i'm going
to run
this sub query first so here i have
select star from players
order by goals descending
and limit is to let me just run it
so the selected sql query returns
the first two rows ordered by goals
and if you see here clearly
we have again ordered the value returned
in ascending order which means from this
table
if i order this table in ascending order
daniel should appear first
and out of that i am limiting my result
to
1 so it will print only daniel if i run
this again
you can see i have the desired output
now let's check
the fifth question in our list given the
below email table
write a sql query to find the distinct
domain names
from the email column so if you consider
this as my email
table the domain names are gmail.com
in and we have hotmail.com these are the
distinct
domain names now to solve this task
again we have two methods either you can
use the substring underscore index
function
or you can use the substring function
now the substring underscore index
function returns a substring of a given
string
before a specified number of delimiters
so let me first
use the first method okay
so here on my sql workbench i'll write
select i'll use
the keyword that is dextent then i'll
use my function which is
substring underscore index
here substring underscore index will
take three parameters
the first is the original column name
which is email
followed by the delimiter i'm looking
for that is at the rate
so i'll put at the rate with single
quotes since it is a
text or a character and then
i'll give the number of times to search
for the delimiter
here it is going to be -1
so you can either give a positive value
or a negative value
if it is a positive number then this
function will return
all to the left of the delimiter if it
is a negative
number the function returns all to the
right of the delimiter
all right and then i'll give an
alias name as say domain name
from my table that is email
if i run this
you can see i have the list of all
unique domain names or distinct domain
names that we saw in our table
this is one of the ways the other way is
to use the substring function
now the substring function extracts the
substring from a string
starting at any position so
let me write my sql query i'll write
select
dixtent
i'll then give my function as substring
here substring will take in two
parameters
the first parameter is the column name
which is email id here
so i'll write email i'll give a comma
next i want to find my delimiter so for
that
i am going to use another function
called locate and here i want to locate
the index position of
at the rate so i want to
give my delimiter as at the rate
followed by the column name which is
email
and then i want to fetch everything
after the delimiter and for that i am
giving plus one
again let me give a domain name as the
alias name from
email
if i run this you will see will get
all the unique domain names gmail
yahoodin and hotmail.com so these were
the two ways to
solve the same problem
now moving ahead let's look at our sixth
question
so our question is write the sql query
to find
duplicate records from a table without
using a temporary table
now one of the other variants of this
question is
to delete all the duplicate records from
a table without using a temporary table
now to solve such queries you can use
the group by and the having clause
let's look at how to do it
so here on my sql workbench i'll write
my select query as
select star
and then i want to count all the
duplicate values
let me give it an alias name as
frequency
from my table name which is employ here
and then i want to group by
name
having
count star
greater than 1 let me just run it all
right
you can see it has returned me two rows
the name is angela in mic
and the frequency is two let me just
verify this to see all the repeated
records
that were present in my employee table
so i'll write select star from
employee if i run this
and scroll down here you can see angela
is present
here as well as at the bottom
similarly we have mic present twice in
the table and hence
our sql query returned only angela and
mike
because they were repeated twice you can
see the frequency here so
let's now look at our seventh question
given the below employee table
i want to write a query to find all the
even and odd records from the table
so as you can see there are two ways to
do it
one is to use a sub query and another
you can use the mod function
so let me show you both the ways all
right
so let me run this sql query to see all
the values present in the employee table
so if you see the last column which is
the employee id column
has all the employee ids as
unique values so i am going to use this
in my where condition
so to find out all the even records
i'll write my sql query something like
this i'll write
select star from employee which is my
table name
where employee id
then i am going to give my in operator
and inside the in operator i am going to
write my sub query which is select
employee id from employee
where employee id
percentage 2 is equal to 0
this means wherever my employee id
is divisible by 2 it will return only
those records
so let me just run it there you go so
here we have easily fetched
only the even records from the table
similarly if you want to get only the
odd records from the table you can use
the mod function also
so i'll write select
star from employee
where here i am using the mod function
mod emp id
comma 2 is not equal to 0 so i'll use
the exclamation mark
is equal to 0 so if i run this
it will return only the odd employee ids
you can see it here so those were the
two ways in which you can fetch the even
and odd records from the table
now let's see our eighth question
so here is the question below is the
customer table
write a query to get the first purchase
of each customer
now if you look at the table there are
three customer ids
101 102 and 103.
now customer101 made its first purchase
on
2nd october 2018 which is this one
and customer 102 made its first purchase
on
5th of october 2018 and since we have
just one record for customer id 103
so this is going to be his or her first
purchase
so i want to return 101
phone 102 tablet and 103
books to do this
we are going to use an inner join
if you can see i have used an inner join
and
i've also used a sub query let's
write this query on my sql workbench
okay so this query is going to be a
little complicated
if you have any questions then please
put it in the chat section
we'll be happy to help you so i'll start
with select
i'm going to take an alias name as t dot
i'll write cust underscore id
comma t dot
purchased at
comma the next field i'm going to select
is t dot
item from
customers as
t next i am going to write my inner join
and inside the inner join i'll write my
sub query
it's going to be select customer id
comma i'm going to take the
minimum value from the purchased at
column which is
my date column
close this i'll give another alias as
min underscore
purchased underscore at
from my table name is customers
then i am going to group it by one
here one means the first column that you
have put in the select statement which
is customer ids so i am grouping by
customer id
i close the bracket and everything
i'm going to give an alias name as t1
now i'm going to join on t dot
customer id is equal to
t1 dot customer id
and my next condition would be
t dot purchased
at is equal to
t1 dot min underscore
purchased underscore
at i'll give a semicolon
i would request you to go through this
sql query in a
detailed manner so that you understand
it line by line
let me just run it now
if i run it okay it has
thrown me an error which says table sql
underscore iq customer
does not exist the reason is my table
name is customers
all right so let me run it once again
okay so there's one more error it says
unknown column
purchases ad so we had made a spelling
mistake here
it should be purchased at now let's try
and run it
all right there you go so for customer
id 101
the first purchase was made on 2nd of
october 2018
likewise for customer id 103 the first
purchase was made on 5th of october and
similarly for customer id 102
the first purchase was made on 5th of
october again
now moving to the 9th question so
here we have a weather table we want to
write an sql query to find all the date
ids with higher temperature
compared to its previous dates so if you
see
we have a date id column we have
the date and the temperature
using this table i want to find those
ids with higher temperature compared to
its previous states
so if you look for date id 1 the
temperature is 32
for data id 2 the temperature is 31. for
data id3 the temperature is
30.8 now if you clearly notice for date
id 4
the temperature is 31.5 which is
actually higher than the previous
date id which is 30.8 similarly for date
id5
the temperature is 33 which is again
higher than the previous date which is
31.5 now if you look at the date values
they start from 10th of march till 15th
of march 2020.
now to solve this query we are going to
use
sql joins again and i am going to use a
function called
to underscore days now my sequel to
underscore days function returns the
number of days between a given date
and year 0. so let's go ahead and write
this sql query
all right so first let me select
all the rows from the temperature table
which we are going to use
for this particular question
i'll run it
all right there's some error actually
the name of the table is weather
and not temperature so i'll write
weather
let me run it okay so here you can see
these are all the rows present in the
weather table
and as i explained i want to return only
the date id 4 and this date id which is
5.
now one thing i want to make it clear
here
that this date id should actually be 6
so there was a mistake while creating
the tables
please consider this data idea 6 and not
5
so i want to return data id4 and data
id5
alright so let me go ahead and write my
sql query
so i'll write select i'll write
a dot date underscore
id from
whether
as a comma
i'll join weather as
b where
a dot temperature
is greater than b dot
temperature
and i'll give my condition and
i'll use the function to underscore days
and give my value a dot date underscore
val is equal to
i'll use the function again 2 underscore
days
b dot date underscore
val plus 1
now i would like to know from our
viewers why have we used plus one in the
where condition
so please put your comments in the chat
section
let me just run it there you go so here
you can see
my sql query has returned the date id 4
and 5
which means these are the date ids where
the temperature was higher compared to
the previous dates
all right now coming to the last
question on this interesting session on
sql interview questions for data
scientists
so there are two tables one is the
authors table
and the other is the books table i want
to write an sql query to find the second
highest author who sold the most number
of books
now this is going to be my sql query
again we are going to use joins
on both tables author and books along
with
limit and offset operators so let me
show you how to do it
so first i'm going to join my author
table and the book table
so i'll write select a dot
author underscore name comma
i'm going to find the sum of
copies sold from the books table so i am
giving my alias name as
b dot copies underscore sold which is my
table name i'll given alias as
some underscore sold from
author as a
join books as
b on i'll write
b dot book underscore
name is equal to
a dot book underscore name
now i'm using book underscore name as my
criteria because book underscore name
is the common column to both the tables
then i'll use a group by clause
i'll write group by a dot
author name
then again i'm going to use an order by
clause i'll write order by
sum underscores hold and i'm going to
order it in
descending order so i'll write d esc
i'll set my limit as
1 and offset
as 1.
if i run this
you will find
that mysql query has thrown an error the
reason is we have used
a column called bull underscore name so
it should be
book underscore name there was an error
here
let me run it again
okay there was another small error this
would be
some underscore sold let's run it
there you go so my sql query has
returned
author 3 because
author 3 sold the second highest number
of books
now let me just remove the last
few lines in the script let me just run
it now
if i run this you can see
author 1 sold the highest number of
books followed by author 3 who sold the
second highest number of books
and then it was author 2 who sold the
least number of books so if i write
limit 1 and offset one
what this line of code will do is it
will skip the first row
and print the next row
so let's just run it
and you can see it has written me the
author who sold the second highest
number of books
in this video we'll be discussing some
of the top mathematics interview
questions for data science
these questions are based on various
topics in mathematics such as
statistics probability and linear
algebra so let's begin with our first
question
the first question we have is what is
normal distribution
now normal distribution is a probability
distribution that is used to check how
your data is distributed
your data could be spread out to the
left or to the right
but in many cases the data tends to be
around a central value with no bias left
or right
as you can see on your screens now this
is called a normal distribution
where half of the points are to the left
and another half of the points are to
the right of the center
now such a distribution this contributes
to 68 percent of the data falling within
one standard deviation of the mean then
we have
95 percent of the data falls within
second standard deviation of the mean
so if you add up 13.6 percent and the 68
percent
plus 13.6 percent this will result to 95
percent of data falling within two
standard deviations of the mean
and finally we have close to 99.7
percent of the data falling within three
standard deviations of the mean
so this is what a normal distribution is
all about
now moving on to the next question so
what are the different
measures that are used to summarize the
distribution
now to get more idea about the data and
summarize the distribution
you can use three types of statistical
measures the first we have
central tendency measures then we have
variation measures and finally we have
shape measures now under central
tendency measures we have mean median
and mode
now the mean is the most frequently used
measure
of central tendency in a data set let me
take you to the wikipedia page and
explain you
what mean exactly is
ok so here you can see on the wikipedia
page it has the formula to calculate
the mean of a distribution so this is
basically the summation of all the data
points divided by the total number of
data points
so here you can see an example we want
to find the arithmetic mean of 5 values
which are
will pick the fourth element from our
ordered set of points that is 6 here
and hence 6 is the median for this
ordered set of points
now if you have an even number of
observations
as you can see here total we have 8
observations
now the median becomes x n by 2 plus
x n by 2 plus 1 divided by 2.
so your median becomes the mean of the
middle two numbers that is
4 plus 5 by 2 which is 4.5
all right now the next statistical
measure we have under central tendency
is called
the mode so the mode is the most
frequently occurring value
in a set of data points so here you can
see an example
we have a set of data points 6 three
nine six six
five nine three so your mode is going to
be six here since
six is occurring thrice in the set of
data points
okay now under variation measures we
have
variance standard deviation and
interquartile range
so first look at what variance is so
variance is the average of the squared
differences from the mean now this is
the formula for
variance you can see x i represents
the individual set of data points and
mu represents the average value so mu is
nothing but the summation of all the
data points divided by the total number
of data points
so this is your formula for variance
next we have
standard deviation so standard deviation
is a measure of the amount of variation
or dispersion of a set of values
a low standard deviation suggests that
the values tend to be close to the mean
while a high standard deviation suggests
that the values are very spread out
now here you can see the formula for
variance now this is
denoted by sigma and
your standard deviation is nothing but
the square root of variance so here
you can see the formula for variance you
have x i minus
your mu square which is the mean of all
the data points
divided by n
then we have the interquartile range
which is also known as iqr so iqr is a
measure of variability
based on dividing a data set into
quartiles
so an interquartile range measures where
the bulk of values
lie so the formula for iqr
is q3 which is the third quartile minus
the first quartile
so here you can see we have a list of
data points
then we are ordering the data points
first
and then we cut the list into quarters
so first you have the
q1 then you have q2 and finally you have
q3
so for these set of data points
your iqr is going to be 7 minus 4 that
is
3 then
we have shape measures so under shape
measures we have skewness and
ketosis so skewness is a measure of
symmetry
your distribution is symmetric if it
looks the same
to the left and the right of a center
point
now they are majorly of two types one is
called
negative skew or which is also known as
left skew then we have positive skewed
or right skewed
and finally we have ketosis so kutosis
is a measure of the tailless of a
probability distribution
it defines how heavily the tails of a
distribution differ from the tails of a
normal distribution so if you consider
these distributions the kutosis will
calculate
the tailedness which is actually these
areas
of a distribution now let's look at a
third question
so the question is create a sparse
matrix in python
now in numerical analysis a sparse
matrix or a sparse array
is a matrix in which most of the
elements are zero now there are multiple
ways to create a sparse matrix
i'll show you two ways to create a
sparse matrix so let me take you to my
jupyter notebook
where i'll create a matrix first and
then we'll see how to create sparse
matrix out of it
so i am on my jupiter notebook here
first let me import the necessary
libraries
so first i am going to import numpy as
np and then from
scipy will import
sparse i'll run this cell
okay next let me go ahead and create a
matrix i'll use the np dot
array function and within this function
i'll create a
3 cross 3 matrix and i'll assign the
elements
so my first row will have 1 2 3
next we'll have 4 comma 5 comma 6
then we'll have
7 8 and 9
all right let me run this cell okay
now let me go ahead and
print my matrix so i'll use the print
function
and let's say i'll pass in a
message that is original matrix
comma and then pass in my variable name
that is matrix
let's run it so here you can see i have
my original matrix
it is a 3 cross three matrix and has
nine elements in it
first let's see how using dictionary of
keys
you can create a sparse matrix so for
that
i'll write the print statement and then
i'm going to use a function which is
called dok
that stands for dictionary of keys
underscore
matrix and i'll pass in my variable name
which is my original matrix so if i run
this
you can see i have got my dictionary of
keys sparse matrix
next i'll show you how using diagonal
storage paste
you can create a spot that i am going to
use another function
that is sparse dot dia
which stands for diagonal underscore
matrix
and within this function i'll pass in my
original matrix
variable name if i run this
you can see we have created diagonal
storage based
sparse matrix all right
now moving to the next question
so given below is a matrix
we need to find the inverse of this
matrix
now the inverse of a square matrix a
which is sometimes called as a
reciprocal matrix
is a matrix a inverse such that the dot
product of a and a inverse is always
i which is an identity matrix now in
numpy we have a function which you can
see here
that is np dot lin alg dot inv
that helps you find the inverse of a
matrix let me show you on the jupyter
notebook
first let me print my original matrix
all right now here i'll use the function
with min that is np dot
l-i-n-e-l-g dot inv which stands for
inverse
and then pass me my variable name
that is matrix if i run this you can see
i have got the inverse of my original
matrix
now moving to our fifth question so this
question is related to probability
you call 2 over x and 3 ellipse if the
time that
each takes to reach you is iid what is
the probability that all the lips arrive
first
next we want to find what is the
probability that all the uber x
arrive first now this is fairly a simple
question
first let's look at the lifts arrive
first
then first we need to find the
probability that the first car is a lift
which is going to be three by five since
we have three
lifts and total we have five
vehicles next we want to find the
probability that the second car is the
lift which is going to be
2 by 4 third we need to find the
probability that the third car
is also a lift which is 1 by 3 now
arrive first
is going to be the multiplication of the
product of
the above three probabilities that is
three by five into two by four
into one by three which is nothing but
one by ten
next let's say you want to find for all
the ubers that arrive first
so you need to find the probability that
the first car is uber
which is nothing but two by five since
we have two ubers
next the probability that the second car
is an uber is going to be
1 by 4 so the total probability that all
the ubers arrive first is going to be
the product of 2 by 5
and 1 by 4 which is also 1 by 10.
now moving to the 6th question the mean
median and mode of a distribution are
30 25 and 20 we need to determine if the
distribution plot will be positively
skewed or negatively skewed
so you can see from the distribution
graph the mean
is to the right median to the middle and
more
to the left so since the value of mode
is less than the mean and median the
data will be positively skewed
and similarly the skewness of the
distribution is on the left
if the mean value is less than the
median and the mode
occurs at the highest frequency of the
distribution
the next question we have is what are
covariance and correlation
so covariance and correlation are
measures that help you understand the
relationship between two continuous
variables
so covariance tells the direction of the
linear relationship between two random
variables
the direction means if the variables are
directly proportional or inversely
proportional to each other
so increasing the value of one variable
might have a positive or a negative
impact on the value of the other
variable
now covariance can take any value
between minus
infinity and plus infinity so below you
can see the formula to calculate the
covariance
so you have summation x i minus x bar
x bar or x dash here represents the mean
x i represents the individual points
then this is multiplied by
y i minus y dash or the mean of y
divided by the total number of
observations
next we have correlation so correlation
explains the
change in one variable leads to how much
proportion changes in the second
variable
correlation tells how strongly two
random variables are related to each
other
it takes values between minus one and
plus one
a negative correlation means they are
inversely proportional to each other
a positive correlation means they are
directly proportional to each other
if the correlation coefficient is zero
then there is no linear relationship
between the variables
so here below you can see the formula to
calculate the correlation
now moving to the eighth question
so what are the sampling methods used in
data science
now sampling is a statistical technique
that is used to
select manipulate and analyze a subset
of data points
and find patterns and trends in the
large data set been examined
now there are two types of sampling
methods
we have probability sampling and
non-probability sampling
now under probability sampling we have
something called as
random sampling so in random sampling
every individual is chosen entirely by
chance
and each member of the population has an
equal chance of being selected
then we have stratified sampling
so in stratified sampling subsets of the
population are created
based on a common factor and samples are
randomly collected from each other
now talking about systematic sampling so
in systematic sampling a sample is
created by setting an interval
at which to extract data from the larger
population
an example could be selecting every
fifth row in a spreadsheet of 100 items
and creating a sample size of 20 rows
for analysis
and finally under probability sampling
we have
cluster sampling so in a cluster
sampling subgroups of the population are
used as the sampling unit
rather than individuals so the
population is divided into clusters
and a whole cluster is randomly selected
to be included in the analysis
now let's look at the sampling methods
that are
present under non-probability sampling
so first we have
convenience sampling so for convenience
sampling
the samples are selected based on the
availability so this method is used when
the availability of samples is rare and
costly
so based on convenience samples are
selected
second we have quota sampling so quota
sampling depends
on some preset standard the proportion
of characteristics in sample
should be the same as the population
next we have purposive sampling
it is also known as judgmental sampling
you select members of sampling on the
basis of the objective of the study
it is very useful when you want to reach
a particular or targeted sample quickly
finally we have snowball sampling so the
snowball sampling technique is used in
situations where the population is
completely unknown and rare
now coming to the ninth question in our
list so explain what
p value tells about statistical
significance
so p value is a statistical test that is
used in hypothesis testing
it helps you to decide whether to accept
or reject the null hypothesis
the null hypothesis represented as h0
is a commonly accepted fact it is the
opposite of alternative hypothesis
researchers and scientists work to
reject or disapprove the null hypothesis
they come up with an alternative
hypothesis that they think explains a
phenomenon
and they work to reject the null
hypothesis for example
null hypothesis or h0 could be the world
is flat
and an alternative hypothesis could be
the world is round
so lower the p-value the greater the
statistical significance of the observed
difference
now the p-value is just one piece of
information you can use when deciding if
your null hypothesis is
true or not the p-value lies between 0
and
1 as you can see here the threshold for
p
is set to 0.05 when the value is below
0.05 the null hypothesis is rejected
now coming to the final question in our
list of
mathematics interview questions for data
science the question is
what do you understand by type 1 versus
type 2 error
now in statistical theory the idestical
error is an integral part of hypothesis
testing
in statistical hypothesis testing no
test is ever 100 certain
that's because we rely on probabilities
to experiment
even though hypothesis tests are meant
to be reliable there are two types
so type one error occurs when the null
hypothesis is true and we reject it
it is also known as a false positive
finding or conclusion
an example could be an innocent person
is convicted
and type 2 error occurs when the null
hypothesis is false and we accept it
it is also known as false negative
finding or conclusion
an example could be a guilty person is
not convicted
so here you can see we have a reality
where your null hypothesis is true
and here we have the null hypothesis is
false and this is where the type one
error
lies so this can also be represented as
false positive
where the null hypothesis is true and be
rejected and this could be
false negative where the null hypothesis
is in reality
it's false and we accept it in this
video
we will learn about some of the machine
learning and deep learning interview
questions
so let's begin with our first question
the first question is how to detect
outliers in data
so in data analytics and machine
learning you often find data points that
lie at an abnormal distance from other
points in a random sample
from a population those are called
outliers
now outliers in data can significantly
impact any prediction analysis
there are majorly three different
methods to treat outliers
first we have the univariate method it
is one of the simplest methods for
detecting outliers
the univariate method uses box plots a
box plot is a graphical display for
describing the distributions of the data
box plots use the median and the lower
and upper quartiles
this method looks for data points with
extreme values on one variable
next we have the multivariate method so
the multivariate outliers can be found
in an n-dimensional space having n
features
we look for unusual combinations of all
the variables in this method
finally we have minkowski error
this method reduces the contribution of
potential outliers in the training
process
the minkowski error is a loss index that
is more insensitive to outliers than the
standard mean squared error
now moving on to the second question
what is a confusion matrix
so a confusion matrix is a table that is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data
for which the true values are already
known the target variable has two values
positive or negative
the columns represent the actual values
of the target variable which you can see
here
the rows represent the predicted values
of the target variable
which you can see here now there are
four important
terms that are related to confusion
matrix first
we have true positive which is this one
so in true positive the predicted value
matches the actual value
so the actual value was positive and the
model also predicted a positive value
then we have true negative which is also
represented as
tn the true negative depicts the
predicted value matches the actual value
now the actual value was negative and
the model predicted a negative value
next we have false positive now false
positive is also known as
type 1 error in false positive the
predicted value was falsely predicted
the actual value was negative but the
model predicted a positive value
finally we have false negative the false
negative is also known as type 2 error
so in false negative the predicted value
was falsely predicted
the actual value was positive but the
model predicted a negative value
now moving to our third question which
is
explain the roc curve now the roc curve
is one of the most
important evaluation matrix for checking
the performance of any classification
model
roc stands for receiver operating
characteristic
receiver operating characteristic or roc
curve is a method to compare the
diagnostic tests
the roc curve was created by plotting
the true positive rate against the false
positive rate at various
threshold settings so here on the y-axis
you have the true positive rate
on the x-axis we have the false positive
rate the true positive rate indicates
the proportion of observations that were
correctly predicted to be positive
out of all positive observations
similarly
the false positive rate is the
proportion of observations that are
incorrectly predicted
to be positive out of all negative
observations
you can take an example suppose in
medical testing
the true positive rate is the rate in
which people are correctly identified to
test positive
for the disease in question let's say
the coronavirus testing
roc does not depend on any class
distribution
this makes it useful for evaluating
classifiers predicting rare events such
as diseases or disasters
now moving to the fourth question we
have what are the assumptions
for linear regression so linear
regression analysis is used for modeling
the relationship between a single
dependent variable y
and one or more feature or predictor
variables
some of the important assumptions for
linear regression are
so first they should have linearity
so linear regression needs the
relationship between the independent and
the dependent variables to be linear
it is also crucial to check for outliers
since linear regression is sensitive to
outlier effects
next we have homocydasticity
homoscedasticity
illustrates a situation in which the
error term that is
the noise or random disturbance in the
relationship between the features and
the target variable is the same across
all levels of the dependent variables
third we have independence so
observations should be independent of
each other
finally we have no multi-collinearity
so there should be little or no
multi-collinearity
independent variables should not be too
highly correlated
now moving to our fifth question in our
list of interview questions
the question is what is regularization
in machine learning
explain the l2 regularization
so regularization is a machine learning
technique that is used to reduce the
errors
by fitting the function appropriately on
the training set in order to avoid
overfitting of data
so overfitting happens when a model
learns the detail and noise in the
training data
to the extent that it negatively impacts
the performance of the model on new data
so here you can see we have a nice plot
which shows how overfitting of data can
be visualized
and here we have a good fit line over
the same data points
so this is also known as the regression
line
now l2 regularization is also known as
ridge regression
so ridge regression modifies the
overfitted model by adding the squared
magnitude of coefficient
as a penalty term to the loss function
so on the right
you can see a set of data points plotted
and we have our
linear regression line and here we are
calculating the cost function for the
ridge regression line
so our cost function is actually loss
plus
lambda into summation of w squared where
loss is actually the sum of squared
errors
or squared residuals lambda stands for
penalty for the errors
w is called the slope of the curve or
line okay
now consider a case where there are two
points
passing through the linear regression
line now if you calculate the cost
function
we get the value as 1.69 so here we have
assumed that loss is zero since the two
points
lie directly on the line we have taken
lambda to be one
and w is one point three so if you use
this function
or this formula you get the cost
function as one point
six nine now moving ahead
let's consider another situation where
we'll calculate the same cost function
for the
ridge regression line there is some loss
for both the points as they are not
on the same line so here you can see the
sum of squared residuals
is 0.05 is actually is the sum of 0.2
square i'm assuming this as
0.2 and 0.1 for this one
so if you square both and add it the
value is
0.05 and lambda is again 1 and w
we have assumed to be 0.6 now if you
find the cost function the value is
0.41 let's draw the linear regression
line and the ridge regression line with
all the points
we find that the ridge regression line
as the best fit
since its cost function is less now
coming to the
sixth question what are the different
methods to split
a tree in a decision tree algorithm
so there are three methods to split a
decision tree
first we have variance so reduction in
variance is an algorithm that is used
for continuous target variables
this algorithm uses the standard formula
of variance to choose the best split
so here you can see the standard formula
variance which is summation of
x that is all the individual points
minus
x bar which is the mean squared divided
by the total number of observations
now the split with lower variance is
selected as the criteria to split the
population
now the steps to calculate variances you
need to calculate variance for each node
and then you need to calculate for each
split as the
weighted average of each node variance
moving ahead the second method we have
is information gain
so information gain is used for
splitting the nodes when the target
variable is categorical
it works on the concept of entropy now
the degree of disorganization in a
system is known as entropy
so here you can see the formula for
information gain which is
1 minus entropy finally we have
gini impurity so gini impurity is the
probability of incorrectly classifying a
randomly chosen element
in the data set if it were randomly
labeled according to the class
distribution in the data set
so below you can see the formula for
gene impurity
so we have 1 minus summation of p i
whole square where n represents the
number of classes
and p of 5 represents the probability of
randomly picking an element of class i
now moving to the seventh question
so the question is how do we find the
optimum cluster value in k-means
clustering algorithm
now there are two methods to find the
optimum cluster value
so first we have the elbow method which
is one of the most well known for
finding the
optimum number of clusters so in this
method you need to calculate the
within cluster sum of squared errors for
different values of k
and choose the k for which within
cluster sum of squared errors
first starts to diminish so in the below
plot of squared errors versus the number
of clusters k
you can see at k is equal to 4 the
squared error starts to diminish so
hence
our optimum k value is 4.
next we have the silhouette method
so the silhouette method measures how
similar a point is to its own cluster
compared to other clusters the average
siloid method computes
the average steroid of observations for
different values of key
the optimum number of clusters k is the
one that maximizes the average solid
over a
range of possible values for k the
soloid score reaches
its global maximum at the optimal k so
in our case
the average siloid reaches maximum at
key is equal to 2 which you can see here
so our optimum cluster value will be 2
here
moving ahead the 8th question in our
list is
how does the pooling layer work in a
convolutional neural network
so the pooling layer performs a down
sampling operation in order to reduce
the
dimensionality of the feature map so in
the pooling operation
you slide a two dimensional filter over
each channel of feature map and
summarize the features lying within the
region covered by the filter
it is a common practice to periodically
insert a pulling layer in between
successive convolutional layers in a
convolutional neural network
architecture
so the pooling layer operates
independently on every depth slice
in the input and resizes it spatially
using the max operation so in the
diagram shown here you can see
we have a rectified feature map
we are using a 2 cross 2 filter and
performing a max pooling operation
so consider this as the filter if you
perform the max operation over the
values let's say
0 5 3 and 1. so considering this one our
pool
feature map maximum value will be 5.
similarly for this chunk of data it is
going to be seven
next if you slide the filter over this
square frame
you get eight and similarly here you get
six so this is also known as a
pooled feature map moving ahead
the ninth question in our list is how
does lstm network work
so long short-term memory networks are a
type of recurrent neural networks
that are capable of learning order
dependence and sequence prediction
problems
so remembering information for long
periods of time is practically their
default behavior
now lstms also have this chain like
structure which you can see here
but the repeating module has a different
structure so instead of having a single
neural network layer
there are four interacting in a very
special way
now you can see these are called as
gates these gates contain sigmoid
activations
a sigmoid activation is similar to the
tanning activation
instead of squishing values between
minus 1 and plus 1
it squeezes values between 0 and 1
and ls dm has 4 gates
now these are called forget remember
learn
and use or output so if you see this in
the first step
we use the forget gate that decides what
information should be thrown away or
kept
the information from the previous hidden
state and the information from the
current input is passed through the
sigmoid function
values come out between 0 and 1.
so if the value is closer to 0 it means
you need to forget that information
and if the value is closer to 1 it means
you need to keep that information
next we have the input gate so the input
gate is used to update the cell state
first we pass the previous hidden state
and the current input
into a sigmoid function that decides
which values will be updated by
transforming the values
to be between 0 and 1. 0 means not
important and 1 means important
you also pass the hidden state and
current input into the tanh function to
flatten the values between -1 and plus
1.
this helps to regulate the network then
you multiply the tanh
output with the sigmoid output the
sigmoid output will decide
which information is important to keep
from the 10h output
and finally in step 3 we have the output
gate
this output gate is used to decide what
the next hidden state should be
first we pass the previous hidden state
and the current input into a sigmoid
function
then we pass the newly modified cell
state into the tanh function
we then multiply the tanh output with
the sigmoid output to decide what
information the hidden sheet
should carry the output is the hidden
state
the new cell state and the new hidden
state is then carried over to the next
time step
finally talking about the last question
in our list of interview questions we
have
explained the concept of gradient
descent in deep learning
now gradient descent is an optimization
algorithm which is mainly used to find
the
minimum of a function in machine
learning gradient descent is used to
update the parameters
in a model parameters can vary according
to the algorithm such as
coefficients in linear regression and
weights in neural networks
you can see we have these maps and
on the y-axis we have the loss
on the x-axis we have the weight and
here
we are trying to find the local minimum
or the global minimum
now this gradient decent method is used
to minimize the cost function and update
the parameters of the learning model
the gradient always points in the
direction of the steepest
increase in the loss function the
gradient descent algorithm takes a step
in the direction of the negative
gradient in order to reduce the loss as
quickly as possible
to determine the next point along the
loss function curve
the gradient descent algorithm adds some
fraction of the gradient's magnitude to
the starting point
now this process is repeated to find the
global minimum
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on data scientist full
course
i hope it was useful and informative
thank you for watching stay safe and
keep learning